[Music]
oh for
oh
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
is
n
[Music]
is
I
[Music]
e
oh e
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh for
oh
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
is
e
[Music]
St
hello everyone good morning thank you
for being here uh I know it's early and
you guys probably went out last night so
you guys are the real ones for coming to
the first talk uh my name is Rodrigo I'm
going to be the MC at stage six today um
I'm the e ecosystem funding lead at the
ethereum foundation um here from
Colorado um and yeah excited to uh
present some of the speakers we have
today uh before we start um few items uh
if you guys need to use the rest rooms
uh it's around the corner to the right
beyond the booths uh please exit quietly
uh if you want to take pictures or
record any of the wonderful talks that
we have today uh you're welcome to do so
but please do so without Flash
and if you'd like to ask any questions
to the speaker U we have a system called
mircat um if you used it yesterday uh
there will be a QR code and you can also
access it uh through the Devcon app uh
our first talk today is uh from Niara at
safe uh she's a technical product
manager working on account abstraction
Dev tooling uh the talk is on the
Butterfly Effects and paradoxes of
account abstraction in
defi so everyone if you could please
welcome theara to the
[Applause]
[Music]
stage GM everyone today I'm going to be
talking about the Butterfly Effects and
paradoxes of account abstraction in
defi imagine this in in 2018 Unis swap
introduced the automated Market making
model a smart contract that runs
billions of dollars of
transactions daily this single
Innovation became like a Cornerstone of
defi setting off a chain reaction of new
protocols in defi Lego blocks in form of
composability and that's essentially the
butterfly effect in action incremental
technological decisions leading to
massive ripples across the entire
ecosystem let's fast forward to today we
stand at another edge of transformative
shift account abstraction on the surface
AE might just seem like a technical
optimization another EIP another EIC but
beneath that there lies a potential to
reshape how users actually interact with
these T5 protocols from simplified
wallet experiences to seamless gas
management
AA can remove some of the most
frustrating Dy challenges that plague
the ecosystem today however as with any
transformation Innovation AA brings its
own set of challenges and paradoxes how
do we improve security without
compromising on the usability how do we
ensure
decentralization while seamlessly
offering web tool like
ux and how do we Foster innovation
without fragmenting the ecosystem system
I'm Niha and I'm going to be uh I'm I
work with safe as a technical product
manager and I'm building AA Dev tooling
to build more secure onchain apps if
you're interested in this topic I'd be
happy to chat with you later so let's
navigate The Butterfly Effects and
paradoxes in the defi realm before
everything else let me quickly explain
the concept of Butterfly
Effects this concept comes from the
chaos theory
famously illustrated by the idea that
butterfly flapping its wing in one part
of the world can set off a hurricane in
another part of the world at its core it
demonstrates how very small or
insignificant changes can lead to large
unpredictable outcomes over time and
this concept is not just limited to
abstract mathematics or weather
conditions it's deeply relevant in the
technological space especially with defi
as the system is vastly interconnected
and small Innovations or decisions can
Cascade into massive systemwide
changes now let's take an example in the
tech history about the Cordy keyboard in
the late 19th century the Cordy keyboard
was designed to prevent typewriters from
jamming by spreading apart frequently
used characters it was a very small and
a practical mechanical decision made at
that time and fast forward to today
quity is actually the most dominant
keyboard layout globally influencing how
billions of people interact with
computers and mobile devices daily and
that small local decision in the 19th
century has rippled across centuries
shaping modern digital
communication and now if I allude back
to the amm model of UNIS
here's how the Butterfly Effects come
into the picture Unis swap introduced
the amm model to enable swapping without
relying on order books to match buyers
as well as Sellers and they use a simple
formula to uh facilitate these trades in
the liquidity pools at its core it's a
simple equation x * y equals K where X
and Y are two quantities two tokens of
the same value in a pool and K is a
constant that remains unchanged and in a
nutshell here how it works the liquidity
providers deposit the two tokens into a
smart contract which is the pool and the
Traders can swap between these tokens
directly from the pool paying a small
incentive fee to the lp
providers and why is it transformative
three reasons one accessibility anybody
can become a liquidity provider that
democratizes the liquidity provisioning
efficiency amm eliminate the need for
complex order books and it reduces the
barriers for decentralized trading third
composability protocols can very easily
integrate Unis swap into their own
ecosystems which enables many swapping
or liquidity
strategies so the incremental change
that we see with Unis swop was that in
2018 the M model was introduced removing
the need for aut books in an exchange
and here's the ripple effect so now we
have amm model and anybody can provide
liquidity which democratizes liquidity
and after that it it made dexes to be
more Central to Defi and inspiring more
and more dexes to come up like curve
balancer or sushi swap which cater to
very specific use cases like stable coin
swapping or multi-asset pools and as a
result anybody can provide liquidity
which democratizes liquidity and after
that it it made dexes to be more Central
to Defi and inspiring more and more
dexes to come up like curve balancer or
sushi swap which cater to very specific
use cases like stable coin swapping or
multi-asset pools and as a result
billions of dollars started flowing
through these contracts which resulted
ccts which resulted ccts which resulted
ccts which dollar started flowing
through in which account abstraction
actually hits the hammer on its nail
they can be very simple onboarding to a
wallet experience in case a user
experience in case a user is locked out
of their account there are social
recovery mechanisms or multiactor
authentications baked in having the
native gas token on the Chain users can
also bundle multiple transactions into
one simple transaction for for example
for swapping for approving and this is
also quite gas
efficient security features like uh
setting daily spending limits or session
keys will become a standard and this
significantly reduces the risk of losing
funds or falling victim to a malicious
contract and cross chain and Layer Two
compatibility cross-chain interactions
can be abstract Ed users interact with
dii protocols without needing to
manually Bridge the assets or even be
aware of the underlying Network account
abstraction is not just about solving
these us ux frictions it's about truly
unlocking the potential of defi it
Bridges the gap between web 3 and web 2
to offer more intuitive more secure
experiences so that many more non-native
crypto users can participate in defi
with ease and
confidence now I want to give you a real
world example of how innovation in defi
is causing ripples in the world today
poly Market is a decentralized
prediction Market which has taken the
World by storm because of the recent US
presidential elections something that's
not talked about enough is that poly
Market use is safe in its architecture
if you read on polygon poly Market's use
of safe in its architecture is a
critical component to its ux strategy
and security by leveraging proxy wallets
and maintaining a non-custodial approach
poly Market ensures that its users have
control over their funds while still
benefiting from enhanced functionality
and the security that safe offers and
here I would like to take a look at some
numbers so far poly Market has created
about
420,000 saves
and the number of transactions that went
through
oopsy sorry about that and the number of
transactions that went through safe on
poly Market were about 1.6 million which
is approximately 3.7 transactions per
account quite sticky enough for web 3
and finally so far the betting volume on
polyon uh on poly Market is 5.7 billion
and as we see it the smallest
Innovations in account abstraction like
easy onboarding experience can set off a
Cascade of transformative events in defi
Innovations like account abstraction are
not just a technical upgrade they're a
catalyst for a future where Finance
becomes more accessible more secure and
more
efficient while these numbers are quite
optimistic addressing defi gives rise to
several challenges and paradoxes where
solving one problem creates new problems
or it reveals conflicting priorities
let's take a look at
them the first Paradox is of security
versus convenience this highlights the
tension between making systems that are
most secure and ensuring that they
remain convenient for the users to use
and striking the right balance between
the two is the key to Great user
experience one of the advantages of
account abstraction is its ability to
provide Advanced security features such
as multisig wallets social recovery me
mechanisms and these features enhance
the security of user assets by reducing
the risks associated with the private
key loss however adding extra steps or
extra layers of security comes at a
great expense of convenience for
instance in a multisig wallet it
requires several parties to sign off a
transaction before it hits the chain or
with social recovery mechanism is Ms it
is designed to involve several trusted
parties which requires some coordination
and forethought and while these features
make accounts more secure they also
introduce friction in day-to-day
use the second Paradox that I want to
talk about is customization versus
standardization while account
abstraction offers great level of
flexibility to users to Define their own
account behavior and this includes
custom uh trans transaction logic as
promised by ERC
7579 or automated workflows users can
create account personas that fit to
their needs for either trading
strategies or rebalancing portfolios or
just to hold assets however with
increased customization comes the risk
of fragmentation and standardization is
very critical to ensure that different
wallets protocols Services they work
seamlessly together and everybody can
create their own com custom account
behaviors and the risk of
incompatibility with different protocols
or apps grows and this Paradox centers
around challenges of offering enough
customization to meet the needs of the
user while maintaining enough
standardization to ensure
interoperability and what if I tell you
there was a way to transcend these
paradoxes and this is where AI agents
intents come into the
picture intents are a fundamental shift
in how users interact with defi uh
decentralized systems instead of
micromanaging every single transaction
the user simply expresses their desired
outcome whether it's swapping tokens or
executing a yield farming strategy these
are all high level goals that can be
abstracted away while interacting with
multiple
protocols and the where this is where AI
agents also kick in these intelligent
agents can interpret users intents and
navigate decentralized
ecosystems and optimize the outcomes
autonomously and imagine an AI system
where it's continuously monitoring
several different liquidity pools
without any kind of human
intervention in a in essence like
intense and AI agents they resolve the
very paradoxes that we discussed in the
previous slides and have the potential
to set off a ripple effect in defi to
another
level there are two use cases that I'd
like to discuss here an AI agent can be
used in decentralized trading for
example the user expresses the intent to
maximize profits by grid trading
strategy where token X and Y should be
within a price range of $100 to
$120 the workflow would look like this
the agent would be constantly monitoring
the price of X and Y in several
different pools and as soon as the price
in the grid hits to the lower level of
100 or 105 it places buy orders and as
soon as it hits a higher range it places
sell orders and this would be occurring
in a gas efficient manner potentially
potentially transaction badges because
there are several token involved which
can save gas and the outcome is that the
user achieves their desired profit
targets without needing to manually
track or execute these
trades the final use case that I want to
talk about is with poly Market the user
might Express an intent to maximize
returns by betting on most likely
outcome of the US presidential election
to reallocate funds based on real time
changes in the probabilities and here's
how it would look like with the workflow
so the AI agent would be constantly
monitoring offchain data news reports or
social media sentiments and it defines
some probability estimates bet can be
placed on the highest expected value
based on the current odds and the
transaction costs and if new data
suggest a shift in probabilities between
different candidates then the AI agent
would dynamically reallocate the funds
to a more favorable outcome and as a
result the US can the you user can
actually maximize their potential
earnings while minimizing risk without
needing to interfere manually because AI
agent would just take care of of uh
readjusting the portfolio and in this
Essence we see how the future of web3
can look like where decentralized
systems become more intuitive and
automated and AA provides the
programmable infrastructure and AI
agents
provide in uh user intents to be read in
a more intelligent Manner and together
they can Empower users to interact with
defi in a more smarter and a more
accessible way
and with this I want to close by saying
that whether you're a user a developer
or a product leader your actions today
could spark the next wave of innovation
and let's Embrace this responsibility
and continue building a decentralized
future one small flap at a time and the
question I want to pose to you today is
that what what small decisions will you
make today that will shape D5 for
tomorrow and with this I close my talk
I'd be hanging at the a community Hub
later today and happy to chat with
you thank you for the amazing talk um
now I think we have the the most
interesting part is uh we can have uh
questions from the audience uh if you
guys haven't logged in to mircat you
still have a few minutes to do so but
why don't we start with the first
question uh with the most upvotes
how how do we safely nav navigate
through quickly changing account
abstraction environment 4337 seems
already
deprecated okay um I do not agree that
4337 is deprecated it's rather getting
upgraded with new entry points and
there's more standards that are coming
into the picture for example
7702 which enables EAS to perform or
make themselves better as smart
contracts
and then the last question what do you
think about the emphasis the web3
community puts on Technical Solutions
for ux issues what other things do you
think are required for the ux to truly
improve
so of course like from a technical
perspective we saw that there are
several issues that do plague the dii
industry but also culturally I think
defi has not performed the best that it
has been in the news for several
scandals several scams and there has to
occur a mind shift that defi can
actually truly change people's lives and
there I think technology would kind of
fail and it's more about the vision that
we're working towards and making sure
that the vision that we're working
towards is incline or in line with what
we're doing dayto day it should not be
that we are only so deep into technology
that we forget about the end use and
it's only about over
engineering all right think that's it
can we get a final round of applause for
a wonderful
[Music]
speaker we have
another yeah we have another uh talk
starting in about 8 minutes on uh data
ownership from Rachel um so if you guys
are interested in that please stick
around
[Music]
I
oh
[Music]
ch
okay cool minute okay minute
[Music]
okay
hello
everyone thank you for coming today I'm
Rodrigo I'll be your MC uh am the
ecosystem funding lead at the ethereum
foundation um few quick things before we
begin we have uh bathrooms to the right
around the corner um we also encourage
you to take videos and photos but please
do so without Flash uh most importantly
uh we have a Q&A system um that uses
mircat the QR code will be over on the
screen in the bottom right hand corner
please uh do so when this talk begins
you can ask questions throughout the
talk and you can also vote on other
people's questions so even if you don't
intend on asking a question feel free to
log in and vote on other people's
questions I think it makes the session
really cool and interactive uh our
session today is from Rachel at privacy
and scaling Explorations uh she is
working on cursive they have a booth
they are working on ZK solutions to
human connection uh please go check out
their Booth today uh as a reminder the
booths will change over tomorrow so go
if there's booths that are open today
please go see them today um so please
welcome Rachel uh her talk is on
uh oh God I I forgot the name of the
talk
um
[Music]
okay all right hey
everyone I want to start with a little
poll of the room
so uh can you raise your hand if you
ever opened a social app to connect with
a friend that was your intention only to
get lost in some content that you can't
look away
from okay yes so relatable
experience um maybe even this week while
you were in changai you meant to check
in with a friend send them or sorry
we're in Bangkok
now um you meant to check in with
friends send them photos of your trip um
but you you got
busy catching up on important
content and maybe you're thinking yeah
Rachel that's ads based social media
it's for dopamine hits and you're not
wrong but here's the thing these
platforms were built on a promise of
bringing people
together many still claim human
connection as their core Mission so
today I want to examine this discon
for those of us genuinely seeking
meaningful relationships through these
social apps are they actually helping us
achieve that and more importantly how
does our lack of data ownership
undermine our ability to truly
connect let me take you back a little
bit before um I was a designer I had my
fair share of rage over government
websites and Healthcare portals that
made it really hard to be an informed
law-abiding citizen and when I learned
about the field of ux I was giddy over
this idea
that uh Services could actually be
improved to the point of making it
easier for people to do hard
tasks uh I couldn't wait to start honing
this
craft and when going into the field I
think um a lot of us are introduced to
this book that gets recommended as
essential reading uh called don't make
me
think it's filled with a lot of amazing
principles for removing friction for
users so that they can achieve their
goals and um while many public service
applications um at least in the states
are still decades behind by usability
standards social media apps have nailed
these
principles um they're so easy easy that
you're served exactly what you like
before you even have to think about what
you want from the
app but my question is when does easy
become too easy when do thoughtfully
crafted ux principles cross the line
from enabling to
exploitative what happens when
frictionless design and our surrendered
data serve profit rather than
people when social apps makes us feel
good for at least some of the time we
often end up entrusting a lot of our
personal data to these centralized
systems but that convenience to entrust
others to custody manage and use our
data introduces some additional
vulnerabilities the cost can come in
different forms like losing sentimental
things we thought were were permanently
ours uh or potential genuine connections
with other humans lost um if we get if
our accounts get hacked or uh we get
banned for maybe unjust
reasons
um so
yeah imagine losing all of these things
um but perhaps most
relevant right now is uh what if we lose
genuine quality time with the people
that we care about um to and as a Devcon
attendee this might be old news for some
of you but for the average consumer it
may not be obvious that the companies
will use our behavioral and
informational data to bait us into
opening their app and keeping it open
longer to maximize the number of
eyeballs on ads and I believe all of
these costs are making us feel less
connected to the people we actually want
to connect
to I think it's really important to
remember that designing for usability
isn't as simple as ease of use it's
about designing systems that help users
actually achieve their
goals there was this time when I
believed these popular social apps could
be a place to connect and it always
felt strange that these connections
happened publicly by riding on each
other's walls or that all of my
interests were broadcast to all of my
friends remember exactly when it clicked
for me that the promise of connection
here was an empty one so when this ad
ran in 2020 to that claimed personalized
ads by helping us fit in and be happier
been deleted from
YouTube so I don't know maybe they
realized they couldn't convince users
that buying things would make them feel
less empty
inside and
while we see now the return to human
connection rhetoric externally
you'll find a focus on content
consumption if you look a little deeper
I thought I would find empowering users
in a lot of designers bios uh with a
quick search but the focus um seems to
be
ower primarily on empowering creators
creators of
content the goal is getting more people
creating more content that keeps folks
on the apps longer the user desire for a
genuine human connection remains
unmet
so what happens when we flip the script
when we put data back in users
hands genuine connection becomes more
than just website
copy let's examine this through the
three pillars of usability effect
Effectiveness efficiency and
safety and I want you to like do some
thought exercises with
me what might it feel like to use a more
effective social
app that helps us you know go back to
achieving that goal of connecting with
other
people maybe we reconsider the don't
make me think philosophy
instead of algorithmic suggestions that
keep us scrolling past our bed times
imagine apps that aren't trying to
hijack our
attention imagine no more for you page
bombarding you with content the moment
you open the app to message a friend
instead you see tools for intentional
connection you not an algorithm decide
what connections would be meaningful you
choose what to share when to share it
and who sees it by utilizing your
private portable social
graph now let's consider efficiency when
we own our data could we more
efficiently connect with other
users instead of broadcasting
information
perhaps we would narrow cast
it what if instead of putting your life
on display by posting and liking on
public
Pages you could in intentionally connect
with specific
people by only revealing your private
data to those who meet certain match
criteria almost like putting digital
pheromones out into the
ether you might do this to find friends
who share your
interests connect with mentors who
complement your
skills discover people in your community
with similar or differing
perspectives or discreetly signal that
you're open to new work
opportunities only if they meet certain
requirements lastly how might safety be
enhanced when users own their
data uh I like to think about these
three varieties of safety for users
there's uh technical social and
psychological from a technical
standpoint safety can increase for us
users when Builders commit to using
open-source code for encrypting user
data instead of saying trust us they say
verify imagine being able to control
what you share with who go back to
that and the feeling of social safety
that that might bring if we had even
more control over this process than we
currently
do and now put yourself in the future
when these applications have been
refined through many
iterations by awesome builders that are
in this
community um lots of user testing has
been
done and you have full control over
defining the experiences you want to
have utilizing your
data imagine the psychological safety
that might bring if the expectations
remain
consistent and remain consistently
met this isn't just theoretical it's ux
principles in
practice instead of optimizing
for purely engagement metrics we're
optimizing for actual human
connection when we own our data we're
free to connect on our own terms not
through the lens
of uh what's most profitable for the
platform so now picture yourself opening
a social app and actually connecting
with a friend instead of getting lost in
a feed designed to keep you
scrolling to me that's the promise of us
user owned data where technology
enhances our
relationships instead of competing with
them at cursive we're experimenting with
these
ideas you can get an NFC chip at our
booth on the first floor to start
building your own private portable
social graph to make uh MPC queries over
um so you can do you can try out some of
these examples that I gave in the
presentation where you add your things
that you're interested in um ways that
you want to connect with people
and while our servers don't see the data
you're adding um we're running this cool
cryptography that um if you do have a
match over private data with another
person
um on the app you'll uh be notified and
connected um there's a lot of design
challenges in this space I think they're
really fun to think through and I am
excited to meet people who um are
excited to talk through these
challenges um I would love to invite all
of you to join us in redefining
usability for an era of data ownership
because I believe authentic connection
is worth designing
for our work is
um funded by privacy and scaling
Explorations who I've been with for the
past three years um they have an we have
an impact Booth right out here in the
hallway so you can check out more of
this open- Source tooling that makes
um app experiences like the cursive one
possible
um thank you so
much thank you for a super interesting
talk um yeah uh think we we have a few
questions uh from the audience the first
one besides cursive can you give classic
or future use case or examples what are
current projects that meet the ux and
decentralized
ownership um that's something honestly
that like I want to learn more about so
if you have ideas um please share them
with me because like doing
more comparative research and testing
these tools is a really important part
of like all of us
improving the next question ads are a
way of supporting and paying for
services how should Builders and
designers balance businesses with
usability yeah this is a great
question um and I think like we're in
this privileged position that I think is
like so valuable um you know that this
work
is funded in the way that it is so that
we can run these experiments um and like
I I think that there is some learning to
be had and the
discovery like to the answer to that
question will come uh through like
through trial and error and testing um I
think a lot of these ideas felt like uh
pipe dreams a year ago like oh it' be
crazy if we could do this if we could
actually put this into production and
like the only reason
that like everyone here can even try the
app that is in production now is from
like
so many cycles of um testing these like
Advanced cryptography in
production um so
yeah I don't know if I have the answer
to that question at this time but I
think that this Builder and experiment
phase is really
important
uh here's some related questions but
this one's a bit different can you talk
about the underlying consent models
baked into C
cursive I
um really want to
encourage everyone who's interested in
more of the like technical aspects of
this like you know
I'm really brushing the surface to go to
Vivic talk at um 3:30 today um because
he's going to be talking he's going to
be getting
into um how we achieve what is going on
um in the app that you can experience
um ads are a way of supporting and
paying for services how should Builders
and designers balance business needs
with
usability so okay this is something I'm
excited to yeah explore if you want to
talk about it like come find me cuz I
want to try and understand this better
but like
um when I was kind of looking at my maps
of things for this talk it's
like we have in the classic models with
ads
users
um the application company and then
advertisers so like you're optimizing
for uh that relationship between the
advertisers and the business but like
what if I don't know you can remove that
party are there
uh I wanted to check the question but
it's gone are there ways
like uh to try and balance those things
I mean I think that like you know
less like paid Services is one route to
explore um another question right now
users already have the option to control
whom their data is shared with on
Facebook people don't bother to go into
those settings and change them how will
this would be different with web
3 um I think that you know there is this
feeling of like nobody cares no one
cares about
privacy um But as time goes on I see
more and more um people in my life like
caring but it's not until they actually
experience the consequences that I kind
of like you know dug into a little bit
in this presentation to give like some
personal
examples
um that have made my friends like stop
and like think about how they're
managing their privacy and their
thinking about conceptualizing data
ownership um one of my friends got her
Facebook hacked and she lost all of her
photos like that was where every photo
from like our middle school high school
college was stored and um like feeling
that Collective loss of all of these
memories in a friend group um I don't
know hit everyone as like this isn't
ours this isn't this person's um so I
think it will I think we'll see it
change over time and people wanting more
more
optionality uh we have I think we have
time for one more question um Love The
Talk have you considered that without
the attention economy social apps might
not be sticky enough to onboard enough
people to actually feel
useful yeah I definitely think that um
this is a valid concern and I think you
know I'm interested in
exploring
like what is useful what utility could
we bring to people and
um one thing that's been on my mind is
like maybe it's not
about
uh maximizing the time you're on the app
and
spending like making your Connections in
it maybe it's just about like the
starting point of realizing oh there's
someone in this room that I could have
like a really cool conversation with if
I just have some amount of
awareness that we're we're both here um
so I'm like trying to conceptualize this
different relationship with the
applications we're using where it's not
like so much I'm in my hotel room and
I'm um you know sending messages to
catch up it's more like uh in the moment
how can it change the experience exp I'm
having in a community in a space in a
group I think we're running out of time
for questions but if if anybody else uh
has a question they can go to the
cursive booth and I I think uh Rachel
will be there to answer them later today
yeah and lots of other amazing teammates
who are helping build this experience so
if we can give a final round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry
speak
[Music]
speaker title right only that
hello everyone thank you for coming I'm
Rodrigo with the ethereum foundation um
just a few quick reminders uh the
bathrooms are around the corner beyond
the booths to the right um if you are
taking any videos or photos please do so
without Flash um we will have uh Q&A
questions through mircat please scan the
QR code that will be in the lower right
hand corner of the screen um even if you
don't plan on asking a question you can
vote on other people's questions and
decide which is the most important
question to be answered uh our talk
today is on the
uh wallet and ux stack to build uh web
three applications for the masses our
presenter is nich kesson Pat she's a
researcher at 1kx uh please everybody
give a round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone um great to see you here um
yeah so my name's nich uh I'll be
talking about the wallet and ux stack
today um to build applications for the
masses um I'm a uh researcher at 1kx on
the investment side focused on
middleware and what do we mean by
middleware why did we you know see this
as an investable um sector is because we
asked ourselves the question what
accelerates Innovation and adoption in
web 3 right and so the two things that
does this is one smart contract
developer tooling that improves the
developer experience and two it's wallet
infrastructure that um helps us improve
the web3 user experience um so we'll be
talking about how these two things have
evolved over the past few years and why
it's there's no better time now to build
um a web 3 application than
today um so let's take talk about Dev
tools um if you look at uh what the
developer experience was like to build
on ethereum from 2016 till now back in
2016 you had to run and maintain your
own node you have to write your own
token contract there was no you know
erc20 there was no token standards for
you to just import you have to implement
your own wallet connector so you know be
opinionated about the wallets that uh
users have to download and use to in
order to connect to your application and
then you have to Wrangle with really raw
onchain data and basically be an expert
in um blockchain like how the protocol
Works before you even get to implement
your application right today thanks to
all these uh tools the time taken has
gone from to for you to deploy your app
has gone from hours to days to literally
minutes um and you know you can come in
as a a web 2 developer and pretty much
get started right away uh uh building
applications on web
3 so um if you look at how web 2
developer tools removes the barrier to
Innovation and the impact this had in
the mid 2000 you had the the Advent of
uh cloud computing right which democ
democratized uh access to to powerful
Hardware so people who are building
websites didn't have to think about
running their own servers anymore to
connect to the internet and this
unlocked you know the wave of early web
2 apps Netflix Myspace and so on and
then you had apid driven development
that allows you to um connect to third
party uh databases and do programmatic
data reads and writes so you don't have
to implement your um you know every
service in house from scratch so if you
look at things like plaid this uh
payments rails allowed uh fintech apps
like venmo and Robin Hood and shopy to
be to be built then you have development
Frameworks allow you to uh reuse
pre-written code and you know scaffold
performance and responsive web apps be
uh without without having to start it
from scratch and in web 2 this this took
over two decades to get to where we are
today for the experience um to to get to
where it is today for the 14 million um
JavaScript developers that are out there
compared to you know the tens of
thousands of uh of of uh blockchain
devs um so in web 3 we've seen new
abstractions and and Dev tools improve
the developer experience as well from
you know the first icos and ethereum
launching in 2015 to um you know uh
infura and and consensus metam maso on
allowing devs to Outsource the node
infra so people don't have to run their
own nodes anymore to token standards you
know trle ganach if people have were
developing uh developing daps in 201 uh
16 remember those um uh scaffolding
Frameworks and you know uh protocol apis
like chain link the graph allowing you
to read from the blockchain without
having to Wrangle with uh with low-level
uh blockchain data um continuing to
today we had early def5 Primitives in um
2019 with things like a uh Unis swap
allowing you to scaffold and compose on
these open defi protocols and build on
these uh dexes and build uh more and
more um subsequently complex
applications so things like you know
Foundry launching getting easier to
build and test um and now like over the
past two years we had account
abstraction Technologies which we'll go
into uh more deeply in a little in a
little bit that completely changes and
flips um the user onboarding Journey
onto web 3 on its head right um
it's even getting easier to navigate
docs so uh you know developers are going
to a website and learning what like what
it is that a protocol does now ai tools
are allowing um you know chat GPT like
interfaces for for you to uh learn about
learn about how to get started on uh a
Dev tool right
away um so if we think about how users
have onboarded onto web 3 in the past
the most successful um crypto businesses
have been centralized exchanges
right um people on board onto binance
coinbase okx and they just stay there
and they you know never kind of funnel
into the self custodial stock and then
use dos um and the most successful self-
custodia dos have been these exchange
owned wallets because they're like the
most defensible top of funnel for people
to go in um and then you have things
like portfolio trackers which is like
just a small percentage of people who
are uh on board onto like binance and so
on so why is this right because it's
because exchanges have been the best at
helping users achieve a very common goal
for entering uh cryptos so far which is
buying and trading and holding tokens
and the usability of uh exchanges is you
know pretty much topof the line uh right
you have the familiar email based
onboarding seedless Fiat on- ramping
it's gas abstracted it's chain
abstracted there's been you know there's
a lot of uh talk on you know chain
obstruction and account obstruction
centralized exchanges have been you know
uh offering this uh experience from the
the beginning but then what makes a user
then funnel down this the the the line
onto onto self custody and daps right
it's lucrative onchain opportunities
that aren't offered by these exchanges
so this uh has differed for each cycle
you know we had defi summer back in 2020
we had uh nft Mania uh and then we had
you know ordinals we had mem coins uh
you know uh right now and like Point
farming and
airdrops so the opportunity for daps uh
to be built um you know you can you can
use account obstruction and wallet
infrastructure to onboard users into
your application right away without
having to uh require them to go to a
centralized exchange and or even um
download uh Standalone wallets so here
we have like a few examples of daps um
uh onboarding without without you know
like going through centralized
exchanges but the technology that allows
you to do so are is wallet
infrastructure right if you look at how
you interact with daps to even make
before you even make your first
transaction back in uh 2018 you see this
uh confusing um you know wallet selector
screen where the user has to navigate
out of your dap download a separate
application that they don't know on
board to a centralized exchange to get
gas top it up with their wallet before
they even you know get to connect and
like interact with application nowadays
with um embedded wallets and onboarding
sdks you're creating embedded Wallets on
on behalf of the users um and you know
without having uh to uh make them
navigate out um to a to a third party
app and also you know the the wallet is
created on the user's behalf
directly and this is this is like a a
very very meaningful change right uh
this is an exer from coinbase's Q3 uh
investor report um ever since they
implemented the uh their smart Wallet
account abstraction wallet in their daps
the daps onboarding time has reduced
from what was 2 and a half hours before
the user made their first transactions
to8 minutes and when you compare it to
web2 adaps this is kind of web two
applications this is still kind of
average right but you know it's a a
drastic improvement from how you would
um how users would uh interact with
their DBS um just from a few years
ago and so every layer of the wallet
stack removes um user friction and
points of churn right so you have key
management and signers um allowing users
to uh do signature abstraction and and
interact with um each chain without
having to be chain aware and do uh SE
lless onboarding through their emails
and familiar web 2 logins to Smart
accounts right uh where you can do
really scoped you can really scope out
the security features of your wallet and
do things like recovery multiactor and
sub accounts uh to account modules um
this is a an emergent sort of uh
development pattern we've seen where the
the users or the daps can install a like
a a a normal a regular smart account
wallet but then subsequently extend on
the features through modules that are
being built by third party developers so
the wallets are now becoming more like
developer platforms where you can
install these features um without having
to uh like onboard onto another
wallet um to creativity and
communication you know helping you do
things like transaction bashing where
you don't have to um where you can do do
multiple transactions uh in one click
and also permissioning and session keys
where you don't where you don't have to
like do con uh confirmations with every
interaction that you do on
chain um some things that we're seeing
on Horizon are things like
personalization
that um allows wallets to um uh give
notifications to users alerting them of
things that they can do onchain
personalized to what they've done before
right so this is things like available
nft mints um uh art uh collections that
they can do quests that uh they're
eligible for um and these things are
very useful for uh improving retention
and um improving the uh sort of
transacting users on wallets
um to things like policy expression uh
prerequisites on who and how you want to
interact with onchain protocols uh to
things like chain abstraction this is
aggregating your liquidity across
multiple chains and it just helps you
know uh helps us being uh like removing
the requirement of being chain aware in
this multi-chain sort of multi- layer 2
uh Universe um to things like data
Pipeline and warehousing to to make more
performant
deps um if you look at the
uh adoption of smart accounts you know
with there's been um a lot of discussion
about 4337 and account obstruction here
it's it's grown it's grown pretty uh
fair over the past year and a half or so
uh after the entry point contract launch
but what's really exciting that's on the
horizon is uh something called EIP
772 right um so uh if you look at the
account abstraction sort of 4 337
adoption relative to the hypee that it
created last year uh it could be a
little bit underwhelming sometimes but
this is because 4337 requires daps to
sort of um deploy new accounts for new
users and it's very very high friction
for users with existing eoas to migrate
their assets and their identity to a new
wallet right and the daps have existing
EA users already there's like little
incentive for them to do that but with
uh which is coming in q1 uh next year it
allows EAS to deploy code um to the
address and upgrade itself to a Smart
account um so then users can experience
the benefits of account abstraction uh
which are primarily gas sponsorship uh
transaction uh batching pass keys and uh
we think that the top wallets will
likely implement this but um require
users to opt in instead of enabling it
by default because this still doesn't
sub subvert the the pass keys and Seed
Freight risk of uh of EAS so you still
need you know actual like native account
abstraction for for that to happen but
it also can improve improve security via
session keys right
um yeah so we think users will opt into
this if they want to use a Dap or
feature that requires AA
features um and embedded wallets will
actually uh play a key role in this
because it allows it puts this decision
on developers instead of users uh
without waiting for uh yeah users to
enable 7702 for their Standalone
wallets um yeah so in summary you know
all of these abstractions both on the
devx and ux side uh increase the pace of
innovation and adoption better smart
contract developer tooling um increases
devx more developers more applications
and then wallet infrastructure uh
enables better user experience um better
apps and hopefully more users
and yeah that's the that's the talk um
happy to answer any
[Applause]
questions I think we have one question
so far um you guys still have time to
submit questions if we can do so quickly
uh the first one is what is your thought
on the kind of chaotic standards and
implementations of account abstraction
combined with the friction of L2 in
ethereum
um the chaot I'm not sure I understand
the question I I don't think I
understand either
um uh if we have any other questions or
if whoever asked the question uh wants
to
elaborate what do you think would be the
end game of onchain experience and how
are are we from
there um yeah so if you think about when
you're using a Dap today um and the
amount of time you're spending doing
things other than using the DAP so for
example like right now if I'm if I want
to use if want if I want to use like an
nft um you know art um marketplace right
historically I have to download a wallet
and and top it up with gas and if it's
on the wrong chain I have to migrate and
so on so that's like not helping me
achieve my goal of buying nfts right I
think think the the
endgame the end game is reducing the
amount of time that I'm that I have to
like work like think about blockchain
stuff uh versus using the DAP is uh as
little as
possible how do you think the hardware
wallet ecosystem anything you are
interested I'm going to mark that as
answered um the the hardware wallet I
don't think Hardware wallets are going
to go away uh um it's you know like our
Hardware wallet um is definitely found
PNF with users who wants to keep their
assets super safe but things like uh
smart accounts and and multi signature
wallets I think is something that um I'm
most excited about because with Hardware
wallets like if you lose that then
that's still a single point of failure
right I think Hardware wallets are uh
great as signers to something like a
like a safe
um what is a good way to onboard very
schedu dap users who want to hold either
zero or very tiny amounts of crypto that
need low to medium level security and
upgrade the security as the balance
grows I think onboarding sdks and
embedded wallets are a great solution
for this um so embedded wallets um to
the user they come up as these models
that allows you to either sign up or log
into the DAP with their emails they
create a wallet on their behalf and
right now embedded wallets are very
powerful uh a very powerful player in
the market because they can aggregate
different products and services like
Fiat onramps um swaps um uh off ramps
and and things like that so so um and
you can also sponsor gas for the users
as well so the gas sponsoring on L2 has
become a user acquisition cost now for
adaps because uh gas is low enough for
you to just uh do that on behalf of
users and allow them to do make the
first transactions so I think um yeah
that's an easy way for you to uh that's
an easy way for you to onboard casual
users um and you you're seeing now like
different chains offering um gas
subsidies for dap developers to build on
their chain and use their uh Services uh
if you're Building on Base for example
they have their smart wallet their
onchain kit and they have their pay
masters as well I think like giving away
around 30k in in gas credits um for you
to build on them so yeah there's a lot
of optionality as a that you have as a
ad user can you give a good example of a
smart account implementation to raise
the penetration of a web 3
game
um uh I I think this so smart account
implementations are pretty agnostic in
terms of what what types of use cases
they they enable
um but there are so gaming gaming
develop er uh platforms for example that
have uh uh Dev tools for you to scaffold
your game like nft marketplaces and and
embedded wallets have these um embedded
wallet Solutions on on behalf of their
platform so I look into those I think
this is a good one uh what
customizations could l2s do to reach ux
endgame faster than
L1 so we're starting to see specialized
l2s now um versus generalized um so by
General Iz versus specialized I'm
talking about uh things that came out
you know 2020 2021 like optimism
arbitrum uh and so on um that's kind of
doing a wide blanket of the uh the types
of daps that they want to be built on
their ecosystem but now we have consumer
Focus layer twos like abstract uh which
is built by the py penguin team that is
specifically focused on consumer apps so
this comes with everything from uh comes
with everything from native account
abstraction to gas sponsorships to
embedded wallets and you know uh that
optimizes for the types of apps that you
want to build for consumers so I'd look
uh into things like um yeah abstract
chain is there any possibility to help
user navigating through daps more
safely um yeah so a lot of wallets now
are uh going away from the blind signing
pattern where users are signing things
and they actually don't know what it is
um to you know uh having a clear and
verified uh human readable like
information that pops up that allows a
user to to be really aware of what it is
that they're signing
for um and then yeah there was a there's
some like uh small tools like fire which
I think was is now um Cerberus that
warns you if a Dap that you're
interacting with is um is is dangerous
or malicious or not um so yeah there's
these like Registries of trusted
contracts that you can install within
wallets or within your browser
extensions to uh to to do like a double
check what standard do you think will
get the lowest friction in the years to
come uh
St the lowest friction I I
mean I mean with 7 702 I think it's uh
it's like a like a step forward from
4337 right because 4337 you still have
to
um deploy a new
wallet what are your thoughts on
differentiating wallet types or
front-end experiences for users g a
wallet that a wallet address is like a
bank account number for many which
increases
friction um yeah so uh there's a few
like identity protocols that allow you
to have different addresses mapped to a
human readable name um
so like these you know things like ens
and things like clusters which allows
you to have aliases on different chains
and that maps to a wallet um would
improve the user experience a lot
because yeah I don't think uh addresses
are are that meaningful to the to the
vast majority of users whereas I can
just say you know niche. eth um and have
people send tokens to me
there how do we solve the fact that
embedded wallets are siloed to the app
where they are created is that really
web
3 um so the DAP specific the DAP
specificy uh specifity and um The Silo
the siloed issue wasn't an issue in the
past but um things uh projects like
capsule and privy are have now launched
uh Global wallet embedded wallet
features where if you
create uh a wallet within one dap you
can sign in with the same login and that
wallet will be imported to another dap
so this was this was an issue in the
past but um the invented wallet
providers um are launching or have
launched these features uh in the past
few
months since web 3 daps tend not to
analyze user events via tools like mix
panel entry Etc this does affect user
experience is there a web 3 alternative
to conduct user analytics while sticking
to web3
ethos um the r tool the r tools for for
for dap analytics like uh Telemetry
performance um uh showing showing the
DAP developers analytics of like where
the users are dropping off but this is
quite nent um it's it's offered at a A
Primitive level I I Believe by things
like Alchemy and uh there's a few
there's a few um web3 analytics
protocols that are starting to do that
but since things since a lot of things
are on chain um the the DAP developers
are being Savvy and kind of doing these
analytics themselves cuz they're I think
we haven't reached the scale where
developers are willing to pay for for
these tools um in terms of like the the
revenue they're generating from their
deps
um so yeah we haven't seen sophisticated
analytics tools yet what about ux and a
and account extraction Beyond
evm yeah so I think um yeah uh so you uh
the concept of AA is very evm sort of
centric right Solana has a different
completely different account model where
this uh account abstraction features are
baked in from scratch and you can have
um other parties natively pay for your
gas so for some like non evm uh sort of
chains this is kind of a moot point
because it's natively baked into their
to their uh protocols which is what
ethereum t uh aims to do with Native
account
abstraction how do we do away with seed
phrases and private keys can an
alternative be
secure yeah so that's what Native
account abstraction aims to do right uh
we want the smart accounts to be the
default thing uh we want users to be
able to sign with any keys that they
want like pass Keys um social login um
email addresses Hardware wallets and so
on um the alternative is so why the
alternative is more secure is because
it's removing this central point of
failure right the point of removing seed
phrases is removing this point of
failure and having like redundancy in
terms of like what keys can be used to
move assets out of your account um and
then you can scope the different uh
permissions or capabilities based on
each of these Keys uh so yeah that's why
smart accounts where you can install
where you can have features like multi
signature and session Keys uh and
Recovery uh we want to make that the
default way that people interact on
chain that's uh all the time that we
have for questions right now um thanks
you guys for asking a ton of questions a
lot of questions yeah if um if they want
to ask questions is there anywhere that
they can reach out to you
after yes
um I think can I go back to the
slide well you can just find me around
here okay like yeah U but can we give a
final round of applause for niche
thank
[Applause]
you if you guys enjoyed this talk we
have a uh panel on wallet ux that I
think you guys will also enjoy uh that
will start uh in about 3 minutes
[Music]
oh
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today we have a panel on wallet ux uh we
had a few last minute changes to the
lineup um but please welcome uh Derek
rain uh the host Hester Brookman Eric
galansky and Lucas
Shore and yeah
[Music]
GM who's
awake okay we got a few people who are
awake that's amazing yeah welcome to the
wallet ux panel let's maybe before we
get to the speakers let's get to the
audience who thinks wallet ux is amazing
today who thinks it could be
better okay who think thinks it's
terrible right the next question um
before we get to the intros who here
knows what fire blocks
is who here has used fire
blocks oh right on who knows what safe
wallet is who's used safe
wallet and who has heard about
metamask all right that's um that's a
good amount um skip the last question
all right let's get uh to the intros I'm
so thrilled to be here I think uh my
name's Derek I'll get to my intro last
but I think wallet ux and ux and evbm is
really one of the biggest challenges and
we have the most amazing crowd here to
discuss that today so I'm more I'm very
thrilled to introduce ariq Lucas and
Hester and aric why don't you give a
quick intro about you and fire blocks
sure thanks D I guess ladies first but
um yeah so uh I'm Eric um and I work for
fire blocks uh it's great that some
people here actually actually know fire
blocks in a lot of situations were're a
bit behind the scenes um if some of you
for example uh use revolute or you use
uh if anybody here played Off the Grid
that's been exploding recently uh so
like like the biggest web three game
ever uh so like those kind of a lot of
times when you use something that uses
the blockchain behind the scenes um fire
blocks will be there basically uh in
payments in stable coins that you might
be using and even if you're just doing
uh trading the other party a lot of
times will be fire blocks based uh we
basically provide a wallet uh and other
infrastructures for companies that are
building blockchains based products um
and uh yeah that's that's on my
side Lucas yeah everyone um I'm Lucas
I'm with safe um yeah what we do is we
build cont
infrastructure uh we're coming from this
perspective of like with eum with like
new technology uh as it's always the
case uh it has a lot of potential uh but
this potential is locked in the
beginning because it might be expensive
it might be uh very technical hard to
use it may be um just not accessible for
for different audiences and for us while
the potential is there with like defi
Financial inclusion with new kinds of
coordin
mechanisms like we still far away from
actually having this potential fully
unlocked and we see account abstraction
as a key accelerator to making that
happen uh so smart accounts can really
level up uh the user experience and the
security and all of that for interacting
with ethereum as a technology uh and
that's what we've been doing for the
last I don't know six seven years uh
still some some time to go but like I
think we made some good progress
so hi everyone uh I'm Hester uh I'm
standing in for a colleague actually
Adam uh who can join um I'm a product
manager at metamask uh on a team called
wallet ux don't kill me
um we do what we can uh no so a little
bit more context uh wallet ux is a team
that coordinates is responsible for
bringing different units uh together uh
features accounts worked on by a variety
of teams and we try and uh bring that
together in in what uh what is to be a
cohesive cohesive easy to use experience
so if we introduce different account
types more contract account types uh
we'd work on how do we actually
introduce those in your importing flows
in your account selection um same for uh
settings and discovery of other features
so um yeah I think that's a little bit
about me and I'm very happy to join
these gentlemen here um I love that joke
um so
yeah my name is Derek I work for a
company called reown we used to be
called wallet connect and many of you
have probably interacted with wallet
connect thanks for using the product
okay so first question let's do a little
bit of a I'll start with a little bit of
a hot take so I'll claim that a count
abstraction actually failed um some data
for that is trust and okx were the main
consumer wallets that actually launched
account abstraction but in okx wallet
they you can't sign up anymore so so
yeah what do you think about that that
account abstraction completely
fail I think we're partially there is
what I'd say uh account abstraction
becomes useful uh and wallet ux is about
usefulness as well and it becomes useful
when you get the opportunity to control
what the account then does uh and I
think that's the kind of the missing
piece the granting permissions uh
enabling users having an interface for
users to control what that abstracted
account actually does
are you going to ship an account
abstraction um I think so what is very
well known we're working on a a
framework called delegator framework um
that introduces permissions and
permission management for uh smart
contracts
accounts um I think a account
abstraction to some extent is a victim
of hype versus reality
situation um and like like you mentioned
this is one example the numbers are
definitely not there yet for the account
abstraction uh but the hype is so much
there that people kind of expect it's
one day to get everything that was
promised um now the reality is that um
when for example a account abstraction
sort of launched which is not exactly
something you can do to something like a
account abstraction uh there was no
mempo for account abstraction right so
there was just like an entry point and
that entry point changed I think seven
or eight times since right so there's
like a product like they take time um
and 4337 was the first iteration of a
account obstruction that had some level
of traction and usability uh and I think
7702 which I'm not sure how many people
here are familiar with but I think 7702
EAP 7702 is actually going to be the
next phase and this is something that
the ethereum foundation is working on
right now like uh the core devs not the
thean foundation itself but the core
devs are working on introducing that
into ethereum beginning of next year um
and one of the big differences between
7702 and 4337 because we're probably not
going to go and talk about the standards
themselves but I think the big
difference is that the first iteration
of account abstraction was really just
uh looking at smart contract wallets as
participating right so like Lucas has
already kind of been in that game for
the last year but the next version is
also looking at EA participating um so
mamass can start getting into that game
as well and fire blocks with our
offering and our clients of fire blocks
can also get into that game and since
99% of people still use an eoa um this
inclusive offer like new proposition is
actually going to be a big boost towards
uh adoption but we're definitely not
there
yet yeah I do think that account abst
section was
overhyped uh massively but I think it
was also necessary because that is the
reason that we uh have like about 10
panels on account OBS section at a
conference now we have bunch of
discussions and like progress a bunch of
Builders working at that and needed this
initial impulse to get things started uh
but it also at some point the sobering
effect comes where the big promises take
longer Etc um like for for me anyways
the
goal uh is not necessarily the account
abstraction part which is often
associated with like the eips and the
standardization of of ethereum Etc
around it but is really moving users
towards smarter accounts um because that
will unlock the the potential for users
that will make them feel more secure
have better convenience Etc and I think
in that regard uh we haven't failed at
all like uh right now already just
looking at safe smart accounts they make
up 10% of the transfer volume on
ethereum like 10% Like that's not I
wouldn't consider that as a failure at
all and that means obviously there's 90%
to go but like at some point we will
also reach a tipping point where like as
as apps see that actually a lot of the
transfer volume is coming through smart
accounts they start optimizing for it
and it creates this uh virtuous cycle of
like constant uh optimization which
eventually will lead us towards having
every account a smart account which What
We should strive
for yeah but uh even on safe wallet I
think you don't support 437 yet in the
UI so the 10% that you mentioned they
don't use the ERC 437 features just just
to like um give a c cynical nitpick I
mean the user doesn't care the user
doesn't care if there's 457 there or not
they care about oh my transactions are
sponsored they care about oh my
transactions are batched together I have
multis they care about these things if
457 is the right thing to achieve that
if 7702 is the right thing to achieve
that whatever EIP is coming in the
future I don't care I want that the user
benefit uh gets to shine yeah I agree
with that yeah I I just wanted to say
there's probably like 20 different talks
about 4337 or 7 702 and just one wallet
ux or like maybe there's a couple more
like user ux there's not a lot of them
right I think maybe that's a bit of an
indication of the priorities we have
currently in the ecosystem uh focusing a
lot on the details of the different
solutions uh and not focusing enough on
like what lookas just said that the end
result how does that look is it
comfortable right uh uh so like that's
that's part of maybe the shift we need
to do as an
ecosystem cool then next can each of you
maybe pick your top three exciting ux
improvements that you're going to see
that we're going to see over the next
year or
two we're going to see three that's
amazing yeah I can think of two I'm
gonna get I'm going to rely on you both
to add third fourth sixth fifth um no
I'm thinking one two of the things I am
really excited about is permission
management uh I think that's going to
give a lot more control uh that users so
far have had to rely on solidity
developers uh for to to get smart
accounts to make accounts smart or do
what what you want it to do uh and the
other thing I'm excited about is
introducing more identity components
into wallets uh being able to track your
proofs and credentials that you have
shared um so I think those would be my
uh my top two picks I I think I think
you left a really easy one for me uh so
I'll take that one uh but gas
abstraction right when people talk about
a c abstraction they usually put a lot
of things into that bucket uh um but I
think gas abstraction like or sponsored
and gasless transactions are some of the
things that are most exciting because
probably a lot of the people in the room
don't remember that feeling because like
you're obviously like very reversed in
working with blockchains and sometimes
when we're like that we sort of assume
everybody is but if you go to a website
and you want to do something and you I
don't know you're buying an NFD or uh
you're want to pay with with like a
basically like dollars right like for
somebody who's not part of our ecosystem
already um and suddenly somebody starts
saying hey you need to have ethereum to
make that
transaction um that's like very very
painful in terms of the adoption uh of
new like new users for this
ecosystem um and by the way even for us
it happen sometime right like uh um I
had it just recently where somebody like
I wanted to complete something it wasn't
a chain that I didn't have the native
token for right like um an evm chain and
suddenly you're you're in that position
you were the first time you use the
blockchain how do I get this gas token
now um so I think what smart contract
wallets in General in account
abstraction as it connects to eoas
brings as well with 7702 is definitely
the ability to let users on board to
blockchains without first figuring this
really hard thing of getting the guest
token uh and I think that's just in
terms of onboarding we already see this
is very
useful now the good thing is if you go
last you can actually think about three
things um
I I I would say
for from users perspective like the what
they what the user value we should bring
especially with with smart accounts is
around speed security and scale like
that's really what the user feels from
what comes out of it uh and there I
think over next year we will see uh big
Advance advancements in all of them
speed it's around uh one enablement for
this could be session keys where session
Keys allow you to have like actually
have like the the wallet be a cold
wallet where the key is secure but like
you you give permissions to session keys
that then allow you to do easy
interactions with an app without every
time signing with your with your uh like
U yeah private key uh directly um that's
the one thing uh and security part is we
still rely a lot on the front end
managing the security for the user where
I think with account obstruction smart
accounts that we can introduce better
and harder security guarantees for the
user uh where like we've got providers
like a blockade for example in in safe
wallet uh they check every transaction
and they say to the user this is like
malicious this is okay and the user just
trusts the front end there like these
same guarantees could be given on a on a
transaction level on a transaction
inclusion level where blockade could
actually say hey our engine said this
this is a malicious transaction whatever
front end is used even if you had the
private key EXP Expos we block this and
the only way to then go forward is if
you have unpack whatever your social
recovery or your backup key or whatever
uh so that we we will see like these
advancements in in security for the user
and the last one I would say is scale
where the users should really do as much
as possible with their wallets and right
now we we live in silos across chains
where uh it's really hard to to migrate
between jurisdictions uh and
like across different l2s Etc and I
think there we also see advancements in
like yeah usage just has like a single
unified balance they can go to an app
they don't care what chain it is they
just spend the the assets there they can
use those assets on a different chain
with a different application and the
scale of user interaction just increases
massively and that also is requires the
account
abstraction maybe maybe it's worth like
uh Lucas just mentioned this uh
multi-chain situation um so I think it's
it's maybe kind of bringing the the
audience into our situation right in
terms of getting good wall good ux for
users not just wallets so this ecosystem
was built initially for a single chain
uh and even as people were thinking
about smart contract wallets for example
the entire idea was you pull the wallet
on chain because everything is on chain
and then L2 started to happen and it's
not the wallet's fault but
basically it's my take that when more
and more all l2s happened they basically
degraded the wallet experience for users
right because suddenly problems like I
have money on this chain I don't have
money on this chain but the DAP is on
this chain they didn't exist initially
um and now we have a lot of chains right
like probably on the panel next to us
somebody's announcing a chain um so
suddenly even your Unis swap is on a
different chain and your ens might be on
a different chain and everything is on a
different chain and that creates uh a
user experience problem uh because you
need to do you need to get the user
informed of the fact that it's a
different chain and he needs to do some
action on the other side you might hide
from him that he there's a different
chain but if you hide for him what if
you introduce a security risk as a
result maybe the other chain is not as
trustworthy as the one you have money on
right um so there's a real dilemma
between the use usability user
experience that you can give to people
and sometimes on the other side is not I
don't want to do development work it's
rather there's a risk element right
there's a security problem uh that you
need to account for so that creates like
a very complex uh process so actually
would say it's a trilemma I think the
the problem with W ux is always you want
to maximize on convenience you want to
maximize on security and you want to
maximize on control like in web 2 we
figured out how to maximize on
convenience and security to arguably uh
but like people just don't have the
control that's why web free that's why
one want non-custodial solutions that
users have more control they can migrate
their accounts to whatever solutions
they want Etc but then suddenly the
problem is you can only maximize on two
of them because like you can have
control plus security uh but that's
usually the very Technical Solutions
which then don't bring the convenience
or like cold storage solutions Etc or
you can have uh convenience
and uh yeah convenient Solutions with a
lot of control but then usually this is
too much abstractions and the user
doesn't understand what they sign
anymore and they do something wrong and
the security gets lost so kind of this
trilemma I think we've been navigating
over the last years in the wallet space
uh and I think they yeah again account
abstraction I would hope that it helps
uh kind of managing these uh this these
trade-offs better or or even enable it
eventually to have like all of the three
be maximized at the same time but I
think that's uh yeah that's the at least
my mental model when when it's about
world DX is these three three
things so we got quite a bit we got
identity permissions session Keys chain
abstraction gas abstraction
security
um so we got quite a bunch of things
there's going to be a QA later if you
disagree if you think the the speakers
forgot something please um put in your
your hot takes um I'd be curious
I know the amount of fire blocks users
is probably not so huge but the last
statistic I saw from metamask was 30
million um I think monthly actives in
the in the last bull cycle so you
probably have a lot of user data is that
also what your users are asking for like
does this come up chain abstraction or
anything like that gas
abstraction yeah so I think what we what
we get as feedback is related to
convenience to like having a good ux
whatever that that means uh and it's up
for up to us to then interpret that and
understand how those problems might be
addressed with account abstraction
um yeah I'd be doubtful that we're
actually getting like we could do some
searches but I'd be doubtful that we're
actually getting demand for account
abstraction uh so it's our
interpretation that some of the feedback
that we get can be resolved through
account abstraction um and and better
control and
security cool I think I I just want to
say we that fire blocks has created more
than 250 million wallets just want into
like in terms of like the amount of
users and stuff but I mean how many end
users are in so so a lot of them what so
a lot of times what would happen like
fireblocks kind of has two when we're
talking about models there's like well
actually more than two models but like
we can simplify it into two models where
there's uh like a more of a treasury
oriented model for companies that hold a
lot of money and we want to make sure
they're secure and that they have all of
the things they need to build and that's
like like what a lot of people usually
think about fireblocks uh when they're
familiar with with fire blocks and the
other Mo W the other model is more
wallet as a service so a lot of times
what will happen is companies will
create millions of Wallets on fireblocks
uh for their users right and in that we
also have uh for the clients the ability
to do custodial and non-custodial
wallets so so a lot of times what will
happen is that the the the client of
fire blocks will create non-custodial uh
wallets for their users using like MPC
technology and things like that uh that
is underneath the surface to make sure
that the wallet is actually still known
custodial uh for the user got it yeah I
want to tap into that a little bit more
later but one thing that that fascinates
me is Lucas and and safe are massive
innovators on on account distraction and
smart contract wallets and one feature
of that is that now you can have
multiple signers and you can have
spending policies and all this and uh
I'm curious where what is the wallet of
the future basically do I still have an
app in my phone to to use the account or
do I just have a pass key signer and I
sign in the app directly um where you
what's what's the wallet of the future
in let's say five years and how does it
impact your
business I'll hand to Lucas he's
smiling
uh I know if there going to be the
wallet of the future um obviously if
it's kind of like sci-fi kind of thing
the the wallet is completely invisible
to the user and it just uh interact or
kind of Acts on the users's behalf as
with an AI agent behind it and uh in a
in a very secure way and when the user
eventually at the end of the lifetime
passes away all the assets get somehow
routed to the descendant of this person
uh like a lot of the things that that
are today not not solved but like the I
know this is more the kind of esoteric
perspective I know if some more uh
product oriented an no I'm thinking what
remains especially if we're talking
about in introducing more embedded
wallet smart contracts accounts is that
you continue to have a place which then
becomes becomes an evolution of the
wallet where you aggregate uh search
probably through smarter AI interactions
uh what you've done in the past what you
want to do in the future what kind of
caveats you want to add to that um so it
it becomes more your control center of
accounts I don't see those fully
abstracted away in managing or
exercising control but I do see them
abstracted away from interactions that
you do with let's say daps or uh or
other um decentralized
applications Okay C can I add a bit of a
hot take on that in that area so um I I
think like obviously like uh Lucas
mentioned earlier one of the easy ways
to provide great ux for users is just be
like custodial right like that's what
web 2 did um and so there's kind of like
as an ecosystem we're like we want to
enable something better something
different um and there's now this very
big push in the ecosystem of everybody
being excited about like the wallets
that you can sign with a pass key um I
wonder like how many people here are
excited about the ability to like on
board have a pass key just sign it you
don't need to create Keys you don't need
to do those kind of things there's a lot
of companies that are building this
right now um but I think pasis are a
very big risk of centralization right
and I don't think anybody talks about it
right so like out of the people here who
have aasy or ever experienced a pasy
signing I don't think maybe there is
there anybody here who created his pasy
outside of Apple or
Android or like like create okay we have
like five like okay that actually
created A Pas key in their own system
like you can do those kind of things
right pasy as a technology is
decentralized but we know a lot of times
that user habits bit technology so if
you create your pass key in apple apple
will back it up in the Apple Cloud and
apple can move it around between Apple
devices but you cannot get your pass key
so if Apple decides to shut down your
pass key you cannot sign I don't know if
that's self custodial
like somebody should tell me I have no
idea but like it's definitely not the
fully decentralized world that we
imagined so I think there's going to be
challenges it's very exciting because it
gives us the ux we want but I'm not sure
it gives everything we want I want to
take a a hot take on that or like I want
to counter that actually in our app SDK
I think it's the the P ke of convenience
Fe feature the way it's used today it's
a second um it's a tofa and that's how
it's used in Google and I think that's
how it's going to Beed in crypto too in
our app SDK that also uses a safe smart
account for normi users and it's ESC 437
so they don't need to have gas and
whatnot they first provide their they
first provide their email and then their
Pass key so now the email still also can
be censored But ultimately I think the
like the wallet of the future basically
you have multiple signers and if you
have serious funds maybe you have you
know some some Ledger in a in a safe or
something if you in a bank safe um so no
I think the Pas is a nice convenience
feature and I think it's successful as
such and in crypto it's going to be the
same yeah yeah it's is but I I would say
pasis as the primary and only signer of
an account I I very much agree that this
should not be the the way we should go
down as session Keys app specific Keys
pass keys are amazing but not as a as a
primary key and sorry Hester cut off I
think no I think Luca summarized it uh
exactly how I would want to put it uh
not as a primary solution uh not a
primary key uh and I think like to add
to the point of decentralization it also
kind of reduces Global access because
not everybody has the ability or
availability to use pass keys and this
is kind of like the process we need to
go through things right we get excited
about this technology over time we
understand wait a sec there's some
trade-offs here uh and hopefully new
Solutions come in but like that's going
to take some time personally I'm more
with regards to centralization I'm more
concerned about that the way we fix the
ux problems um such as smart account is
going to lead to more de centralization
until very recently the only UI where I
could manage my safe my safe core was
the safe wallet UI and today the only UI
where I can manage my coinbase smart
account is the coinbase UI same for
trust so actually the user now gets
vendor logged in there um but for safe
this is exactly the thing we didn't want
to have like safe is ecosystem we were
pushing there's 200 Builders uh like
some do like uh more more death tooling
but there's at least 50 user front ends
where you can Port your account because
that's that that's exactly the risk that
we have going towards account
abstraction is that we will lose the
portability of our accounts it's the
greatest thing that if I don't
like fire blocks anymore I I hopefully
have a way to migrate my account somehow
to to metamask or to leer or like I I
this is what web free can make so
powerful have disc control so I
shouldn't have CAU the reowned UI for
instance also supports safe so safe is a
bad example but personally I'm more
concerned about these things than the
the pasy centralization so aric what do
you think I think I think I think that's
a that's a great point right when you
had an EA it's just a key so it's more
easily portable right there was multiple
wallets that allowed you to import even
Keys even though there's obviously
security problems there when you import
the key you took outside like it's
already outside of the safe environment
goes but still like it was easy to
transfer what we saw initially in the uh
smart wallet space is you could not migr
stuff right like you had a safe uh they
had their implementation let's say you
now wanted to move to an un buer wallet
that was like that you basically had to
move your funds right like it was there
was no way to do those kind of
transitions because they were not
aligned on the standards that are used
and things like that um a lot of the
work that's happening right now again
mostly uh on the back end of a lot of
our communication right between us and a
lot of other companies is there
different standards are being formed
right if safe has one implementation of
modules and other smart contract wallets
have different implementation of modules
uh it's hard to reuse model it's hard to
to do things the more standardization
that we do um the more portable
everything becomes so there's like the
smart contract side of of the uh uh
standardization that a lot of work is
being done there and also so kind of
giving the props to the wallet connect
uh initiative as a start and reown as an
an actor um what happens a lot of times
behind the scenes and this is how a lot
of us know each other is that uh the
wallet connect te kind of organizes us
to all of the different wallets together
and we talk about how do we make user
experience because eventually there is
one app on the other side right like uh
again we can it's always easy to use
like a Unis Swap and they need to
interact with a lot of wallets and if we
don't aligning that interaction on
something that a lot of different
companies a lot of different wallets
will support Unis swap will not add the
feature right because they're like if
only 2% of my users can use this feature
it's not even worth it but as soon as we
all combine the efforts both on the
client dap side and the wallet side we
can push kind of like those things
forward so so a lot of this
decentralization is also about allowing
the interaction to be the same and then
you can move wallets without feeling
like you lost a leg when you were moving
right so that's like I think that's
important we we love you too and and
aric is amazing on the standards as is
as is Lucas um uh but I think the smart
account the problem I mentioned you
cannot standardize because there's too
much uh Innovation I'm also talking my
book because Reon are building a library
so that wallets can easily manage any
smart account implementation and such
that users can still rotate uh I want to
maybe Lucas has another take but I want
to switch gears a little bit because
it's so rare that we have um wallets
with so many users and different types
of users on the stage maybe um and and
someone like aric who's onboarding um
new types of wallets I heard the stat
this week and it seemed credible I don't
get it together right but tldrs we
capture we penetrated 10% of the market
so 10% of Internet users somehow
interact with crypto so so that doesn't
mean um but there are probably users
like myself like my bank I have X
accounts but maybe soon I will have 5x
accounts because my Chase Bank also has
crypto I mean that's probably ARX
wheelhouse but I'm I'm curious a where
are we going to get this 90% from and
then B does it keep you up do you think
you can compete or is someone completely
new like Apple going to come away and
and sweep away the
users we get them from
mobile from mobile that would be my
answer I don't think we uh built good
enough mobile interfaces yet uh metam
mask or everyone just kidding generally
speaking no and I know that's that's the
space that wallet connect makes a makes
a huge difference um but I think that's
the growth of our uh user base um yeah
and then yeah no let me let me pause
there yeah mobile yeah I I totally
believe that the biggest adoption comes
initially through intermediates so I
think I don't think what's going to
happen I like maybe you know but like I
don't think what's going to happen is
that we're going to onboard a billion
users to like like if you're saying to
wallet to extensions on browsers right
uh mobile is definitely one of the
things but I think what's more likely to
happen is that companies with that
already have billions of users right and
hundreds of millions of users are are
going to be embedding more and more
blockchain
capabilities um and as they do some
users will feel the blockchain first
time without knowing it's a blockchain
right again like like there's a lot of
people playing a game that has
blockchain behind it and they don't know
and they don't care and I think a lot of
it's it's like number one in the store
uh first time it ever happened uh um and
so I think that's what's going to happen
right I think that social networks are
going to bring those capabilities and I
think that like you know like um online
shopping is going to bring those
capabilities because they have so much
to gain from optimizing all of their
operations to be or many of their
operations to run on blockchains um it's
cheaper it's faster like they can create
better experience that's why they'll do
this they will not do this because they
like blockchains as a concept they'll do
this because they will provide better
service to their users and they're going
to save money um and so I think that's
where adoption comes from and over time
the people that until now heard about
blockchains as the place where people
get hacked or the place where price has
gone up a lot but they missed the train
uh they're going to feel the blockchain
as oh that's why my internet is better
now um and hopefully over time we can
get them to be you know more self-
custodial and more advanced users things
like that but I think that's where
adoption comes
from yeah I actually also very much see
adoption to potentially come from more
custodial Solutions first where like I
think we also reached the limit of like
how many people we can uh convince to
use to write down the seat phrase and
store it securely uh so but like people
are used to like Web Two experiences if
something even if it runs on on the
blockchain has a web two experience and
it it is has some custodial nature to it
they would use it if it it brings a
value and I very much want to see a
future where
we very much Embrace exit hatch as a
valuable option for things well like the
the the source problem that we have
today with intermediaries and with
custodial Solutions is that I'm locked
in like I have no way out I have my bank
account like my bank account is not
going to say oh here's the easy
migration part how we can move from
credit Swiss to UBS I mean except just
acquiring them and but like the let's
say JP Morgan and UBS they they don't
have like this inter connection yeah you
can send out the the assets one by one
or like I know uh rewind your position
your portfolio Etc but like there's no
interoperability there there's no exit
hatch there like that's what we need
that's what unlocks Innovation compet um
better competitive environments uh for
for startups Etc and like I want to use
Facebook it's fine if it's custodial
like it's fine if they manage my social
graph if they do transactions on my
behalf if if they have a way to secure
the off R but like I want to have this
xit attached that if Facebook uh I know
goes down the the wrong path I can take
my social graph and Port it into some
other solution uh and I think that's
that's the very thing we should preserve
with control like if we don't have this
anymore I start doubting why we do
things in the first place because then
we will slowly but surely go down the
same path as web 2 had uh so this this
kind of
exit um yeah value we I want to see in
the future
yeah there's one I would add that maybe
we haven't touched on which would be
stable coins uh which we've seen as a as
a force for adoption uh certainly don't
hope to see more of that as a as a root
cause to drive adoption but it's
definitely where I think we'll see more
adoption happening access to stable
coins in uh uh volatile uh
economies interesting I mean I one thing
that I'm that I think we're going to see
soon with stable coins is an explosion
of stable coins yield bearing stable
coins coins so we were talking about I
think gas abstraction chain abstraction
but we didn't talk about stable coin
abstraction but obviously when I'm when
I do a checkout on stripe um in usdc and
I have a yield bearing stable coin I
want to be able to use that so um that's
going to be a problem for sure yeah
first of all I can say we see stable
coin explosion right like because uh
that's obviously a place where uh we're
very active uh but I think for example
like for me I don't know I feel like
it's sort of an Arbitrage opportunity
right now we have a world with so many
coins and pretty much nobody uses a
stable coin that is not the dollar
that's unclear to me right like it seems
to me like something that's temporary
and will change over time because uh not
everybody necessarily wants to be uh um
like you know somebody in Europe not
necessarily wants to hold his money in
dollars most of the time right like
because he still lives in Euro costs in
that sense and then he moves
automatically to the dollar obviously
there's a good thing about it if you're
from an economy where you don't trust
your coin but uh like your native coin
in the country uh but uh but it kind of
feels like weird to me I think that's
something that will be solved I think
over time we will see more stable coins
that are on different uh Fiat connected
to different Fiat uh and we're going to
see more of an fx Marketplace on the
blockchain that we barely see right now
um so that's definitely something that
will happen that's by definition will
bring more stable coins and the other
thing that will bring more stable coins
is that um eventually more institutions
that the average person trusts will have
their stable coin right now like again
like we ourselves were like well we're
kind of used to having stable coin some
of their most TR more trustworthy
organizations some are less trustworthy
organizations but like for the average
user they know their bank and if their
bank has a stable coin they might just
kind of trust it more so like I think
also that's something that will happen
we need to earn trust trust uh and like
as an ecosystem we've done like the
ecosystem has done a few things that
hurt that the trust thing um so yeah
definitely going to see a lot more of
those but also I think more
decentralized what do you think is going
to be the the killer app you it seemed
like you have some negative sentiment
towards stable coins I think stable no
oh um but then yeah maybe maybe what's
going to be the killer app could be
stable coins could be something else
no just to just to add some Nuance to
that I wasn't referring to stable coins
more the
the the reason for end users to find
stable coins opposed to their uh their
Fiat stable currency uh that was the the
negative sentiment that that
unfortunately shouldn't be The Driver
um let me think on the killer
app because I think what we were talking
about for new users like the next 90%
And they will probably not just have one
account but maybe a 100 um another thing
might be Lucas used the example of
Facebook like if Facebook becomes a
crypto app or Instagram adds crypto like
that's a new account it's a new um so
might draw in this if they build a
killer app that might really quickly get
us a billion users um I saw I think we
saw a little bit of that with frch they
obviously didn't get to a billion but um
I know telegram is a hypothetically a
new platform and they might have app
specific wallets so I curious to see
where is this going to happen overnight
is there going to be a killer app
drawing in these users or are we five
years away from pulling in these these
next
90% yeah I mean we definitely had two
killer apps this year one is poly market
and the other one was worldcoin or is
worldcoin like uh you can say yeah poly
Market it's us elections probably this
adoption it's going to be hard to
maintain it but like they definitely
made it into mainstream media they were
able to onboard a lot of non- crypto
users uh with a account abstraction
under the hood to kind of have this web
to like experience and World coin
similarly like yeah there there are some
controversies around it but they uh they
onward a lot of users who had no touch
points with crypto before um like I
heard something like 25% of the people
in Buenos AOS signed up for worldcoin
and now it's about them actually making
good you use this and funing this user
base to something that's valuable but
like they definitely like we're not 2019
anymore where the only people using the
products are the people building the
products we definitely made a lot of
progress
there all right um final question any
any hot take on on ux on wallet ux I I
already shared
one any hot takes on what sorry wallet
ux
I think I don't know if it's hotake the
getting to Great wallet ux is a bigger
problem than people think and not
necessarily everything works in the same
direction again as I mentioned right now
with like multiple chains sometimes you
don't just go forward you actually go
backwards uh so like I think it's like
really requires a big push from the
entire ecosystem to get to where we want
to get to
no I I I would just second that as a
great point I think when we talk about
wallet ux we often talk about talk about
the user interface and things feeling
clunky or slow um but I think that's a
like a perception that is a um uh a
combination uh of the ecosystem that
represents itself in the wallet that's
where you see the fragmentation
happening on many levels it's like
always we're the one at the Gat so we're
the ones that people see so we kind of
hide all of the problems of everybody
behind us
What's Your Heart Take
Lucas trying to make it as spicy as
possible very Thailand no uh like I love
metamask and I also like especially what
you're doing at at metamask but I do
think
a
but a big reason of why we haven't made
more advancements in W ux uh so far is
because of metamask because metamask has
had too much
mode uh and generally competition drives
Innovation and I do think it changed a
little bit in last two years I would say
but like 2018 to 2022 like metamask was
just like everyone just integrated
metamask in their app um until wall
connect kind of opened it up a little
bit leveled the playing field a little
bit everyone was optimizing for metamask
and met if one entity always dictates
the ux of an industry that's not good so
like um again like metamask is is great
everyone should use metamask you guys
are doing good job but like I think
looking back there was a bit a missed
opportunity that we didn't have more
competition in our industry I think we
would have been further along you
actually got hot take that's so cool
yeah yeah yeah I should have started
with that but H please respond no I
think it goes back to standards uh and
there was definitely an era where
standards were lacking the kind of
wallet U wallet Alliance uh dissipate
data for lack of a better term uh and
that was definitely an era that I think
we've passed now there is there is
strong competition uh which is a good
thing and I think that's going to drive
the ux
forward maybe maybe a sign of that is
that I think a lot of the early
standards around wallets have just been
uh basically reverse engineering what
mam mask is doing so that other thing
like wallets do the same and then you
can use both because it's the same and I
think right now what's happening is a
lot of the standards is more like
communication between wallets and
creating the standard that everybody
believe is correct so like that probably
signals a shift in that but like uh
we're definitely not there yet because
like you know like competition increases
but definitely there's still a big
Advantage I'm quite bullish I think I
mean even at this conference few years
ago people wouldn't talk about ux you
know now like ux is we maybe wouldn't
have had this panel you know just a year
ago so I'm quite bullish and wallets
like yourselves are super game um aric
many people from metamask many people
from safe when be put to get an event
everybody get in the same room for a
week you're always happy to provide
people so I think we're going to be able
to um yeah fix problems together much
quicker let's get into
Q&A maybe quick clap for for the hot
take especially Lucas um um that was a
that was a good one elephant in the room
maybe I don't know what C's what the
audience thinks all righty
I like the first one yeah and these
are yeah these are rated by how many of
you voted so yeah let's do the first one
um H has a take go ahead yeah well I I
just because of the framing of the
question I don't think it's about 100%
decentralized it's about
100% uh distributed control which is
different from
decentralized uh I think distributed
control
is uh a worthwhile goal that is
achievable fully decentralized I would
be highly doubtful because of the
fragmentation because of the indexation
that needs to happen for accounts for
networks for tokens anything we surface
in the wallet uh but distributed control
of those indexes uh I think that's a a
goal that's achievable like
centralization is such a sneaky thing
okay because at the moment you think you
solved it you most likely just pushed it
into a different place right and this is
what we see is an ecosystem like
ethereum staking so does so much work on
making solo sticker easy making this and
then suddenly like a Lio comes in people
are like oh we missed that part and then
like you know and then new actions
happen so like what usually happens with
centralization just like security issues
you push them from one place to the
other place and you need to constantly
reduce like those so I mentioned this
earlier with baskis I think that's going
to be the second PL that the other place
that Catches Us sort of off guard then
that's going to be solved and then
there's going to be a new place that
catches us off guard so like it's going
to be that process where you just move
it around between places and you'll
hopefully it doesn't have anywhere to
hide I can you want to please um yeah I
can take the next one with thoughts on
coinbase Smart wallet um I'm personally
super excited that they working on this
I would have had higher expectations at
the beginning of the year of where we
are now because like the the promise of
like coinbase is offboarding all of its
user base which already has crypto on
chain and they use Smart waller for that
and they have amazing Innovation there
around magic spend where you can
actually use your coinbase centralized
exchange balance on your wallet and
spend it with a with a DB directly like
I I thought this would be like a yeah
this kind opens the the floodgates and
now all the the coinbase users are
coming in we haven't seen that actually
uh the yeah there's bunch of wallets
deployed but like if you look at how
much assets are actually used on these
wallets it's it's quite minimal I mean
minimal like one $1 million or something
but compared to what coinbase is but
still I'm I just recently heard that
they doubling down on this strategy and
that's that's a very good thing where
like they they very much engage with the
ecosystem the world ecosystem especially
also the account abstraction ecosystem
they get where things are heading uh
they contribute to to to standards as
well uh yeah I I hope they will uh
especially embrace the standards that uh
enable neutrality uh such as ERC 7579 so
we have like a open way to to build on
coinbase Smart wallet and it's not a a
permissioned thing and like I yeah so
long story short um thought it would be
faster but still very much excited about
it let's go to the oh just to add one
thing I think it's a very positive
indication to our industry that somebody
like coinbase uh who has so much control
over their users are willing to
relinquish some of that control to
advance the ecosystem so first of all
that's like a big kudos to them on
making those steps with slowly because
they they're not just making money
they're also have this thing they
believe in and they're slowly pushing
towards that we kind of expect now l2s
to do that right with their like single
sequencers and we want them to move to
more uh centralized efforts so it's just
a bullish thing for all of us that
they're kind of willing to do that
effort so and so good on them are we
like the Innovation too but got to say
like all like all the exchanges
obviously following that strategy and
they're all doing amazing like okx was
really the first large scale wallet to
do an account abstraction wallet the
first one half a year before the second
one trust which is also owned by binance
uh came along so I think all the
exchanges are doing surprisingly um
amazing in Innovation um I'm surprised
that nobody's asking what aric's
favorite Pokemon is um I know the answer
or ask me later um not glur rock um yeah
who wants to take the on-ramp question I
think the questions are
great I have a take on onramp but I want
to take the next question I think onr's
been absolutely amazing like there's so
much
there's so many Fess onramps um it's
mostly for the for the west but the
innovation in onramps has has been
amazing um so I think it's going to you
have a counter I I think we talked about
it a bit as well like I believe un
ramping doesn't a lot of situation go
through somebody who already has user
attention right and can solve some of
the problems that the user has to deal
with and just get them more easily into
the ecosystem I believe in that I mean
you everyone coming online with an
on-ramp stripe has an on-ramp like it's
it's not big yet but like it's going to
be you you're going to have an account
somewhere within a custodial solution
where where you already have your bank
account linked and then you can easily
onramp and then one day every will one
will have this magic spend like feature
where I can just you Source funds from
this is a bit further out in the future
but yeah I think onr is getting great
offer him a little bit less Innovation
as far as I can tell but but still I
mean there was there was like um there's
like Bridge was the big fintech
acquisition recently which makes off ram
for now in the US easier in the in the
EU there's also like this bank account
type offramp Innovations so very bullish
on that um I like the question yeah if
you have enough if you have enough
designers yeah I know I'd love to this
one we are hiring
designers I think what one of the
challenges is for for designers I mean
this is the space is mindboggling for
any of us right like there's so much to
keep up with it's the same for designers
um I think what what really helps
designers is being involved as early as
possible you can't design for anything
that you don't fully understand uh and
what I still see often is designers
being kind of looped in at the end to
add a user interface on top of something
that's already abstracted if you imagine
coming into the space now um especially
with account abstraction coming you
would have no concept or understanding
of how accounts are uh generated or
initiated in the first place maybe the
problem is not that we don't have enough
designers I think we don't have have
enough founder designers like I think
that we're such a technical space that a
lot of the founders are Technical and
maybe like the designer view of the
entire company is something like like
founder designers might be interesting I
don't know how many of those we have
it's coool take yeah I mean rainbow
wallet is very designer heavy family
launched yesterday founded by a designer
so interesting take I think in the early
days also we were kind of designing or
building for ourselves as a target
audience lot like a lot of technical
people and that kind of worked uh but I
think now we reach a point where we are
not the target audience anymore like if
you want to extend you said like 10% had
uh touch points with crypto like if we
want to get to this 90% we need to build
for people people that are way different
than ourselves and it doesn't just have
to do with designers it just has to do
with having a extremely user oriented
approach to product development not
solve technical challenges with
Technical Solutions but solve user
problems with whatever is the best way
to solve that and it can involve design
it can be technical Innovation it can be
different ways that you achieve that but
like maximize on user value and not on
uh uh just Innovation uh and the other
part is that our industry very much just
likes doing the same thing that everyone
else is doing so we live in narratives
and like if someone else is doing
something we just assume they they
somehow uh had some big insights and we
just copi them and we do that instead of
talking more to our users and actually
do what our users tell us to do instead
of what our competitors are doing last
last question and then we wrap um sorry
to put you on the spot Hester but the
question is is the extension wallet
going to disappear sorry which one uh
the second one is the browser extension
wallet going to
disappear uh H interesting I think the
uh the interaction Paradigm of an
extension the way we know it might
disappear what you're definitely seeing
is everything moving into a side panel
which makes total sense because you have
the wallet in context of what you're
doing you something you don't have when
you're using the traditional extension
um disappearing entirely um I don't
necessarily see that happening um just
because there are so many use cases that
you wouldn't want to use on a desktop uh
interface uh but it'll definitely it'll
it'll reduce uh again with the use of uh
smart contracts accounts your mobile
might be your primary uh way to uh
manage your your accounts and and
signatures um yeah paired as a companion
uh to what you might still do on a
desktop awesome thanks all and thank you
for listening right thank
you thanks for the great panel
guys we have another presentation on ERC
3668 on Linea uh starting in a few
minutes uh if you guys are interested in
that please stick around
[Music]
than e
for
[Music]
hello
everyone thank you for coming uh my
name's Rodrigo work at the ethereum
foundation uh I'm glad that you guys
have all come uh this is our last uh
presentation before lunch uh as a quick
reminder uh please refrain from using
flash on your phones uh use mircat to
ask questions you guys have been doing
an awesome job with that um and I'd like
to introduce our our final speaker uh
before lunch uh it's Arthur uh product
manager uh at Linea and he is going to
be talking about ERC 3668 uh trust
minimize data retrieval uh from L1 to L2
from L2 to L1 sorry
[Music]
sorry about
this okay hello everybody thanks for
being there I know it's the lunch break
so thanks really for for being there so
my name is arur I'm a product manager at
linear and so like today I will be
talking about rc4
3668 um so yeah let's get started
basically the agenda is quite
straightforward I will explain what it
is uh why do we need it right um and how
does it work the use cases behind it and
I will spend some time uh talking about
the cool integration that we did at
linear to benefit from this standard so
maybe to set the context uh let's just
talk about how we can access external
data I think most of you knows but
natively right a chain cannot access
data from the external World whether
it's over chain or the web but like over
the time we build some over
protocols that solve those problems so
the the main one are bridges right if
you most known to if you want to bridge
assets so coins nfts but there are also
message bridge that let you send a
transaction on chain a and it execute a
transaction on chain B um there are also
oracles that are well known for like
price feed most mostly but most recently
they have creating more generalized
implementation
such as like chain link functions and
other and lately we have also
co-processors that are enabling those
kind of use cases um so the question you
might ask yourself is okay why do we
need another solution and basically ERC
4668 uh also known as ccip read was a a
standard proposed by the ens team
especially Nick because they had a like
unique use cases where they wanted to um
access um the information for L2
especially for managing like domain name
in a with cheaper like gas cost but uh
the they have some constraint and the
design is reflecting that so the first
benefit is that it doesn't require any
trans transaction to send on chain
compared to over all the other solutions
that we mention um so this is more
efficient in a way if you don't need to
store the data on chain because you
don't have to pay the gas cost you also
avoid external depend dependency sorry
on external protocols because it's an
ERC and it's uh like on top of the
protocol but doesn't have those
dependency and extern additional trust
assumption as well so let me tell you a
bit how it works uh there is three part
to it um it starts with the client and
here we are not talking about execution
client or consensus client but more like
the uis or like backends that are
calling the the blockchain and uh like
the client will uh call a smart contract
right standard if call to to get some
information uh something that happens
quite generally and the main um part of
the design from ERC 4668 is this uh
allows the contract to revert with an
error that's basically tell the client
actually you need to give me a bit more
data so that I can do my job so uh at
this point so the client will uh add the
job to fetch the data on a Gateway so uh
standard HTTP call and uh of course the
Gateway will send the result and then
you the the client is uh like giving
back the information to the contract uh
through call back function and at the
end of the day you have an answer so
here I talk about call but actually the
Callback function can be also sent in a
transaction so that means that at the
end of the day you have some logic that
can be executed on chain in a block um
the nice thing about this design is that
if you look at the offchain data um
error there is all the information store
on there there to uh explain to the
client what he needs to do so in advance
the client doesn't need to have any
information about what what are the
gateway to call what is the information
that I need to send to the Gateway which
is the call data uh or what are the
Callback function and so on so this mean
that the client can have a standard
implementation and you don't need to
integrate each time like a specific use
case so if you want to integrate like a
chain like I don't know optimism and a
chain like linear you don't have to do
it
twice um so if you are following like
attentively you might ask yourself but
okay like it seems that you have to
trust the Gateway and like thanks to
during the introduction we said it was
like a secure and trust minimize way to
um fetch data and actually you don't
have to trust the Gateway uh necessarily
if the Gateway provide also a proof of
the information uh that were given and
the nice thing about it is that you know
that l2s like in the design of rollup
are posting their state on the on the
layer one and so you can like just fetch
a storage proof on the L2 and then like
uh verify it on the layer one so that
you can be sure that the data is
accurate so that's what is shown here
when you are doing when the Gateway is
doing the HTTP request actually the
Gateway will call L2 RPC will ask for
the information for if call and then
also like do something like a if get
proof to to get the storage proof and
then when the contract receive the
information it will call the rollup cont
contract which can verify the proof at
the high
level so I think like the design is
quite of cool but uh what can we do with
it um as mentioned in the introduction
like ens was the one proposing it and
actually they have they had a very
specific use case in mind which was to
enable to manage like domains on L2 for
cheaper like gas cost and that's the
main use case that we are seeing today
uh one example is the linear names that
we introduce on linear where you can
have like names like brian. linear. if
or a. linear. if um it's something that
we built and that can be reused by like
the E ecosystem to build any uh uh
integration with ens and every it works
like everywhere ens is resolved as an
example like we have a nft collection on
l which are called if frogs that wanted
to give ens domains to all the holders
so for instance know if you have a um UT
type 743 if. if it's it res to the uh
owner of this nft and if the nft is
transfer like the the name is
transferred with it as well so this is
kind of cool but it's just a first size
and it doesn't stop there like um it can
be used for
any type of um use cases where basically
you want to either compute or store data
on the layer two or even of chain and
access it on on layer one so some
example include uh like Dow governance
where with solution like um sorry we
with like governance solution like
snapshot X that are providing like
voting on chain you can vote on linear
or overl tools that are shiper in gas
and then you can just take the result
and use this call this result to execute
transaction on the layer one one other
interesting use case for instance is to
like gate access to Smart contract so
for instance like if you are doing an
airdrop or nft mints you can require
people to have specific credentials that
are minted on Layer Two for in
attestation for
instance um so okay you might ask your
question how do I need to implement that
it seems really complicated you're
talking about proof and so on um the
nice thing is that we already
implemented all the smart contracts uh
so like all this complicated logic or
not so complicated but all all this
logic is already taken care of we have a
Gateway that is running we have all the
smart contracts the one that are
verifying the proof which for Z up is
esec especially difficult because uh the
the ZK layer 2 usually have a different
way to uh store data uh because like um
the standard Ash function can be a bit
like complicated for ZK so for instance
on linear we have like Spar veral tree
instead of Merkel tree but basically all
of that is to say that uh we have
contracts that are open source and that
can be called to verify the the data
to also fetch the data directly so
basically on the smart contract level
it's much more simpler and uh on top of
that there have been team like the unrug
team that have built additional layer of
abstraction that simplify it even more
and uh abstract the chain so it can
seamlessly like work on different
chain so to summarize the benefits uh
like ERC 3668 is efficient because you
don't have to send a transaction on L1
when you don't need to it's secure
especially when you are working like on
a layer two with like zero knowledge
proof like likea you don't introduce
additional dependency to over protocol
and like the development uh overhead is
minimal because all the contracts the
Gateway everything is already for you to
to build
on um and so if you want to get started
uh those are some links to our doc
documentation open source Trio uh but
most importantly we are doing a a
workshop just after the lunch break
where we will Deep dive into really code
example and you will'll be able to have
a live version uh running on on your
laptop at the end of the
session so yeah that's it thanks a lot
just a reminder guys uh if you guys have
any questions you can ask them through
mircat scan the QR code um looks like we
already have some more coming in uh the
first question is it possible to read L1
data from L2 um so yeah in theory it's
POS it's totally possible like RC
3668 allows to fetch any data the only
thing is that you you need to have like
the state of the blockchain that you
want to to query onur on the Chain where
you want to from which you want to sorry
I will go go again uh but you you need
to on the blockchain that is querying
the information you need to have the the
state of the blockchain that is being
queried and so like it's not most scup
doesn't have that at the moment maybe at
some point we will see like Oracle fun
Oracle that are uh streaming this kind
of data on Shain um but it's it would be
something really cool to
build uh the last question we have
doesn't it make the process more
centralized so indeed like the point of
centralization here is the Gateway uh
but uh if we come back to okay um
actually like the smart contract can
like pass multiple URLs so you have a
kind of redundancy here because you can
have multiple different Gateway not to
rely on a single point of failure but
since the Gateway is passing a proof
like it cannot be tempered with uh so
there is no additional trans assumption
regarding like the um accuracy of the
data we have uh another question keep
them coming guys we we still have time
um does it open up to a temporal attack
if the L2 storage proof is not posted on
L1 yet yeah that that's a very good good
question so you are aware that like l2s
are not not finalizing like like every
second or minutes on on L1 and so
basically you don't have the the state
of L2 uh like before is getting
finalized so on the like zik rollup it
can be uh from a few minutes to to hours
depending on the layer tools on
optimistic rollup it's like the seven
days so this means that you need to to
wait this period in order to fetch the
data so there is this ceny uh but like
as the space evolve and we are going to
faster finality hopefully this will get
better I don't think there is an attack
uh it's just that like the client and
smart contract need to be aware of this
limitation and like uh work with it at
the
moment what libraries already implement
this
behavior um if if that GS for sure wag
me as well unrug is creating a like
higher level abstraction to work across
chain so you don't even have to worry
about like uh the specific of the um
each gateways and so on as a builder
that wants to to rely on on your own
Gateway um th those are the libraries I
know is there any L work latency when
reading
data um so yeah the it's the
finalization light latency so as I
mentioned like from a few minutes to
seven days if you're on optimistic
rollup but like from the network latency
really like it's really uh quick like
usually less than a second or even less
so you you can test it and like type for
instance like arer do. if on the on your
metamask or on the ens website and you
you will see like the answer is most uh
instantaneous I think those are all the
questions everyone can give a round of
applause for Arthur um thank you
[Applause]
guys this is the last session before
lunch um so if you guys uh want to come
back uh sessions will start again at 2m
thank you everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
that
[Music]
m m
e
[Music]
you
for
[Music]
for e
e
[Music]
m
to
[Music]
for
is m
[Music]
e
I
[Music]
oh
for for
[Music]
oh
oh e
[Music]
all
I
[Music]
oh e
for
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
[Laughter]
for
[Music]
oh
all
[Music]
y for
e
[Music]
for
that
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
w
n
[Music]
GM GM GM GM
everyone I welcome back after a break I
supposing you enjoy your lunch uh this
afternoon we're going to have two
sessions and the first one is going to
be interesting one my name is Eric and I
come from Africa my state is Ghana so
next time you meet me remember that my
state is Ghana let's have fun it's going
to be interesting this afternoon um you
help me welcome an amazing speaker who
has been working on ethereum indexing
and no other person than Ryan Smith is
going to speak on index on etherium
oh my goodness okay he's going to speak
on indes on ethereum what you need to
have know about it so ladies and
gentlemen everyone here help me welcome
Ryan Smith on
stage
hello how's it
going um cool
uh oh okay cool there we go um yeah so
hello I wanted to first um talk about
some stuff that I saw in Hacker News
this morning uh this hard drive here it
was pretty cool
um it's uh I think it I don't think it
has the number on here but it was like
60 terabytes of data and the the part
that I saw there was kind of interesting
was 12 gigabytes uh per second of uh
sequential reads um and that's very
exciting and I'm going to come back
um to why that may be interesting a
little later in the talk here um another
thing uh that when I saw that I was
reminded does anyone remember um Fusion
IO does Fusion iio sound familiar okay
like two people maybe three people okay
do you know who the guy is up in the
corner like raise your hand do you know
who that is yeah Steve wnc the Apple guy
yeah in 2010 he started a company called
or he was co-founder or something he
started a company called Fusion IO and
they were building um
really cool storage technology uh and
then that reminded me of this thing that
I read recently um Dropbox uh I think in
20 uh it might be on there yeah 2022
Dropbox uh had this article where they
talked about how they were migrating
away from ssds and onto hard drives
which I thought was just like a very
fascinating thing and in particular like
maybe you've been sleeping on hard
drives uh but um there's been some
recent developments in like the spinning
metal
uh area of of of databases which is um
shingled hard drives uh and that's that
was like a a thing that was entirely new
to me um and you can see there like if
if you Google actually uh Dropbox SSD uh
SMR hard drive you'll find this great
article that talks about um all the
reasons why they went away from ssds and
back to hard drives um and is a very
fascinating article um okay so I've only
got 25 minutes and I was thinking like
boy there's like a lot of stuff that I'd
like to talk about uh when it comes to
ethereum indexing and so my first
thought was like well I can hit these 25
topics and and maybe do you know one
topic a minute but then I was like man
but that really doesn't like cover all
the stuff that I would be excited to
talk about and so I was like well
there's really like 50 things that we
could like explore um that gives us like
30 seconds per topic um but then I
realized like this is just a terrible
approach um and so I willed it down to
three which gives us about 8333
repeating of course minutes per topic uh
which I think is much more reasonable um
so uh the way that I'm going to break
this down is uh I'm going to share kind
of how I think about software
dependencies in general um and then
we'll kind of like also explore like I
think some unique characteristics of the
ethereum data space uh as it relates to
dependencies um and then I'm going to uh
I'm going to talk about um uh I'm going
to talk about like this pattern I've
built like a lot of indexers over the
years I've been in the space for a long
time and there's been like a couple
things that I've seen like kind of just
like be like I've done some things like
over and over again and I've kind of
distilled it down to a pattern so I'm
going to share that with you today um
and maybe um you know inspire you to
build your own indexer and perhaps you
could use some of the ideas in this
pattern uh and then finally um I love
databases I I really enjoy postgress I I
like other databases as well but
postgress is in particular uh a thing
that I enjoy and so I'm going to share
some fun postgress
tips um and so uh let's see yeah let's
get started um oh yes okay so uh I have
a project called index Supply it's a
company that sells indexing stuff but
today like I'm going to convince you to
not buy my software uh even though I do
this stuff uh I actually think it's like
great fun uh to build it yourself and I
also think that there are particular
situations in which it actually makes
sense for you to build it if if you're
working on on a company we're going to
explore that here in just just a second
so um I'm I'm going to I'm not being
factious I'm giving this the college try
convincing you to build your own indexer
do not use uh do not use my stuff um
okay so let's get into to kind of how I
think about
dependencies um so to start like uh I
want to talk about um ethereum in
particular uh and so like there's kind
of like this base question of like what
is you know indexing ethereum and uh and
so uh quick quick pull here who's read
the yellow paper
that's about like I want to say like a
third of the audience okay great so in
the yellow paper you basically get um
and and like the way that I'm kind of
like thinking about this is that when
when you think about dependencies you
have to pick some Anchor Point right
like at a certain point you're going to
say like okay I'm going to go like
invent a new kind of hard drive
technology like no you're not going to
do that you're going to use you're going
to buy a hard drive and then you're
probably going to like use a file system
you're probably going to use an
operating system and so like there are
these things that we kind of like anchor
around and then like on top of those
anchors then we start to think about
like okay should I build it should I buy
it um and so I think in particular for
ethereum uh like we we have like these
primitive data structures that are built
into execution clients and they give us
things like blocks and transactions and
logs um but the uh the databases that
are within these execution clients uh
are really optimized for processing the
transactions like not necessarily
optimized for arbitrary queries
uh and and I think that's like a fine
thing and perhaps there's like
opportunities um to you know blend those
two types of workloads together maybe um
but we can kind of uh I think it's fine
actually um like in particular G has
like these freezer files has anyone
worked with a freezer file raise your
hand no one has worked with a freezer
file I don't see anyone is work with the
freezer file okay these are really cool
in gu um like all of the transaction log
data is just like packed
into a binary file on this file system
you can read through it very quickly
it's very interesting if you ever if you
use Google freezer files you'll see some
interesting stuff come up um okay I'm
gonna keep going here uh okay
so okay so uh one of the interesting
things about the ethereum landscape is
that you know we we have these core
primatives we have the nodes and we have
a standard Json RPC API uh and what's
really great about this is that um you
know if you build at W with that as your
dependency you have this really nice
commoditization effect where you know if
you don't like your particular provider
uh they're not you they're not doing it
for you you can go to like 10 other
providers and so you you really do not
have hardly any vendor lock in um now
there's some disadvantages like if you
just work at this level because you have
to actually develop software you have to
manage databases so there's a little bit
of a cost to it um and so you know if we
kind of move up if we go to like the
other end of the stack back and you use
something like you know like what I
build or there's like a handful of other
products out there that give you like a
more robust API to access the ethereum
data uh and maybe you don't have to use
a database but now you're like entirely
dependent upon that API and if that API
doesn't work for you you've probably
built your application around its
abstractions and so uh you want me to
move over okay I got a subtle hint that
I should move over you want me to keep
going okay perfect is this
better uh wonderful uh so uh yeah so um
you know if you build around those types
of abstractions you can kind of
hamstring yourself uh eventually if if
if it doesn't end up working out for you
uh and so like another way that I like
to look at this is when it comes to like
dependencies in general like let's say
that you have like a very high value
project like you could have a high value
project or a low value project right
some you're messing around all the
weekend or you could have something that
you're trying to build a business on top
of and you know within that category you
have like you know low skills or high
skills uh and you know if you don't know
anything about uh you know about
interacting with databases or you know
uh keeping you know data around and and
F and and easily accessible then you
might want to buy something and that's
fine um but I think one of the things
that I would like to you know kind of
pait today is that um indexing ethereum
like it actually isn't that hard I don't
think and uh and I I'll throw like a
couple things kind of at you uh to kind
of encourage you to like if if you're if
you happen to be in this category of
you're working on a high value project
but maybe your skills aren't there I
think that there's absolutely stuff that
you can do to advance your skills so
that you can build something that you're
really proud of um and then on the other
end of the spectrum it's like okay
you've got a high value project you have
high skills um and and and here um I
think it's like very important to build
it actually uh and if it matches your
the core competency of the company or
the project that you're working on and I
think the the the most important thing
here is that like when it comes to
thinking about dependencies is like you
don't want to Outsource your thinking
you want to kind of come up with your
own opinion and like your own motivation
for why you're doing a particular thing
with your data and you and and when you
build it you're forced to think about it
and you're forced to lay lay something
out that you think is going to match
what the business
needs um okay so you got a low value
project and you have low skills you know
I say just jam it together you know you
do whatever you know find the quickest
path to get the thing online and that's
fine um if you've got a low value
project but you have high skills I think
actually kind of both can work um and
the way that I kind of think about this
is you know if if you form an opinion of
how you like you know you're working in
in a particular problem landscape and
you come up with your own opinion for
how you want to build a solution and
then like you maybe do some shopping you
say like oh wow there's a couple
projects that already exist that are
doing the thing that I would do uh and
so in this particular case you're not
Outsourcing your thinking you're
Outsourcing the maintenance of that
softw software which is like a real
Advantage um and so even if you're you
know even if you you have the skills uh
you know it really is a tossup in terms
of whether you build versus
buy okay so part two I'm going to go
over this um essential indexing pattern
uh and like I said I've used this for
probably I don't know five or six years
I've worked on some pretty big websites
uh in the ethereum space and this is the
pattern that really has worked well for
me so I'm going to share it with you
today and it's basically um there is
this old Fred Brooks quote that says um
uh you know show me your flowcharts and
I'll continue to be mystified show me
your tables and I won't need your
flowcharts uh and so I like to start
with the tables first um and and and so
like the the building block here is that
you have a table called blocks and you
keep track of the number and hash of the
block and then you have all these
auxiliary tables like Fu which is like
your indexed data arbitrary data that
you want to
index okay so now here's like a wall of
code uh but basically like this is like
the core function I and I won't like go
into every painstaking detail here but
this is like the core function that uses
those two tables to effectively index
data on ethereum and uh you
know it it it uses some like you can
kind of see here there's some RPC code
going on there's some database code
going on uh in particular this thing
down here at the bottom this copy logs
uh that's like a really cool postgress
technique that allows you to really
really quickly load data into a table um
and so again like I'm not going to go
through the whole detail here but I
wanted to show you this because it's
actually like I'm I'm I'm saying like
this can get you very very far and in
fact you can even just kind of copy and
paste this uh into a project to kind of
help bootstrap you and get you started
um and uh at some point like I might
even throw this on a gist or something
you know so that so that you know
someone could like copy and paste this
and we'll make it work and compile and
stuff because right now it doesn't but
it's it's more or less there
um okay so another thing with pointing
out is that like the current like like
kind of highle architecture of uh of uh
of ethereum indexers kind of fits into
this first category um and so basically
like I said earlier you know we have
these sources of data like an RPC API or
an execution client uh but they don't
really give us the type of interface
that we'd want when it comes to building
queries for our applications Source uh
we it's like an ETL workload right we
extract the data from The Source we
transform it and then we stick it in
another database that gives us flexible
query so that we can build stuff onto
our apps it's fine pattern it's like
what the graph uses it's like it's a
very common pattern in the space um I
think that there's another pattern
though down here at the bottom which I'm
more interested in which is um you know
how can we like just continue pushing
like our query logic onto the source
data and and instead of having ETL uh we
just have query to the database um and I
think that's a whole interesting path um
to explore and I've got some ideas there
and would be happy to talk about it but
um I I just want to kind of call that
out okay so part three we're coming in
here on the end uh I'm going to go into
some postgress tricks um and then real
another Poll for the audience here uh
who uses
postgress okay wow qu quite a bit of
people this is by far the biggest um
yeah the biggest uh positive affirmation
of a poll that we've done so far is
about like I would say like 70% maybe
75% okay great so um so so you've got
the essential indexing pattern you've
got the architecture what are some like
here's like a quick checklist of like
really good features to use when it
comes to indexing ethereum first one is
copy uh uh show hands here do who know
who uses
copy okay few let's say like 10 to 20%
okay so if you are inserting more than
let's say three rows at a time and
you're using insert you are way wasting
compute Cycles it it it is is massively
inefficient There is almost practically
zero downside to using copy so if
there's one thing that you walk with
today and you're a postgress user and if
you're ever inserting more than let's
say three rows like move over to the
binary copy and you will instantly see a
Major Performance boost um advisory
locks another really cool feature in
postgress so uh it's an in-memory uh
lock that you can use so it's very cheap
you can have thousands of them maybe
even hundreds of thousands of them them
and this is a really nice way if you
want to build an indexer and you want to
have two of them and you want to perhaps
like run them in a ha configuration but
you only have want to have one doing the
work at a time and advisory lock is a
great feature to use um another feature
that I like is table partitioning um and
so we'll kind of explore this a little
bit in my next tip um but basically um
you can loot you can take like a table
uh and you can specify a partition key
on that table and then you can specify
how many part itions you want to run
like let's say 10 and postgress will
automatically create 10 child tables for
you and then when you query The Logical
table it'll automatically find the right
partition table to uh to get the data
from and this is like completely opaque
uh you don't have to deal do do any of
this stuff in your application uh and it
gives you a really nice performance
boost when you are bounded by disio uh
and and so let me kind of show you how
to kind of think about like when you may
be uh dis iob bound um so to to do that
I'll quickly introduce a Brin index show
a hands who who knows about a Brin
index even fewer this might be the
smallest number but I see you out there
and I and bless you um because this is a
this is a very fantastic index for some
use cases um so basically like when you
have a table and you put data in that
table uh postgress will put like if you
insert a row into a table postgress will
take that row and it'll end up in a file
on the file system postgress by default
uses 8 kiloby file sizes so that means
that it's going to be spreading your
rows across multiple files on your file
system uh what a Brin index will do is
uh it will uh basically if you have a
column that has a high correlation like
so for example an ethereum block number
would be a high correlation to the way
that your data was going to be laid out
on disk if you do an insert only a
pinned kind of right style so if you're
just like keeping up with the blockchain
and you're writing data and you're
putting the block number in those rows
then like as you store stuff on dis it's
going to correlate with the block number
right and so this is a great use case
for a Brin index because what you do is
you have this super tiny index much
smaller than a b tree and it keeps like
we have like this page block up here
that says okay in this page block zero I
have block number Z to 9 99,000 and
those rows are stored in Pages Zer and
one and so you basically have like this
top level like higher level index that
like you know for a given block number
it can basically redirect you to the
right set of pages to read in the
operating system um and so let me
quickly show uh we've got about two
minutes left uh let me quickly show you
so here's an example so I have I have
this table called logs you can see I got
a block num column there um this table's
about four gigs uh and then you can see
I I I checked the correlation of the
block number it said 80 to 99% and I
quered it like earlier this morning and
it was saying 99% and then all of a
sudden it just stopped saying 99% and
started saying 83% and so that I became
very angry um but that is what it is uh
so uh I think it's wrong but that is I'd
like to find that stuff out later um
okay so here's another cool postgress
tip if you're writing queries you got to
figure out like the the explain command
it's like it is literally life saving
like get to know this command and you
will become a great database
administrator so you can see here uh we
hit a bunch of blocks uh about 500,000
buffers so multiply that by 8 kilobytes
that's how much data that we read you
see I created the Brin index and you can
see that index size is only 320
kilobytes and I had a 4 GB table so very
small index and then the resulting query
after that is I only had to read about
42,000 buffers um so like a massive
decrease in the amount of IO that was
going to happen there um I'm just going
to go ahead and show you what a b tree
index uh would do which is like your
default index so you can see here it's a
much bigger uh you know we went from 320
kilobytes uh B tree index is 250
megabytes much bigger index uh but you
can see down here it's just you know
game over B indexes are really great um
you know much faster much fewer fewer
buffers uh but sometimes you don't need
um sometimes you don't need to have uh
that level of performance and you might
want to trade off storage size also it's
very quick like if I have a terabyte
table and I create a berry index over a
block num it's actually going to take a
long time because it's gonna seek scan
that whole table a Brin index will
happen much much much much much faster
so even if you're in a pinch and you're
trying to like find some data and in a
big table and you don't want to wait to
create a be tree creating a Brin might
actually be a good stop Gap uh another
postgress little bit of you know tidbit
of knowledge is that um you know you
have a a b tree index uh and and and
that is going to have a ton of data in
it and you might say like when you're
doing a query and you have a huge table
and you have a huge index um does does
posters have to load the entire index
into memory to be able to do the search
of the berry to be able to find the
right rows to return to you the answer
that question is no and I thought this
is kind of like a fun fact but uh in the
docs it says um you know typically when
you have a b tree index so if you have
an index it's let like you had a table
that's a terabyte you got an index it's
like 100 gigs 99% of that is going to be
the leaves which means that when you
want to go search that table uh before
like you need to find like the uh the
target rows you're actually going to uh
be able to keep that that index in
memory because you know the majority of
the data that you're going to be
searching on is going to be very small
um okay so time is about up so I didn't
oh man I'm really bummed I really wanted
to talk about
CDs um and I didn't um but it's really
cool because uh whenever you quer I'll
just briefly mention it whenever you
query a table you can always ask for a
seed it's a hidden column on a row and
it tells you what page and what offset
into the page that particular row is in
um and then there's some cool things
that you can do with clustering uh to uh
you know if you want to rearrange uh
rows as they sit on disk for improved IO
performance you can do that with cluster
although it's not an online tool you
would have to recluster if you wanted to
change it um yeah so uh okay Whirlwind
tour there uh but that's it I wanted to
kind of plug a foraster we have a
postgress channel and I uh I encourage
you if you're interested in any of this
stuff check out the postgress channel um
there's a lot of good discussion
happening on there so thank you very
much thank you R um question time so the
audience have some questions for you and
we're going to go through it the most
high
reorgs yes uh so that code that I showed
earlier handles reorgs uh it was in
there uh and and so um you know maybe
you got a photo of it or maybe we can I
can post it on on gist or whatever but
but there there are very easy ways to
handle reorgs it's not that big of a
deal don't let it scare you um yeah we
can definitely we can definitely solve
that
problem um so first question one PTA one
p for us was hand blah so five votes it
means that's the most important question
now on the stage so can you answer that
one F yeah we just did that one so I
think the next one would be uh how to
deal with load balance rpcs yeah yeah so
it's kind of a also kind of a pain in
the ass basically you send a request to
an API you say give me the latest block
and it's like the latest block is 10 and
then and then you say okay great now
give me all the logs for Block 10 but
it's load balance so it goes to a
different node and the the awful thing
the the the the sin of the uh Json RPC
API is that if you ask for logs and you
give it a block number that is higher
than the block that it's currently
processed you would think it would say
hey I don't have that block I don't have
these logs you know error it does not do
that in fact it'll just give you no data
back as if it had that block but had did
not have those logs um and so this is a
big gotcha and you really have to look
out for this there are a couple tricks
I'll just go ahead and give you one now
um but it's like 50% success rate I
don't think there's a
100% way to deal with this but one hack
is the Json RPC API allows you to send
batch requests and sometimes there are
proxies that will take batch requests
and split them up and give them to
different nodes but assuming your API
provider doesn't do that and it just
takes the batch of requests and sends
them to one machine you could hack this
by putting your git logs request with a
get block number request because if you
ask for a block number buy a specific
number and that block number isn't on
that node it will return an error so
this is like one way to trick the node
into giving you an error when you ask
for logs and you don't have the block so
there's a couple other Solutions I think
but um yeah we'll keep cruising here
yeah you think okay do you think it
makes sense to have an index or
interoperability I don't I I don't I
don't know about number one that first
question I'm going to go on so what do
you think about using click house or
times oh that's interesting yeah so I
mean here's the deal if you want to do
like a group buy or you want to do like
a count or a sum over like a million
rows or yeah over a million rows like if
if if you want one column over a lot of
rows you might want a column or database
uh and the idea there is that you are
wanting to Red like so so instead of
like you know if you don't have a commer
database and you have to like get the
the the value out of a row that means
that you have to go scan a whole bunch
of operat system table pages to get all
of the rows but really you only care
about one and so you know for doing like
an aggregate or something uh and so uh
so that's a lot of wasted IO right and
so the idea is can we do better and so
for very specific use cases when you
want to do aggregated stuff a columnar
database might save you from a lot of
that IO so you know it is a way to
improve performance if what you're
trying to do is uh like more analytical
queries that that you know works on
aggregated data so not great for olp
stuff but yeah if you have AG Fine one
minute to go um let's see do you think
it makes sense to have an index oh I
already did that one I didn't have an
answer there can you explain better why
a Bren index is so much smaller than a b
tree uh yeah because um a b tree is
going to have like some knowledge of
every Row in the table right like every
Row in the table is going to have uh
like a some map onto the index structure
whereas a Brin is like lossy right so
like like I in a Brin index I have one
node in the index but that one node in
the index can actually cover let's say
100,000 rows right it can say Hey you
know you're quering for block number 10
and I and the Bren index says okay well
I know that block number 10 is like in
this block of operating system Pages uh
and so then you you have to then go like
basically sequential scan within that
set of pages but at least you're not
scanning on the entire table right so
it's like the Brit index is small
because it just simply has less
information uh but but it can cut you
know if you're just trying to get rid of
a sequential scan like it it definitely
can like cut out a a sequential scan so
all thank you so much SM thank you for
having us please keep me thank
you oh wow
interesting um the next session is going
to be a Kos speak by
okay so we have 2 minutes
break um just to move around stretch
your leg 2 minutes we are back on
stage at
2:30 thank you
[Music]
for
she
[Music]
welcome come
back everyone GM GM once again help me
welcome Justin who is going to have a 20
minute keynote on the
team the universal cryptographic adapter
and Justin is the man to do this so in
the next 20 minutes the man you're going
to hear is Justin and Justin this is the
audience please wel on stage and engage
your audience thank you
[Music]
hello so after Ryan talked about data
we're going to talk about data
um so to kind of like situate ourselves
a little bit in I have 60 slides you
can't go through 60 slides without
knowing why you're here because
otherwise you'll just like lose
attention and collect frogs so um zerre
thesis for Data Systems is that
essentially in like one sentence
programmable cryptography so zero not
proof FH officiation enables what we
call the universal data adapter which is
in some way like the touring machine
moment for data what I mean by the
turing machine moment is it's we think
we basically finally have an abstraction
that's powerful enough such that it's
not like a marginal Improvement it's
like an order of magnitude improvements
the same way electrical circuits
basically could got turn into like
extremely powerful beasts when we
figured out how to program them and make
them General it was not like an
improvement at the physics level it was
an improvement at the Al model level so
um another way to say that is we think
cryptography is a way to get more out of
data and most people will tell you that
cryptography is a way to make data more
private or whatever I think that that's
a great side effect but deeper than that
cryptography is a way to get more out of
data essentially make data more
interoperable be able to get data out of
their silos reap more economical
benefits out of data and it's pretty
important because we live in a world
where the value of data keeps increasing
over time um one way we we like to put
it is we take data out of their data
today if you want your data to be safe
and secure it's useless uh you have to
like kind of like keep it for yourself
and and it applies equally for like
individuals who want to do self custody
but also for companies like why keep
your data on your Linux server if you
can put it in the one big database you
know because the one big database will
like give you more value out of that so
there's kind of like this push and pull
between people want to keep their data
kind of like away in some sense in in in
a secure environment but that's
equivalent to a prison you know you
can't go screw with the inmates but
inmates are not useful to society um and
and another way yet to say that is
enables more interoperability in usage
of
data um so our goal is to create more
total value out of this and at the same
time enable a pragmatic route towards
data ownership in a world where data
keeps increasing in value because if
data keeps increasing in value the
burden of proof for going through that
route keeps increasing okay so this is
kind of like the tldr on the data stack
we have so far um we have pods which are
essentially specially issued packets of
cryptographic data almost like a record
in a database we have these
cryptographic machines called gpcs that
ingest pods and make claims about them
using zero knowledge proof and the
really interesting thing with this
system is it's performant enough to run
on mobile browsers uh while being
flexible and it's close to being
production ready and all of you guys are
using it uh Zupas where your tickets are
and your frogs are is running on pods
and gpcs so as an example a def gun
ticket is a pod a frog is a pod I use
GPC to log in into the telegram group
where you had to prove you had a ticket
when you enter the Frog Zone downstair
you also make a GPC so this stuff just
works and there is a huge like not huge
but there's there's definitely a list of
like on top of that like third party
application that is built on top of this
system mostly from the zalu ecosystem so
here's the tldr the way it works is some
authority attachs to some data and signs
it via an EDSA signature on the jobjob
curve this gives you a pod you take a
bunch of PODS you put them into a GPC
and you make a claim that is verifiable
and then you can get hand that over to a
verifier that's essentially how it works
um we'll go into the details so the
issuer basically calls this like pod.
sign method on a bunch of key value data
you get out of it this thing with a
signature that is on the content ID
we'll focus on the date of birth here
for the sake of the example then you
configure a GPC config which makes a
claim about the date of birth for this
example here it's not revealed and we
prove that it's between a minimum and a
maximum and finally a verifier receives
the artifact from the proof and can
verify that claim and a really cool
thing is you don't need any new zero
knowledge circuits it's pretty flexible
and also extremely performant right so
we have this system we've been working
on it for a year um and you can go check
it out tomorrow uh at classroom B at
2:30 p.m. um but last summer we wanted
more out of our system like this is
pretty sweet but we think this is far
from being the best we can do so if we
look back at this Paradigm I just showed
you um there's a bunch of limitations
the first one is we need specially
issued data what this means is we need
to convince data testers to like change
the way they issue data which is not
very pragmatic it's limited to one round
of computation you can take pods put a
GPC on top but what you get out of is
not another pod it's like this thing
that you can't keep Computing over and
finally it's very much limited to single
player use cases what I mean is when you
create this GPC proof you actually need
to know all the input pods which means
that if you try to do it together with
multiple people one person will know all
the inputs so this is not compatible
with the world we're in today if we're
pragmatic about deploying this Beyond
you know things like zalu Defcon Etc um
first there's a lot of cryptographic
data yet it's very heterogenous um stuff
that comes out of trusted execution
environment blockchains email transport
layer Security National ID systems Etc
all of this is cryptographic but it
follows different schemas different
signature schemes Etc um basic use cases
often require more than two rounds of
transformation like you want to
transform youra multiple time across
multiple people and we think that
there's a whole world that might open up
if it's actually possible to go more
than two rounds if you think about the
internet today we we never have like
platforms that go more than two levels
deep you know it's like we're building
on on top of mud huts and we dream of
skyscrapers we don't really know what's
going to happen if we can go deeper than
that um there is a lot of work on domain
specific system uh from the cryptography
perspective but yet there's absolutely
no interoperability over the last 18
months none of the ZK ID systems
actually work with each other you know
so it's pretty interesting like why and
from the programable cryptography
perspective the unlock of zero n proof
is trustless refactoring and import
right that's that's the right way to
think about it not as like a way to hide
data in my opinion um and you can use it
to now create a universal system for
making Claim about the world's data and
the unlock of um fully homomorphic
encryption or coar MPC is now you can
combine that data confidentially so we
want to put together a system that makes
use of these Primitives and is like
situated in a world like this without
being wishful thinking about like oh no
the whole world is going to like issue
pods with EDS jujub signature whatever
like that's not going to happen so um
what we want is we want verifiable and
interoperable computational graph so we
want to import data asample emails API
calls this is like a mobile driver
license from the state of California we
want to turn that into pods we want to
compute at arbitrary depth with an
arbitrary number of participants on this
data and finally we want to export a
view of this data to a verifier that can
check the Integrity of all the
computational graph and the Integrity of
all the Imports via like a single
succinct proof right that's where we
want to get to and so that that's
putting it together again the goal for a
second version of the stack is we want
to be able to introduce anything
trustless and the reason trustless is
important it's not because we think that
oh like you're going to be censored when
you like import your like RuneScape
character or something like that it's
more like if it's trustless it's
scalable because any computer can do it
as opposed to having like some
bottleneck in the system somewhere we
want deep computational graph because
actually today we've never really seen
what would happen if many parties were
to be able to operate on a piece of data
and kind of like pass it along right
most of the time you have data that gets
ingested by one big group of people and
then it gets consumed that's it um and
we also want to do it between multiple
people while maintaining confidentiality
because we think this is how you can tap
into much bigger economic output okay so
the first challenge we had when we fac
this which I think not many people have
thought about this is probably the most
interesting challenge is program
composability so imagine you have a list
of friends
um it's probably like a list of PODS
that if you receive like each of your
friends sign something saying they're
your friends you can put in a program
here it's some Rust but anyone can read
this which counts the amount of best
friend you have best friend is just like
a a property of friend and you get out
13 now you take this and you put into
another function that says hey do you
have a great friend groups which counts
how many best friend you have here it
just counts is it bigger or equal than
three and you get a bul out true or
false okay seems simple enough here's
how it looks like more abstractly you
have some parts that going to program a
gets a part out go into program B get a
part out okay so assuming we can do this
cryptographically what problem remains
well the main issue is if you have a
program that operates over the output of
a different program you need program B
to understand program a right either via
static analysis either via formal proofs
but program B needs to know what program
a does so unless you write program B
after having written program a and kind
of like hardcode the link between them
it's really hard for a program to make
sense of the output of another program
if I tell you 42 and I tell you how it
was computed it's really hard for you to
know even what the significance of that
output is and we don't really think like
that most of the time like when people
say oh we'll have ZK VMS and we can
solve everything the main issue is that
yeah good luck now doing static analysis
and kind of like trying to make sense of
other programs and at the end of the day
it reduces to the holding problem so
what we did is we threw away the CPU
model and we went to logic um and we
threw away the up codes and we moved to
logical operation so instead of a
virtual machine buil on risk five or
something like that we buildt a logic
virtual machine we replaced memory slots
with logical statements so statements
like a is greater than b or there exist
C such that c is part of D we replace up
code with logical operation so as an
example a is smaller than b implies a is
not equal b or if you have a defined as
10 and B defined as 10 you can derive a
equals B all of these are like B basic
logical operations uh data becomes
theorems um programs become proofs uh
not the kind of proofs that you know
about if you're a cryptographer
different kind of proofs now we're going
to mix all the words together um it's
like a pretty interesting way to look at
the system essentially what we have is
data that gets imported are axioms
they're combined into a logic like
through logic proof they get combined
into a theorem and then more theorems
can build theorems right so the
interesting thing with that is all of
mathematics is already built on that
principle which is every time we prove
something we can prove more out of it
and we don't need to understand what has
been done so far like mathematics is
truly interoperable in a way that
programs are not um
so if we get back to this example you
know after we've counted how many best
friends you have and want to know
whether you have a great friend group
what this turns into is you have a
theorem and through another logic proof
you get yet another theorem in plain
English you would have theorem blue I
have 12 best friends uh implies theorem
green I have more than three best
friends makes sense right um so now we
have two kinds of proof in the system we
have a formal proof and with a zero
knowledge proof the ZK proof is used to
show that the formal proof was computed
correctly and high some inputs about it
right you want to be able to say I have
more than three friends without showing
who your friends are right so um and you
can you can kind of like go arbitrary
deep here you have theorems you make
proofs out of that you get a new theorem
you combine that with a previous theorem
maybe for someone else to make more
theorem it's so forth here's how it
looks like in a very early version of
our system so these are statements these
are the actual things that are inside a
pod so the most basic statement is the
value of statement which is that the
value of an entry is this like the value
of is best friend is true in the
specific pod this is how most people
think of cryptographic data they just
have the value of statement they don't
have anything else but then we added a
bunch of other stuff like the equal
statement which is this entry is equals
that entry uh or the sum of statement
which says that the sum of the two um
the entry number two and three in the
two pole equals entry number one and
this is like a very early version that
we had but you can imagine extending
this to something that is powerful
enough to essentially prove anything in
first or second order logic um and these
are our up codes as an example we have
the equality for entries up code which
says hey if you have entry one and entry
two you can apply the equality from
entries up code only if entry 1 equals
entry 2 to get a statement that says
entry 1 equals entry2 uh so what what we
had to do from a cryptography
perspective is essentially build a
circuit that instead of proving the
state transition of a CPR architecture
proves The Logical operations on
statement is done correctly right it's a
cryptographically verified theorem
prover if you want okay so the Second
Challenge we had is um we want to be
able to import data from the real world
because we don't expect people changing
the way they issue data it was already
sufficiently hard to get them to export
cryptographic data in the first place
good luck coming back to them and
telling them they did it the wrong way
so what this turns into is you want to
be able to turn any verifiable piece of
data into a set of value of statement
with special metadata as an example who
signed it what was the URL if it comes
from like a web proof when was it signed
Etc right and then you can further
combine these into any other pod using
the logic um so what if I want a
computer with one of my frog right you
guys have frogs I hope you have frogs if
you don't have frogs you're a loser you
need to go get frogs um frogs are pod
ones pod ones as I was showing earlier
was the first version of our
cryptographic uh data system from the
perspective of pod two they're foreign
cryptographic objects they're on
different curves with different signing
algorithms they're merized in in a
different way yet they can be imported
via what we call an introduction Gadget
so you have this introduction Gadget
that is going to verify the EDSA Sig is
correct it's going to store the signer
into a value of statement with key undor
signer and it's going to copy each of
the Pod one entry into a value of
statement and then you get a pod and the
cool thing is now you can take two frogs
you can introduce them and then you can
make a proof about them you can say uh
Todd is more beautiful than the ma
mustache tote that's something you can
prove with the system after you've
introduced the data um and the first
thing we want to do is be able to import
emails um we want to be able to import
like regular API calls and and probably
deal with one of the the the government
issued ID system uh but then over time
you can imagine importing things from
ethereum importing things from Virtual
Worlds importing bank accounts receipts
or even like actual mathematical proves
and keeping generating statement about
these Okay the third challenge we had is
making building easy um this is what it
looks like to put together a sequence of
logical op codes and it's extremely
gnarly don't ask us why we have strings
it should be pointers um it's a whole
story um and making sense of PODS or
crafting them becomes very tedious and
easy to get wrong right right the users
of the system need to craft a sequence
of logical up code to make a new pods
but on top of that they need to make
sure that the statements they get out
when they receive a pod actually match
what they're asking to be proven if you
get this you know all of these logical
statements like how do like it's hard to
know whether this actually proves that
the person matches the claim you're
trying to like verify so what we did is
we put together a a little lisp it's a
logic programming language to create
pods and verify them uh it's a list
because it's really easy to write a list
versus other kinds of programming
languages and it has an interactive
development Loop um here's what it looks
like so here I'm just making a pod
technically this is an introduction
Gadget because I'm making data out of
nowhere so I I say hey key age is 26 zip
code is such ID is such and what I get
is a bunch of value of statements
including a magic one you know the
underscore signer one which ons to who
created it and then I can make more pods
out of it so let's go through an example
here I'm going to make a pod that says I
have both an ID card and a past tub
where the user user ID is the same on
both and my age is over 18 and uh I
think that's about it and I reveal my
salary right so first what I'll do is
I'll for another part that has a salary
a Time stem issue in an ID and I'm going
to reveal zip code salary time stem
issued by with the same key name and I'm
going to make some assertions that ages
over 18 and then I do a drawing I say ID
card ID and PB ID are the same the cool
thing is I'm going to able to to prove
that ID card ID and ptop ID are the same
without revealing the ID that's the
thing that's very powerful about it what
I get out is a bunch of statement
and um you kind of have to trust me on
this because it's small enough but the
ID is not revealed in the part itself
the fourth challenge we had is multi
party pod creation so today if you're on
the right side like the little Smiley
guy there the red pods are private right
you only see what's in the yellow pod
but if you're the person on the left and
you're putting the proof together you
actually leak you get leaked the the
input pods so what we want to be able to
do is entally put a box around proof
calculation I'm I'm talking about the
formal proof not the zi proof
such that the input pots are not leaked
across the party right and um we were
hoping to get a demo of this by Defcon
but of course um it did not happen the
rest happen but not that um so the way
you solve this is you execute logical
operation into either a multiparty fhe
or or something like verifiable Garb
build circuit or or coar um in order to
do this you also need to crack
verifiable fully homomorphic encryption
without multiplicate of overhead which
is tricky I won't talk too much about
this but if you're interested come to
the programmable cryptography see less
on Friday so that's part two it's a
system that can import data um that is
cryptographic regular where it comes
from enables deep computational graphs
and then you can you can export whatever
view you want on the data with a suing
proof to a verifier um it's logic based
both for its claim and its operation um
and has a bunch of cool features it's in
active development right now we hope
we'll have a production ready version by
end of 25 and we'll probably go through
a bunch of pilot throughout the year if
you're interested to learn more about it
uh so first if you're interested in pod
one which you can use right now to build
stuff it's tomorrow at classroom B at
2:30 p.m. and if you're interested in
part two and peex we're running a pretty
long and interesting uh workshop on
Friday at 12:30 pm at the programmable
cryptography CLS so I'll keep the the C
codes up for a little bit um and then
I'll be done so thanks
[Applause]
guys thank you so much Justin and we
have a ton of questions so looking
through the questions and start
answering them we have three
minutes oh so you're not going to read
the question I have to do the work okay
cool all right uh you mentioned first
order logic also second order those are
not computable Logics they're just
computable and numerable what am I
missing then because you're Computing
for sure this this is true so our logic
so far is a bastard logic it's a logic
that is not actually the kind of logic
that logicians use so an active area of
research is figuring out how do we
essentially like have a logical system
that is also computable in a way that
it's like as sound and complete as
possible and um if you have asked that
question please come talk to me because
we're very interested in that so great
question running this is the browser
means you need to trust the server to
serve a non-compromised version of the
software uh how will this work in
practice are we going to have an open
ster for pod processing um okay so if we
go down to the level of like well you
have to trust the software you use I
have a bad news for you which is it's a
problem for all of the industry so far
so the way you'll solve this is the way
you'll solve everything else so I don't
think I want to answer this
question what's
next can you scroll or
something no they'll scroll it from
there I got there late what is this for
um it's for making data useful Beyond
this stuff that we have right now where
we just store them in databases and we
sell them to open
AI okay I think that's it thank thank
you all right thank you so much Justin
for this session um we have some
break uh we have 5 minutes break but
before you go thank you for your time if
you're here you're developing something
we need to move Beyond just building a
tech and looking for application I'm
building the biggest human layer in
Africa if you want to see how this
technology is solving problem you need
to visit Africa or Argentina let's do
this and I hope you have good time in
Devcon thank you thank you see you
[Music]
again e
to
[Music]
for
you oh
[Music]
for
the
[Music]
for
hey guys can you hear me
okay sounds like you can um my name's
Heidi and I'm gonna actually be your MC
for the next three hours over the next
three hours we're going to be talking
lots of different things scaling l2s and
my favorite which is cyppher punk but
what's funny about that is that uh I'm
actually from coinbase funny enough so
some of you guys might get a laugh out
of that being into the cyppher punk
style stuff anyways we've got a really
good lineup of people here um but before
we talk about that we should probably
talk about where the bathrooms are if
you guys haven't gotten up in a while go
up and stretch but the bathroom is if
you walk past stage five over here and
then turn the corner that's where it is
um and then uh yeah one other thing that
I want to remind people of is that you
can participate in the Q&A as well so
how do you go about doing that well you
scan that QR code now if you're
privacy-minded like me you're probably
sketched out by QR codes and that's
perfectly fine you can also access it in
the Devcon app which is what I usually
do and uh go and ask your uh questions
and we'll have a Q&A at the end so
without further Ado I'd like to welcome
TT onto the stage who will talk about
autonomous
worlds good afternoon
[Music]
all right my name is tat I'm a software
engineer at
Lis um and um yeah I'm about to talk
about bring you on our journey uh
basically building the best
infrastructure for autonomous worlds and
mud
apps okay um so I will start by talking
a little bit bringing a little bit of
context uh for those who don't know what
m is and what are autonomous worlds I
will then kind of describe some design
patterns that we um learned about while
we were fa uh essentially solving
problems for mud apps uh and how
basically we solve them uh and then I'll
be describing uh a new system that we're
prototyping uh you might have gotten
sneak peek already if you catch if you
caught alvarus talk earlier um on mud so
yeah stay tuned
okay um so if you're not familiar with
lattice uh we've been promoting a vision
for onchain games to basically develop
properties of a thing that we call
autonomous worlds uh who knows who here
knows what autonomous world is or has an
idea okay that's quite a lot of people
who knows about
mud all right that that's good uh but so
we're all on the same page um I'll give
my quick definition of it um
essentially um whoa things are moving um
so when I say autonomous worlds what I
mean is like permissionless Virtual
Worlds that are seated by initial teams
who are then joined by early adopters
who build on top of it until the plot
evolves Beyond anyone's single control
and then complex drama and social
components emerge um and to enable
autonomous worlds we've built mud on
ethereum so that world Builders could
have robust Primitives to implement
their vision and build fully onchain
gaming loops and then onchain games are
well too expensive to run on ethereum
Main net so we needed a cheap chain with
Big Blocks and uh infinitely scalable da
um so we basically um added that feature
to the op stack and deployed it as a
chain called Redstone and on top of
redstone we're also running uh free
services for mud apps like public rpcs
and indexers
and actually to give you a little
context this is a screenshot of cwi's
public rollup dashboard um and if you
look at the top six l2s um you can see
except from Bas all of these l2s are
mostly focused on onchain games uh so
these are like all the meag gas per
second that is here uh so all these
rollups are ranked by megag gas per
second and you can see all of them that
have extremely high megag per second are
basically um have have onchain games
deployed on it um and actually it's kind
of interesting too is redstone doesn't
have that much transaction per second
but its Mega gas per second is very high
that means that mud transactions are
actually storing a lot of data on chains
so they're actually quite big so that's
why we needed uh Redstone so to have a
chain with very big blocks and a lot of
gas and so that um mud mud apps would
stay
cheap so some applications
um that launched on or are about to
launch on Redstone um if you didn't
haven't caught the eve uh talk earlier
by Hillmar and Justin but I'll talk a
little bit this e froner is a part of
the E online universe so they designed
an incredibly sophisticated World
physics and are progressively bringing
components on chain over the next few
years you know they're here for the long
term so build this can basically
Implement business Logic permissionless
on top of it um so if you missed the
talk earlier recommend you go back and
check it out um and then biomes is
bringing Minecraft physics on chain with
the with new types of creative gaming
Loops um and they have very intensive
requirements to enable multiplayer
they're currently on Redstone mayet
actually most of the the gas that you
saw on the dashboard earlier is coming
from biome so very excited about um this
world um and while these teams develop
the physics and they seed the worlds
with the origin stories and the gaming
Loop uh um it is when people can build
on top without permission and extend the
world with new experiences that
properties of autonomous world really
emerge uh so we like to call more
technical users who extend the worlds
sewage hackers because they get their
hands dirty and they need access to
lower level infrastructure Primitives
such as indexers RPC apis to power um
their applications and you know it's
like most inhabitants of a city they
don't need or they don't concern
themselves with the sewers but they're
crucial part of these very dense
environments if your sewers stop working
you're you're pretty
um okay so I'll go over some
requirements um we want to enable worlds
where multi multiple players can
interact with the state at the same time
uh we want low friction for inhabitants
uh so that they can they don't have to
pay uh expensive transaction fees we
want to stay evm compatible so that uh
apps can be compatible with other chains
and other tooling that's in the e
ecosystem uh and lastly we want this to
be super easy for mud users to um
integrate so they shouldn't have to
rewrite their apps or add complex client
logic if you're using mud all the tools
that we built uh work out of the
box okay so one of the things that we
worked on was um enabling mud apps to
deploy on Main net with a futureproof
data availability solution so um we
actually worked with optimism to um
I mean we designed and we implemented a
plasma da protocol uh in order not to
use blobs there's actually a talk right
now in the other stage where they're
discussing are blobs cool uh we thought
blobs are not that cool so I mean we
like blobs but we wanted something
that's more future proof and infinitely
scalable if you had more chains um and
so we worked with optimism uh and to
Upstream this in the code base and this
is known as Alda mode and um are
specific
da layer uses a plasma design so that
stakeholders can have an emergency exit
hatch where they can challenge data if
they believe the data is missing and
they you can basically keep the chain
running while you withdraw your funds uh
and if you want to know more about how
this system works I recommend you check
the uh optimism uh
specs actually a fun fact too is once we
decided to launch Redstone we were doing
some uh load testing and we ended up
Breaking the Chain on test net um
because we had too much data and uh we
started with a very large block size 100
milon gas and uh the op stack limits
were not large enough to enable this
kind of payload size uh so we actually
collaborated to with the opack core
developers to raise this limits that was
introduced in the for Network upgrade um
and it was really easy to ship quickly
because we control the full
infrastructure um by running the chain
ourselves instead of adding
intermediaries like roll up as a service
providers uh so it allows us to make
custom changes to the services and test
potential protocol protocol changes
directly um so we can observe the
effects on application directly uh
before they eventually get upstreamed in
the op
stack um and when we first running when
we started running the L2 chains so we
we had to you know learn how to run the
chain and do all that stuff and um we
quickly ran into bottlenecks because our
sequenc or node was busy building blocks
uh and handling RPC Quest so we did some
basic things like separating the read
and the wres um and essentially
eventually the Redstone sequence are
estate private we exposed another one
that was synced over peer-to-peer uh
then that node also got a bit
overwhelmed so we added another node and
split them by regions um now the problem
you face and actually you might have
heard Ryan talk about it in indexing is
you can end up with different states if
you have a load balancer in front of
your nodes um and there's actually
really cool way is that for example
optimism implemented a proxy D which
helps basically keep a health check Loop
so you can check that each of the nodes
has consistent State and you remove uh
them from the set if they they're
inconsistent and you have other goodies
like caching and uh rewriting reorgs um
and eventually we also wanted to have
better latency inside of um different
regions uh so we added you know uh DNS
load balancing so you basically you can
see here our user is in the south of
France he gets redirected to the Clos CL
region uh which then goes to our proxy
and low balancer and and a bunch of
nodes um so this is things that that we
um
implemented another aspect and um you if
you heard Ryan's talk earlier you
already probably know how to implement
your own indexer um but actually a
common bottleneck is by mud experience
by mud application is when the state
grows and users grows the initial load
of the game can be U very slow
especially when it's hydrated directly
from a not RP
so this is sold by loading U the initial
state from an indexer database we first
released an open source version of the
indexer so index um apps could index
their own world and we also wanted to
offer free indexing for all the mud
applications um and our first index or
implementation was kind of not as
performance it had limitations so we
collaborated with Ryan actually and Ryan
built ended up building most of the
indexer that that we're actually running
now um and it can scale for a whole
bunch of world so um
yeah okay another aspect that I learned
about recently myself is how ethereum
providers um like browser clients and
things like that they make a lot of
requests by default before sending a a
transaction and if you're far from the
RPC server the latency can add up um
some of these requests like estimate gas
they're also quite slow because they run
the the evm quite a bunch of times to
estimate the gas um so we made some
optimizations you can see here is is all
the by default you can be making as many
of these uh requests and so that that
ends up pretty pretty slow um so we met
some uh optimizations on the mud browser
clients so we added Ann manager which
only syns with the RPC when you need to
uh we made sure that transaction context
is pre-loaded so when you click you're
only sending the transaction you're not
doing a bunch of other things so that it
feels kind of Snappy and we're also
caching gas estimat so we don't actually
need to call gas estimate gas every time
uh and and and things like
that but you know um however you spread
read nodes across the world if you're
using an L2 at the end of the day um
transaction confirmations will always be
the fastest the closest you are to the
sequencer and you're going to have to
wait for the block time before you
actually get your confirmation um so if
you're running a sequencer in Europe uh
users in California and Japan are
getting pretty awful performance um and
the experience play in the game can be
very different from users we Clos to
sequencer um so what can we do to
improve this you know what how do we
scale um block building so one way we
could do this is we could have multiple
chains in multiple regions maybe they
could even be l3s you know or I mean
that could work maybe they with
optimism's interrup protocol if we want
to bring block buildings very close to
the user but there's going to be a lot
of chains you know you you don't want to
be running tons of different chains all
these different regions especially maybe
your users are moving so you just want
to be loading block building at the edge
wherever you need to so what if we could
run block building at the edge when
needed just for a piece of state and uh
for for example imagine you get matched
with different players in your area and
you start an ultra low latency game
match um and so I will preface this by
saying this is probably not the only
solution um but this is the one we're
currently validating as a prototype and
and so I'll I'll try to explain a little
bit how this is made so if you remember
the the preview here we're like actually
deploying block Builders directly on the
edge and we call them points of presence
like um for CDN and what they do is
essentially they act like a full
ethereum RPC but they only pull the
state they need from the Upstream in our
situation um the pups they just request
the latest version of the State uh and
if we need to write to that state a
point of presence can then acquire a
lock on it and this is handled at the
mud level because we have static ways of
determining you know which mud table the
pup needs to write to and then only the
pup can batch transaction to modify that
state and then they can send the
confirmations immediately without
waiting for the actual chain payload to
be built uh so P pup Builders can send
in transaction batches to the Upstream
uh eventually uh just in time before the
block get built um and then no other pop
Builder can modify that state so and
then you know you have basic CDN stuff
like the state locks are cleared you
know on least recently used basis um and
they're automatically cleaned up once
you have more data that comes in and and
your data has been stale for a
while um and then these are other
examples of things that you can speed up
once you can run them on the edge uh for
example when you're estimating the gas
or you're managing the nonces and so you
can have extremely precise gas estimates
uh by running them directly on the edge
you can have uh fresh non management
when you're singing it and you can do
even do uh ERC 4337 user op bundling on
the edge um and
so I mean this just accelerates a lot of
things and we we were uh when we were
testing this uh it actually ended up
getting to a very very good
performance actually I'll I'll show you
a little demo um I don't know if I if I
press play this will work okay cool um
so this we implemented this the this uh
this game just to demo this prototype uh
it is multiplayer every time you move
the fly this is a transaction that is
executed and a receipt that is sent back
to the browser so you can see like all
of these 20 milliseconds here um every
time you're executing a transaction and
getting the receipt back um and so I
this is still a prototype but if you
want to learn more and get to know
actually test the thing yourself get a
feel for it you can come to Mud day
tomorrow and actually experience the all
the games um and or learn more about how
all these things
works all right thanks for
[Applause]
listening Christian
did that was a great presentation I
noticed that no one had any questions in
the Q&A oh it's coming okay because I
was gonna front run you
guys no no no no no no no no no audience
first oh man okay I'm going to ask my
question then to fill the G time Gap
okay so this seems really awesome and
amazing but given my background I do a
lot of security research so all I see is
oh my God scaling extremely
quickly what are your thoughts around
security I mean obviously you have all
the security Assumption of the ethereum
protocol which are respected you know
we're part of the super chain we're
trying to do all these upgrades so
everything is that is basically touching
the ethereum protocol has the guarantees
of Alda chains from the op stack uh and
you know all of this is audited or like
has is reviewed by the opst uh team and
then um on the things that we control
then it's it looks more like uh Web Two
security where you have your servers and
your DNS and you know tlist all that
that kind of stuff so you do have
different kind of areas and and we have
different ways of of solving these
problems that are more specific to
either ethereum protocol or um basic you
know Services hosted
Services gotcha I have a lot more
questions offline but uh any other
questions since then okay I'll go for
the first one here so how are you in the
super chain with a custom da I mean the
differ we're not in the interrupt Set uh
just yet so I guess this would be um the
kind of slight differentiation um but
we're still kind of so we're not part of
the um upgrade set so we don't get the
RO the basic rollup upgrades uh but
we're in the super chain per se because
we're actually using the Upstream uh
protocol version of the protocol we're
not running a fork um and so all the
code that we run is basically um
reviewed by the op stack core
protocols what's next on the road map
for mud what features are most needed
next I mean I can speak for the
infrastructure part of things um yeah
what we're really trying to do here is
is get to this extremely extremely low
latency and get those uh on Main Nets so
we're trying to get you know the new
indexing we're trying to get all these
things available um on Redstone mainnet
um and then probably the next thing that
we probably will be working on is um you
know integrating interrupt so optimism's
uh multi-chain protocol inside of mud so
we'll also have some uh exciting things
like this but this is still work in
progress gotcha yeah that that speaks to
my question of why you joined the super
chain um how do you balance the benefits
of scaling um and the latency
optimization against the dollar cost
yeah that that's a good question um I
mean one thing we've been trying to do
is like move towards a more like bare
metal server architecture so instead of
using aws's very expensive servers we're
trying to run things uh on different
bare metal providers that are like
cheaper and have a lot of you know
redundancy uh because they're obviously
less stable so that uh essentially if a
region goes down or um a server goes
down if it's not as as stable as a us
it's the users don't don't really uh see
the difference and then you know basic
stuff like bin packing just adding a
bunch of services run on the same
machine so you have all these
optimizations that you can do but yeah
we're we're still fine-tuning this part
actually okay we got a question that's
really popular can it run Doom o h
that's actually a really good question I
I I think you should come to Mud day to
find out about that can wow be
next next question by the way that was a
joke you didn't have to laugh um what's
your thought on
crdt in crdt plus blockchain I'm sorry
I'm not the person to be asking that
question I think it's it's an
interesting question because it's like
crdt use if you really want to do like
pure decentralization and um you care
about you know not having a single point
of failure and having you know all the
browsers be able to eventually reconcile
the state and things like that so I I
guess it would really depend on what
your um use case requirements are um if
you're trying to build a game that is
even if all the latest servers go down
you can still play the game then crdt
could actually be a pretty pretty good
solution but otherwise I'm not fully
certain that you can get the the same
kind of performance and latency that
that we have when we have these Edge
block
Builders cool any other question
guys I got one spicy question here oh
nope someone else has another question
in here um this is not a question crdt
is yeah someone has a point here to make
what is your take on that crdt is only
for communative operations bad for games
thank you for that spicy question or
opinion
rather what was the other take you had
oh the other take I had uh was I'm
curious how you actually see the
difference between um ton chain and all
of their you know fun mobile app games I
don't know if you guys have played any
of them but they're highly addictive um
and you do end up earning whatever
tokens in their ecosystems and they seem
to be building something quite similar
probably a lot less complex than what
you guys are yeah I think so it's quite
interesting too because what we're
really focusing here is like autonomous
worlds where you bring as much part of
the you're trying to bring all the
physics on chain so it can live without
anything on the client um and then
eventually can live out you know outlive
the teams outlive everything and so
these kind of games that are kind of
addictive they're they're not really
geared for this kind of you know
long-term view or things like that you
know they you really have the gaming
Loop that's all that matters whereas
here we're trying to have everything be
on chain eventually and that's what mud
is about really is like enabling all
these very complex physics fully on
chain gotcha
okay thank you any other
questions well thank you for your time
thanks thanks guys give them a round of
applause come back in 7 minutes where
we're going to be talking all about the
arbitra d
[Music]
he
w e
[Music]
hey guys so this next session is going
to be pretty fun we've got Patrick here
from arbitrum talking all about his
experience with the da um and thought I
would add this one fun fact about
Patrick is he really likes to play Red
Alert without further Ado here's
[Music]
Patrick awesome so just before I begin
um who's heard of a Dao before raise
your hand if you've heard of dows and
then raise your hand if you've had a
positive experience in a DA some people
Bess hands exactly you know Dows are you
know you love them or you hate them and
hopefully we'll explore that during the
talk
so just to get started what I want to
talk about today is the following you
know YSU rule UPS care about Dows and
then I want to get into the Dow itself
you know what do we mean by autonomy
decentralization and then organization
as well so I started the arbitr
foundation just about two years ago and
I'm not a dow person you know I don't
know anything about Dows certainly when
I joined anyway so I joined the
foundation and if anyone remembers you
know the arbitrum Dow rejected our
funding that was a great experience then
after all that heated you know
discussion I sat there and thought why
have we got a dow like why should I care
for this Dow why is this Dow important
so I want to sort of answer this
question how I thought about it about
two years ago and it starts with how do
you govern code and how do you govern
the live deployment of code so let's
start with code I'm sure most people
here are familiar with GitHub you go in
the web website you look at a repo you
look at the code you flick around you're
like okay this is roughly how it works
so you can get an idea how it works you
know anyone can read anyone can figure
out what's going on if you're a
dev then the next part is how do you
govern this code how do you decide you
know how to merge code and upgrade the
code so anyone can typically submit a
pull request you look at the code you
find a bug you Fork the code you fix it
and then you do a pool request and then
typic you have these code owners so
these are the code owners for go
ethereum you know they'll eventually say
okay that's a good change to the code
I'll approve it and then it gets merged
in so anyone can contribute to it and
there's this governance process you know
these code owners who can decide the
merge in your code now what's also cool
about open source software is that
anyone can download the code run the
code and you know do what they want with
their deployment so these are the
instructions for goo ethereum you can
download it and and create your own
local test net so maybe as a gauge here
who's ever done that who's downloaded go
ethereum compiled the code and ran it
for your own local network one person
two people there you go people have done
it you know it's great you can do your
own live deployment but then the
question is what if there's you know how
many meaningful deployments are there
off that code and typically in crypto
there's one meaningful deployment you
know there's only one Bitcoin only one
ethereum and of course there's only one
arbitrum as well and then this raises a
new question if there's only one
deployment of the code how do we govern
that how do we decide upgrades to the
code and how do we change the
code now this is a governance problem
and the first way every project solves
it is that is centralized so if you
think when Bitcoin was launched in 2009
it was Tashi Nakamoto on an IRC Channel
this is Source forged so this is the one
from 2009 where you can see you know
satachi Nakamoto updating the code he
you know update the code you go on IRC
and say guys if you're running a node
here's a new version please upgrade so
centrally orchestrated ethereum was the
same and of course all the rollups are
very similar as well from the get-go so
you typically start off with centralized
governance but then how do you you know
get
decentralized so in many crypto projects
like Bitcoin and ethereum we have this
process called rough consensus and of
consensus is a bit like a game of hot
potato no one wants to take
responsibility to decide who upgrades
the software so what you typically do is
you get the poto you pass it around and
you just hope it doesn't land at you so
in rough consensus today you typically
get you know consensus amongst the cevs
consensus amongst the token holders
consensus amongst the community and
consensus among you know the companies
and the DBS and the ecosystem and once
everyone's sort of roughly agreed to say
you know I sort of want this to happen
you pick a flag day so you could say the
1 of December and at the Flag Day the
upgrade should be activated so in
advance everyone you know upgrades their
nodes in anticipation of the Flag Day
Flag Day happens the upgrade occurs it's
rough consensus it's obscure on purpose
to avoid governance attacks and also
because no one wants to take the
responsibility to decide this upgrade
should
happen another approach is is onch and
voting you know what if you could
identify all the token holders the token
holders cast a vote and they say oh I do
want to upgrade the software I'm going
to approve this that is basically Dows
in a nutshell you have his on G voting
protocol you can cast your vote if the
vote passes then you could you know
process the upgrade on chain everyone
has time to upgrade their offchain
infrastructure but eventually the
upgrade will occur and then obviously
the system gets upgraded and so that's
why you know from a software perspective
why Dows are useful you know if a
centralized approach th of consensus
then eventually you could have onchain
voting and that's what Dows really care
about or at least in
arbitrum but wow Patrick you know on
chain voting does that not impact the
security of arbitrum because now have
all these token holders that can upgrade
the software and of course it does but
when you think about a rollup or any
blockchain system to be honest there's
two parts to the security the first one
is the data day operation what is the
protocol protecting the funds is it
proof of work proof of stick fraud
proofs ZK proofs you know what is the
protocol running most of the time that
protects the protects the assets under
the hoot and then there's always
governance no 0 one% of the time human
intervention social consensus where we
all have to reach agreement to say oh
it's time to upgrade the software add a
feature fix a bug or you know fix a
critical vulnerability as well and so
governance is always part of a
blockchain system you might de say there
is no governance but then there's no way
to upgrade the software as well so
governance is always there you just need
a process for it and of course Dows care
about governance and they try to achieve
this you know voting protocol diverse
population that's how you protect govern
you know governance for the software
system so that's you know how I
understood why Dows are useful for
rollups but what about the arbitrum Dow
you know how has it grown over the past
two years and what do they like to vote
on so this is the a you know in Dow
autonomy now in my mind and you sort of
got this already the Dow has two
objectives first the Dao is the ultimate
defender of arbitrum it's up to the Dow
to decide if an upgrade occurs on the
system thus their main purpose they
don't really enjoy that but they're
stuck with it the second thing they
enjoy is that they get the Mony their
treasury you know back two years ago
they were you know they were given 35%
of all ARB and you can imagine people on
the internet they like to write
proposals they like to spend money and
they like to have fun so this is the
really juicy part and the really fun
part so over the past year and eight
months on the Forum there's been about
200 threads that are you know specific
proposals for the Dow to consider there
have been over 329 snapshot proposals
new temperature checks where people have
had the vote there have been around 50
Tali proposals a t proposal you know C
pass or feel but that's where you spend
the money you take the money from the
treasury or you upgrade the software and
to dat they've spent around 700 million
ARB although a lot of that ARB is locked
into initiatives so not really spent but
allocated but that's crazy that activity
is nuts on aage is four proposals a week
like I don't know how the delegates keep
up to be honest because we struggle to
keep up and as our full-time job so our
Dow is is overly active and they could
be less active at this point you know
work out more meaningful proposals that
go through the Dow but they're alive
they're well and they're doing
stuff and what do they like to spend
their money on you know they love
incentive grants they fund a crypto
legal defense they have their own
independent Grant programs they love
real world assets blockchain gaming they
like the fund us the arbit foundation
you know they rejected us initially but
we're there now and they like us and of
course security audits as well
and a bunch of other
stuff and probably the most important
thing in our Dow and I think it's sort
of underappreciated or people aren't
really aware when we started two years
ago we made the explicit decision not to
get involved in our Dow we were not
going to get involved in governance we
were going to you know not write
proposals and let the Dow do their thing
and um I feel like the first three
months from like I say March till
September it's a bit like a game of
chicken we're waiting for the you know
the contributors to do something the
comput contributors were waiting for us
to do something and we never moved and
we didn't do anything and then around
September and then over the summer there
were some proposal sub minute but by
September last
year you know one delegate put in a
proposal for one of the incentive
programs it eventually passed I think
that was I forget now I think it's like
60 million ARB or something it was like
a huge proposal but then the then the
contributors and delegates realized oh
we can do this you know we can submit a
proposal we can discuss the proposal we
can vote on The Proposal we can take the
money from the treasury and only after
the proposal passed does the arbitr
foundation step in and we do our best to
help them and I believe that's what led
to the success of our daad de because
people realized oh they really have
autonomy and they can really do cool
stuff you know in our foundation we have
about four people on the governance team
there's no way we wrote 300 proposals so
it's really exciting to see people will
step up and kick
us and they are active so this is like a
governance call they have 47 people on
it talking about funding stylists you
know that's the AL alt VM for arbitrum
another call where they're talking about
Ops for governance this has about 40
people on the
call uh they've ran their own hackathons
they run their own delegate days our
forum is exceedingly active we probably
get 20 to 50 posts a day and actually
for the hackathon the judges for The he
on no one works at the arbiton
foundation no one works even at offchain
Labs they're contributors and delegates
in the Dow and they consider themselves
arbitrum part of the community and
they're judging arbitrum
proposals I found this on the internet I
thought it was funny Everyone likes
agree Pepe the Frog hi
frogs and they're funding stuff that we
have no involvement in so davriel uni
got funded by the arbitrum DA they
funded their own booth the arbitrum da
booth they fund getcoin rounds and even
like educational programs in Nigeria and
there's a host of other stuff there's
just funding stuff and then I find out
about a four weeks later I'm like oh
what are these guys up to oh that's a
great Booth you know it's really cool to
see people actually do stuff and we're
not even aware of
it now after two years the way I like to
think about the development of the Dow
is that in the first two years or year
and a half we've done a really good job
or at least you know I make it look nice
cuz we also have lots of mistakes but
overall I think we've done a pretty good
job of enabling the Dow to build their
own identity they are a collective they
recognize they're part of the Dow they
can contribute and they can do stuff now
over the past year the Dow keeps asking
us the foundation to be more involved
you know they're like oh Foundation we
want your advice we want you on the
Committees we actually want you to start
getting involved and so now I believe
we're at a point where we can be more
involved you know the D now has an
identity where they're not going to
rubber stump stuff we're going to give
them our feedback our comments our
opinions if they want to take it great
if they don't they can ignore us but now
I think we're at the point where we can
help them more and hopefully get them
aligned on a certain direction where we
can all kick ass together but that's
taken about a year and eight months to
get to that point and now to their to
their desire we're actually going to try
to help them more which for me is really
exciting now what about decentralization
what does that mean in a DA so when you
think of decentralization you typically
think oh let's get the world population
and get it in the Dow you know that's
what most people think when you think of
decentralization for a DA but the
question is what Manor what Manor are we
bringing these people to the DA and is
that even a good idea and there's two
ways to think about it you could
decentralize the decision-making process
or you could work for the Dow as well
you know you could be employed bad down
and have your income there so for
decision making what you really end up
with
their voting blocks you know like any
political process you end up with voting
blocks where contributors have a certain
view other contributors have aign views
they sort of naturally become a
collective and they sort of vote in
certain directions and I think for the
centralization of a DA what you really
want to do is recognize these voting
blocks and try to maximize the
participation in these voting blocks
they make sure you can always reach some
type of decision either yes or no or
they are forced to make some type of
comp
rise and actually sometime last year
someone made this joke to me one of the
delegates he said the arbitrum Dow has
four political parties and I don't know
who those political parties are I have a
rough idea but it's not well defined but
you could find that out you know if
you're a researcher you could look at
the voting records the telegram messages
the the discourse the form analyze it
and start to identify who are these
voting blocks and political parties in
the
Dow and actually the the voting block
idea comes from this paper I have no
involvement in it the paper has two
great insights decentralization for a
dow should be defined by voting blocks
and they have a certain way that measure
entropy but also they highlight
delegation and a dow so if I delegate my
vote to someone else actually improves
decentralization overall where normally
when you look at that mechanism you
think oh does that not centralize it
because now one party has too many votes
so I recommend reading that it's a great
paper but most
importantly when it comes to like
diversity of views in the Dow you want
to make sure that there's not too many
cooks cuz if there's too many views and
too many opinions you osculate the
process becomes paralyzed and then you
make no decision at all and everything
comes to a halt but of course at the
same time not everyone should have the
same opinion because then there's no
discussion and everything you know
passes and obviously then you know
they're not very good proposals so you
want to make a bit of something in
between and of course it's hard to
create that
but also decentralization is about
execution and you know ethereum's done a
great job of this so the question is who
is working towards the success of
arbitrum and long and right now we have
multiple ORS we have the foundation the
Dow offchain lab tropy advisors the gcp
all these committees and long term you
would like to think well if the Arbitron
Foundation disappeared would the Dow
survive and continue and I would like to
think at some point we can get to that
and that's also another form of
decentralizing ization there's enough
orgs out there working on behalf of the
ecosystem and there's not a single point
of failure but now this brings me to the
important question how do you get higher
by a dow and what does the orc chart
look
like so I put this tweet up earlier this
year in January because I recognize that
in our Dow there's lots of these side
gigs you know you perform a task you get
10K you perform another task you get 40K
and sometimes you're like oh damn this
Dow pays really well but where the up
ANS why is no one applying for these
opportunities and obviously when you ask
on Twitter you get everyone's opinion
which is why I you know I get a good
giggle out of it sometimes so here's
some of the comments I got and the
summary is that getting hard getting
hired by a DA is hard now there's a lot
to read there so I summarized it so in
the top left comment he basically says
PTY why would I spend three months
trying to work for a DA to eventually
get hired to then only get 1.5 times my
salary like three months of free unpa
work it's too much for a slight pay rise
it's not worth it no thank you don't
want to deal with the Dow on the top
right hand side you know the poster
basically said PTY the Dow is full of
politics I have the good or the Dow I
basically have the beg to people on the
internet to get a salary no thanks I
don't want to beg I just want to earn
some money then at the bottom the P
poster said well you know the Dow is
scary there's a huge learning curve
there's a scary form I don't even know
where to start where can I find these
paid
opportunities so then after I got all
those comments I stepped back and
thought well what do most people want
like in this room what do most people
want in life most people either want a
hobby do something fun or have a sid
gake today most contributors in our Dow
fit that category they want a side gig
they want have some fun they're just
genuinely interested in being in a DA
the vast majority of people want some
formal employment you know they want a
job hosting they want to apply for the
job they want to be interviewed by a
small panel they want to get hired you
know have stable income health benefits
just want to be a normal employee and
the irony is for the past 10 years in
crypto we finally got to the point where
most people in this room can work for a
crypto company and have a stable job I
don't know if you were here in 2015 but
getting a job was impossible today so
many jobs and now in we've basically
said oh well let's forget about that you
know we finally solved the problem of
employing people but you know what we're
just going to go back to dalls and not
employ anyone but most people want to be
employed and so most Dow contributors
they're actually more like
entrepreneurial Spirit you know a
contributor is willing to go to the Dow
submit a proposal pivot pivot pivot get
rejected get rejected again then
eventually get their proposal passed and
then have the opportunity to run their
initiative but most people can't do that
you know unfortunately to the people in
this room you know most people just want
a normal job they don't want to fight
with random people on the internet to
get run an initiative and you have to
recognize that which is why Dows don't
get huge you know like not many people
work for a dow for that very
reason so you could solve this and say
well ptty why know does just have a
centralized org that can hire people and
obviously that's not the solution you
know the whole point of a dow was not to
have a centralized or was to be DEC ized
so what happens then in practice and so
over the past two years in arbitrum I
basically came to this observation where
the Dow's job is to create an orc chart
through popular vote so every time the
da wants to do something they either
spin up a new committee like multi-
service the procurement process treasury
management or they spin up a new orc so
we funded no when I say we the arbit da
funded enty advisers the ging catless
fund ply labs the quby gr program and
that's how or charger created in Dows
and then you would like to think in the
future if you want to work for the Dow
you wouldn't go to the Dow itself you
would find these orgs find these
committees and just apply get the job
and then go kick ass so I see most
people working for Dows via orgs and
committees and not actually interacting
with the Dow
itself and that's basically my last
slide I have a bunch of like interested
things I find interesting anyway about
Dows for example
example um I think this one's probably
one of my more interesting ones at the
moment so in Dows sentiment changes
really fast six months ago the D wants
to do a six months later a is toxic we
should do B and that Overton window is
so interesting to see how opinions
change so fast that's really easy to
measure you know you could just do
analysis of the text and figure out why
so I've ran out of time so now is the
Q&A so there's any questions then I'm
down down for a
Q&A awesome that was a great
presentation uh on arbitrum Dow from
last year now there are a couple of
questions but uh if you have any burning
questions here for Patrick please um
either scan this QR code or go into the
Devcon app and just ask some questions
using your zoo pass we already have one
question here that is definitely the
most highest voted which is a question
that I think many of us have is how do
you actually encourage active
participation in the Dow given that most
people simply care about making profits
instead of actually being involved in
the decision-making process which could
be lengthy why should people care yeah
exactly I think people should follow the
money you know most people want to make
an income they want to have a salary
they want to be paid I think what's
important is like most people want to be
paid for their Merit and not their
geographical location so if you have a
skill that you can contribute to a
community you should be paid for doing
that and that's the same for Dows you
know a lot of our contributors who
interact with the Dow directly you know
they eventually get a proposal passed
and they get paid from that proposal and
you should be paid from your proposal if
you're going to run an initiative you
should be able to make money for doing
that so you know it's not an altruistic
thing you just have the right that make
some money just like everyone else you
know Dows aren't free they're not
voluntary trying to make some money if
you
come awesome thanks for that how do you
verify that the decision
makers really have the expertise to make
the right decisions they may have the
votes though
oh 100% this is one huge issue for Dows
so I think one of the problems we have
now is not even just expertise but uh
when you have four proposals a week and
now let's say
380 380 proposals over you know two
years not only do they not have the
expertise but they may also just not
have the time to do the proper due
diligence so I think what you really
want is the Dow to vote on big important
initiatives not small grants for example
if there's a proposal to the Dow for
$40k
probably not worth the time of the Dow
itself go to a ground program what you
really want is then they vot on big
proposals but also hire experts so in
our Dow the Dow has hired the
arc the arbitrum research development
Collective and their job is to provide
expert advice to delegates Bas in
certain proposals that come along like
Risk you know technical or even just
economics or anything business but of
course delegates themselves may not have
that expertise and there's a huge risk
in that and another one is is we don't
have it but you also have liquid
democracy I know that's more
experimental where I could delegate my
vote on certain topics to certain people
so that can help but that requires more
participation we've got a lot of
questions coming in here some of them
actually aren't appearing right now on
the screen so I'll ask one that's on the
screen what would we need to develop uh
Dow in a dictatorship country like Burma
where we are not legally able to
establish any sort of blockchain
initiative to scale fund educate
ourselves more about blockchain and Dows
what we need to develop
Dows I mean I'm not a lawyer so that's
not really the one for me the answer but
what what I would say is you know Dows
aren't restricted to your geographical
location they're typically centered
around topics so in our case we're
centered around you know a roll up a
software topic and that's what people
interact with youve got like
Constitution now whereas there again
random people on the internet that
wanted to buy the US Constitution but
then they got rugged by you know Wall
Street but they're mostly around like
you know initiatives and not locations
so that's probably the best way I can
answer that I have a cheeky question
here actually too how do you vet
proposals to prevent malicious proposals
from being pushed through but I have an
addition to that question sorry um and
that's how do you actually vet your
contributors because increasingly we're
seeing a lot of problems with
contributors being uh not exactly the
people you want contributing to your
core projects and instead putting back
doors in so I mean I mean I think that
was like was that not tornado cash but
they got rugged by their Dow proposal if
I remember right yes tornado cash but
there have been several other Dows that
have been rugged like this so I think
like at least in in the technical sense
there's two there's three aspects one we
V the code ourselves if it's going to go
through because we need to protect our
Dow they have the ardc I think is open
Zeppelin right now that should also vet
the code and sort of give a sign off to
say it looks good um then the third one
is like also like compliance isn't if
you're going to get funds of someone
then we take care of all the compliance
needs and the legal agreements and
everything else you know I I know
someone in the audience who takes care
of all of that for us won't Point them
out but yeah generally it's uh and also
the last one is our Dow has a maximum
politeness policy so if you're not
polite then you shouldn't be involved
and that's done a really good job to
makees sure it's not
toxic H interesting we have one more I
want to ask one more question while
we're here um how do you get involved in
darb arbitrum Dow to become a delegate
how do you get involved in arbit oh
sorry I read the wrong one how do you
avoid political groups in the Dow having
so much power so that they can block
proposals sorry one there's two sides of
this isn't there so I was saying this to
someone earlier in the hallway a DA is a
representation of the values of that
Community um so for example if you're
interested in like defi you know smart
contracts you'll probably end up in the
arbitrum Dow if you're interested in I
don't know uh something that's
completely not arbitrium then you'll
probably not join our community so what
happens there is is you just naturally
get these political parties forming but
what you really want is you want
political party not political parties
you want voting blocks there to make
your decisions do get made but you want
to make sure they're diluted there
shouldn't just be one party that can
veto any proposal in the Dow and the
only way to dilute them is through
delegation and you have to really trust
the token holders who you're delegating
for example we at the Arbitron
Foundation we can't delegate so we can't
impact how people vote at all but that
really comes down to people delegating
in a way that makes views more diverse
but of course making sure the voting
blocks can still exist so decisions can
be made because otherwise you're
paralyzed gotcha thank you thank you so
much Patrick cool GG
guys sorry there were a billion other
questions
[Music]
is
n
[Music]
for
hey guys I'm really excited to um
announce this presenter um Rose here is
from darkfy and she's going to be
talking about lunar Punk endgame which
is very exciting so I'm going to welcome
Rose here on to the stage right
[Applause]
[Music]
now hello
everyone
oh
good um thanks very much for coming uh
before I start I just want to get a
sense of the uh the attendees so um how
many people here have heard of
darkfly okay it's like maybe half uh so
I just want to say uh to start off that
I won't be talking about darkfy much um
but if you're interested in that and you
want to learn more I recommend that you
stay for the talk that's directly after
this uh where my colleague Amir will
talk and explain everything about dark
fi and but today I'm going to talk about
lunar Punk uh who here has heard of that
term
before and and okay uh for those that
don't know what it is uh if you know
what Cipher Punk is and solar Punk then
you might you're halfway to
understanding what lunar Punk is um one
way of describing lunar Punk is as a
synthesis of Cipher Punk and solar Punk
which combines aspects of both uh
imaginaries to create a new version
which is supersedes both um but if you
don't know what Cipher Punk or solar
punk
are the best way to understand lunar
Punk is as a Sci-Fi imaginary that's
oriented around utopian
anonymity um so what does that mean uh
utopian anonymity is the perspective Ive
or conviction that anonymity is
something very good for society and that
it could actually lead to a emergence of
new kinds of
civilizations um the basic idea is that
surveillance um and a society Based on
data extraction um is a kind
of dead controlled world where Society
can't progress um through anonymity we
allow different kinds of societies and
new forms of civilizations to emerge um
so that's why uh lunar Punk sees itself
as a kind of utopian anonymity um and
tools like darki uh play a role in
bringing this Utopia about but the goal
of this presentation is not to talk
about
that uh in fact this presentation has
three goals um so firstly I'm going to
to uh try to Define lunar Punk not by uh
through these words and definitions but
actually by showing you a potential
future um so this talk is a Sci-Fi um
with sci-fi artworks that is supposed to
kind of uh uh speculate on one possible
chain of events um and to Define lunar
Punk
concretely uh by example so secondly um
I want to clear up some
misconceptions uh so when I first wrote
about lunar Punk that was back in
2021 um it there was later an animation
made of it if you Google uh lunar Punk
on the dark side of the cycle you can
find the video and the kind of mistake
that I made at the time was that I
defined the lunar punk in contrast to
solar Punk solar Punk was something uh
related to transparency and surveillance
uh by virtue of its transparency whereas
lunar Punk was uh was was positioned in
contrast to that as a um uh a pro
anonymity um perspective the issue with
this framing is that it made people
believe that lunar Punk was some kind of
negative or some kind of shadow um of
solar Punk that it was a uh that it was
rooted in negativity and skepticism
whereas solar Punk was something
optimistic um and positive so that's a
misconception and I want to show you and
exp through these images why lunar Punk
sees itself more as a utopian uh
perspective so it's really a story about
uh how can these Anonymous tools lead to
a world that is better than the world
today um so it's an uplifting future and
one of the reasons why uh lunar Punk is
often seen as a negative is because in
the lunar Punk imaginary there's an idea
that the State uh the nation state
Paradigm is overcome for some people
that idea is suggestive of chaos um so
they find it scary and they find it
something bad um for lunar punks that's
a really good thing um so it's the
beginning of a new age it's something
uplifting and uh optimistic um so I I
want to I want to show you show you that
in the in the coming uh talk finally the
goal of this presentation is to provide
a new image of the future um so we
believe that by creating images of the
future and by providing uh sci-fi
speculative imagination about where the
future could go we actually make those
new kinds of future Futures more likely
um so by by providing these kind of
images we compel the future in some ways
to move in that direction the uh what
I'm talking about here is a strange
aspect of Science Fiction that you see
in many sci-fi such as William Gibson uh
cyberpunk and all kinds of science
fictions where the Sci-Fi actually
proceeds it anticipates the future um so
sci-fi has this amazing ability to bring
about new kinds of Futures and
imaginaries um so we believe that that
one way to reorient the Future away from
surveillance dystopia is through this
effort of speculating on other kinds of
possible Pathways and through that
speculation making those path Pathways
more plausible and
concrete um okay so I'm invoking uh a
lunar Punk um called porg Pierce um who
was a revolutionary who participated in
the
1916 Uprising in Ireland uh it was a
failed Revolution um but through its
failure failure it actually brought
about the next Revolution which was a su
success
um so this is something that poric
pierce said just before his execution he
said we seem to have lost we have not
lost we to refuse to fight would have
been to lose to fight is to win we have
kept Faith with the past and handed on a
tradition to the
Future um so I'll let you kind of
reflect on that I just wanted to bring
that up um I think it's very interesting
because um sometimes when it comes to
the the the fight for privacy uh people
become very very resigned um but in fact
that it's through our uh our efforts and
even our when we seem to have failed we
are in fact winning uh through the very
Act of of of defying the surveillance
Paradigm okay so now we're going into
the Sci-Fi sorry for the extended
introduction um we begin at the
beginning 12,000 years ago um in the
Neolithic
Revolution uh in those early days there
were many different kinds of
civilizations that
coexisted um on this timeline we see the
emergence of a particular kind of
civilization
um the rise of cities uh and ancient
Mesopotamia the emergence of the nation
state Paradigm 5,000 years ago um so
throughout history there have been many
different kinds of civilizations that
have competed for dominance um the
last uh so in human history there's a
kind of a a rise and fall of different
competing civilizational formats and uh
for in this kind of 500e interval a
particular form of civilization will
Define that Paradigm um so the last 500
years have been the time of the modern
nation state era um but as we move into
the Millennium we're uh coming into a
new paradigm which is different to what
became before us five 500 years ago um
in the past 500 years so this is the Y2K
Paradigm Shift um that we're currently a
part of um and essentially what we're
seeing is this form of civilization that
has emerged and you know became the
dominant form of society in the past 500
years is breaking down
and a new kind of civilization is
assembling
itself um peer-to-peer technology
anonymity cryptocurrency all play a role
in the
disintermediation of the nation state
and the emergence of something
new um we believe that the next 500
years will be a kind of new Dark Age um
that sounds scary but it's actually not
it's actually a really good thing um so
what does it mean uh the new dark age
will be a time of spiritual growth and
development um it will be a time of red
decentralization where uh we will see a
global reconfiguration of power and the
existing uh nation states will um will
Decline and something new will be born
of that uh so it's a fertile age um
where the the new kind of society is
taking
root uh so this is the projection of
toward the next uh 10,000 years of human
history um so the basic contention is
we're entering with the Y2K paradom
shift we've entered a kind of new Dark
Age um this is a period of around 500
years where we experience a time of
great spiritual
growth the Spiritual Development that we
are set to undergo in the next 500 years
will lead to a new
Renaissance um so that next phase um um
1,000 years in the future will be a
Synergy of the 500 years of Spiritual
Development with the uh new
technological capacities um that will
come about as a result of that shift so
the goal in the next few slides is to
sketch out like one possible timeline of
events that you know could lead to these
uh this phenomenas uh and you know it's
a quick sketch but I hope it's going to
excite you and and show you the the
possibility as you can see here once we
go through this Renaissance period we
enter kind of a a Neo Roman Cosmic
expansion where like life and and human
life animal plant life expands to the
cosmos eventually ending in a in a great
human speciation event um where we'll
see a enormous diversity and plurality
of um different kinds of society but
also different kinds of Po humans um
that have evolved to different planetary
conditions
okay so this is um if you can see the
date there in the the the the future
it's it's 2033 so it's the near future
um here in this image you can see lunar
Punk Fighters um they're in a 3D weapons
production facility um so this is a
little snapshot of you know the coming
storm where uh Global power begins to
break up and organized factions um start
to assemble and you know become the
seeds of the new paradigm um so you can
see that there's like forests creeping
in they represent um the reforestation
of society um 3D printed Weaponry is
going to be a major defining force in
this disintermediation of state power
anonymity in cryptocurrency is also
playing a big role um at the same time
we will see the rise of regional
identities um and network uh States so
these kind of new crypto enabled um uh
Network exit
civilizations so I think we're going to
see both things at the same time so the
regional identities are pre-existing um
in some cases like indigenous identities
that have a strong sense of rooted
locality uh to a place so you might have
the reemergence of some of these ethnic
groups that have been um misplaced by
the nation state or or uh you know
silenced by the nation state so they're
going to rise up and they're going to
start to assert a autonomy within the
next hundred years at the same time the
network states are going to rise so
we're going to have both things
happening simultaneously the network
state is something more Cosmopolitan um
so you'll see a lot of different
ethnicities coming together around
technology um around space exploration
around longevity and other kinds of like
guiding topics um so you're going to
have both of these forms this is going
to eat away wear away at the nation
state Paradigm and also provide the
seeds of the of the next
phase so now we've skipped a little bit
further into the future as you can see
we're we're we're like 200 over 200
years into the future um so there are a
series of of events that that that
happen one is this is uh imagees kind of
indicates the um the the changing
spiritual landscape um so we can see
here kind of robed neotic fe uh uh
female figures um on an island Skellig
Michael for those that know it it's a
island that was home to monks within the
previous Dark Ages in the new Dark Ages
it becomes home to a new spiritual order
that um is uh has holds nature as sacred
but sees Science and Technology as a way
of connecting with nature kind of a a
sacred act of worship and reverence um
and so in this new monastic order we
start to see Technologies emerging that
more closely resemble organic life um
and this particular uh monastic order is
is very interested in Quantum Quantum
biology um but also in uh biology in
general at genetic research um so you
can see some of the life forms that
they've engineered in in in the corner
of the
screen um so as as they get deeper into
this Quantum research um they begin to
uncover
new forms of Weaponry I mention this
because I don't want to give the
impression that the utopian future we're
describing is is one where there's no
conflict of any kind um in fact uh we
expect that it'll be more the case that
there will be new Sovereign communities
and those communities are enabled to be
Sovereign because they're able to back
up their sovereignity with weapons that
doesn't mean it's going to be
necessarily a state of War all the time
you know it's just a case of a kind of
armed neutrality so it's like it's like
there are new monastic orders new
spiritual orders there there is society
societal speciation at the level of uh
culture like many different societies
existing uh side by side they're
autonomous and that autonomy is backed
up with
weapons okay so at some point in this
timeline uh there is the discovery of
alien life uh that is like a huge event
for Humanity in the same way as the
cernic revolution like reentered man
from the cosmos and you know was it like
a shock that changed the trajectory of
civilization in the same way the
discovery of alien life um will shock
humanity and force A New Perspective
upon us um I say here like there's
another idea which is like maybe we're
going to disc discover something like
evidence of a old civilization on Mars
um so there's theories about this that
actually Mars was home to a giant
nuclear explosion there's there's
evidence in the minerals so people are
like maybe there was an advanced
civilization that blew itself up with
nuclear the discovery of something like
this on Mars along with alien life could
bring about A New Perspective that is
you know begins to rever n nature and
life as something fragile and special
and that should be protected um so the
idea is like feeding into this new
spiritual pers perspective that has
emerged uh in the in the Neo Dark Ages
you have this like uh this new reverence
for life because you have a cosmic
perspective which shows you know um the
the kind of Devastation of uh of of
nuclear war on Mars that's just one
scenario okay so um back on Earth um
we've seen the results of these this
this new spirituality de has emerged
many different uh civilizations this one
is a is a Neo Celtic civilization that
is um that loves nature and that has
been Reviving extinct
species um so they've started a lot of
all this Research into biology and
Quantum has like uh borne fruits uh so
they've they have this this whole new uh
hyper biodiverse Ecology of extinct
plants and animals that have started to
co- habit with the living um so this is
happening and through that research uh
We've we've by amassing all this new
genetic knowledge of the of the extinct
bonds and species we actually make a
series of
breakthroughs in the our understanding
of Nature and biology uh so so this is
you know immensely useful and it leads
to an evolution in plant Animal Human
communication um so again we be we're
we're nurturing this this deep reverence
for nature through these this this this
deepened uh relationship to the plants
and animals that we cohabitate with uh
via this like improved
communication okay so I put this here
this is just a quick sketch um to show
that at this moment of History we're
we're in like like 2,500 to 2,800 we're
in the uh Neo Roman era uh like just
after the the Neo Dark Age um so this is
a time where you know the the political
structure of the world has been
basically decomposed into more older
regional identities and the newer
Network State type exit civilizations
that are more
Cosmopolitan uh so you have these things
side by side and they have strong uh
trade routes and uh connections so
they're not isolated they're you know
they're they're collaborative and it's
possible to exchange ideas and materials
um through this like Global Confederate
uh system that has like healthy trade
routes I I me I emphasize that because
there's a misconception that you can't
have um like Global cooperation at the
level of trade and economy without
nation states that's a that's a that's a
misconception we've been doing it for
like tens uh you know tensens of years
so uh I'm running out of time but I'm
I'm going to like fly through these
these uh Network States they were
focused on the space exploration so
they've built these centers in the
Atlantic which are like launch pads
where they've been uh they're able to
explore like the the uh the space um so
you know that's the benefit of those
Network States then we see the first
signs of successful um uh uh
terraforming experimentation on Mars
which is the introduction of these like
new genetically modified masses um that
have been discovered by the civilization
uh that's really into Reviving extinct
life um um so terraforming on Mars is
starting to go well eventually we move
the humans and the animals to Mars uh in
three the year
3,740 we begin to see the first signs of
speciation um so the humans and the
animals and the plants that have uh
migrated there are already starting to
adapt to the uh to the low sunlight um
onto the thinner atmosphere um that they
experience on Mars um you know finally
uh I had to put the moon in there
because it's lunar Punk after all uh the
terraforming has also been adapted to
the lunar surface um so we're really
spreading life uh throughout the
cosmos uh finally you know uh 10,000
years into into the future um humans
have expanded into exoplanets and this
is the point where we start to see the
uh you know the the uh extremes forms of
speciation uh where humans and animals
and begin to diverge rapidly um and you
know along with this hyper diversity at
the level of society um so that's a
quick sketch of um of what the lunar
Punk uh future could look like or one
possible future um a huge thank you to
ZK armor who made all of these artworks
um you know he worked really hard on
them and they're so beautiful uh so so
thanks so much for so much to him uh he
does all the art for all of dark fi um
and yeah thanks very much for coming to
the talk and I I'll pass on to Amir
who's coming after me thank
you that was a great presentation Rose
and I actually made a big mistake at the
beginning of this by not introducing you
first and saying that Rose can actually
basically bench press her own weight now
if you can hang on just for one minute
here I want we've got a couple of
audience q&as um so there's a pretty big
question here uh that's uploaded and
that's why is dark fi an alternative L1
when it could instead be a properly
private ethereum L2 its weaker security
scares me do you have any takes on that
or should we wait until the next I'm I'm
happy to answer that um so it's it I'm
going to start with the second thing
which is about this
security um the plan with dark is to do
a merge mine with Monero uh which
basically means we're bootstrapping off
the security of the Monero block
blockchain um so I don't see as as being
scary or like weak security or anything
like that that's the first thing second
thing is um oh why are we in all one the
main reason is um our focus is on
anonymity um privacy so we spent all of
our development effort on that um and we
weren't particularly opinionated on
which like rbn L2 do we use IBC or any
of that that's not our Focus we know
that there are many projects who are
working on uh decentralized trustless um
l2s IBC other kinds of like trustless
bridging so we're just letting those
projects work out those very difficult
problems for us while we focus on the ZK
ecosystem and then whenever like and
please if you have ideas on this please
talk to me it as soon as there are
available trustless bridging um like
trustless
l2s uh decentralized l2s and and or IBC
that can work with the utxo chains uh
you know we'll adopt them we're not
we're not fixated on being an L1 we'd
happily you know we we we want other
blockchains to connect to connect we
want to connect them so we're open to it
come talk to me if you have ideas and I
think we have time for one last question
um does darkfy see AI as a friend or fo
to the mission and it also ties in that
last question you see here where how do
you foresee the rise of machine
intelligence in the lunar Park timeline
um so uh I I see AI as a kind of like um
um like demon that has like grown off of
the surveillance and the collection of
like the mass data harvesting um so it
is this kind of like
scary uh evil demon that is like like
based like grown on surveillance like
fed on our data but that's not to say
that you know it can't also help us in
interesting ways um for example uh maybe
you guys know Dr Nick he's a person
who's very optimistic about the AI so
like if you talk with him he'll give all
kinds of ways in which the AI can uh can
benefit so societies um so you know I'm
I'm I'm I I'm my main issue with the AI
is like it's origin like but I'm not
saying that it can't be used for good
stuff and maybe in the in the lunar Punk
timeline it helps with these uh new
experimentation into like um hyper
biodiversity and space exploration maybe
AI plays a role in that maybe it plays a
role in the human animal communication
um so you know there there are there's
plenty of potential there and I think
it's probably one of those things that
forces the uh the the new the coming
like Shi shift uh toward a new
civilization it's like one of those like
um transformative Technologies that's
going to reconfigure um the like the new
paradigm awesome well thank you so much
uh Rose is going to be stepping off
stage now but I'm sure all of your other
questions you can go up to her and ask
her thank you thanks very much
[Music]
okay I will start now um
so my name is Amiri
I'm a free software developer for 20
years and a core Bitcoin developer from
2010 to
2015 um I wrote the
bip1 I made the first UK Bitcoin
exchange I'm 10 years plus working on
privacy technology I made the first
privacy implementations in Bitcoin uh
coin join stealth
addresses uh in 2015 I joined the ypg
and I fought on the front line for
against Isis I was 3 years working in
Syria for the local revolutionary
government and in this talk I'm going to
talk about darki so darkfire is an L1
for anonymous smart
contracts it's like in the same way
Monero is the anonymous version of
Bitcoin darkfy is the anonymous version
of ethereum so I will also today also
talk about the app that we're building
for users like what are we putting into
users hands
so let's
begin let's have a
look so okay that was actually let's
just go back here so let's start with
the name darkfire darkfire's name
actually comes from
2013 where um there was a project that
we founded called Dark wallet and it was
founded by uh me and Cody Wilson who
invented the 3D printed gun by vitalic
and a group of Spanish hackers and uh
you can actually go on YouTube and you
can find the initial video which is an
important piece of Bitcoin history but
the but the name itself comes from a
speech by the director of the FBI and
the director of the FBI was said that it
that the if people begin using
cryptography wildly widely if the
everybody starts adopting cryptography
it threatens to create these dark zones
in the internet where law enforcement
cannot penetrate the going dark problem
and he the quote is he goes you know the
law has not kept pace with technology
and this has created a public safety
problem so you might go okay well why do
we why do we need the you know the
cipher Punk values you know Cipher Punk
values what are they you know number one
is anonymity and I'm not talking about
when I say you know people go oh our
project's private you know like oh we
provide us no I mean strong anonymity in
the sense that if they come for you they
cannot find out who you are you are
completely protected and there is no
Gray Zone there there is only the
project your project is either Anonymous
or it's not
Anonymous um also censorship
resistance what that means is 100%
you're free speech you can say whatever
you want and nobody can shut you down
there is no compromises with free speech
it is absolute third thirdd uh property
sovereignity well that means we run the
infrastructure we own the infrastructure
they cannot shut it down they cannot
they can't it's like in our hands in the
hands of the
community so why do you need these
things well imagine a scenario where an
author Arian government comes into power
and they begin oppressing your friends
and putting them in jail and you need to
mobilize to create a parallel free
Society what do you do you create an
anonymous onchain Dow you uh you
communicate
anonymously you raise funds uh into that
Dow um you you allocate resources to
people for different projects you
coordinate the work using Anonymous
infrastructure Anonymous task managers
and then people get paid a salary they
get paid money they need to cash out
they need to do OTC they need to trade
it so they can pay for stuff and and
people using this infrastructure are
able to Mobil mobilize and um you know
what I'm talking about is not a
theoretical thing it's a real thing the
time is coming and we all feel that
within the next five years or so there
is going to be some major event of huge
macro you know economic or political
significance right now they are putting
devs in jail for making Anonymous
software and when they are doing that
they're trying to frighten people into
compliance and it's like you know if I
say something and you know it's it's
it's I'm just saying you know some uh
you know commenting about something and
you suddenly go I suddenly go or someone
says to me something and I suddenly go
oh yeah BL
and I react really aggressively and you
go whoa why is he reacting so
aggressively that is not a sign of
strength that is not a sign of power so
when they are oppressing people and
putting people in jail for making
Anonymous software that is that is not
that we are not meant to back off from
that that is a signal of where they're
weak and we're meant to hit them harder
we're meant to push further and you know
uh and you know people always go go to
us oh you know what about this project
you know what about uh this other
project you know dark has no
competition because you know there's all
these projects go oh yeah I'm a privacy
project blah blah join our Discord you
know check out our Google Docs they are
putting people in jail they putting
people in jail and if you are using
Discord then you are obviously not
afraid and if you're not afraid you're
probably not doing anything important
you know in England I literally saw the
other day a guy he went to a protest and
he just held up a sign and he said the
politicians are corrupt you know Black
Rock Etc they put him in jail for three
years this and I I even read now that
they are reducing the the time served
for criminals in jail from 80% to 60% to
make more space in jail because they
expect more people to go to jail now
more higher capacity because of these
new speech laws how crazy is that
they're putting people in jail and like
people are really suffering right now
people like the elites are trying to
divide Society separate people from each
other there's like they're actively
hostile to the interests of the people
and yet cryptocurrency as technologists
we have this huge power of cryptography
and we have not in in after billions of
dollars of VC money you know the VCS
they get the money from central banks
you know they get it from their F their
friends in Wall Street and you know
they're not going to they don't put it
into disrupting the status quo but then
this industry which was meant to change
things to have an impact goes to those
same guys ends up you know cow Towing
before them trying to ask oh please sir
give me some funds and that's why we
haven't been able to deliver like we
that's why projects are going join our
Discord join uh you know check out our
Google Docs we haven't even built a chat
app after so many years and now you're
going on Twitter and you seeing project
going oh I think the future is AI
conscious agents communicating or
allocating research it's like have you
built any of that no you haven't built
anything it's just talking rubbish we
haven't built the basics that people
need and then people go okay you know uh
you know dark five what you're building
you know what about criminals what about
the criminals you know
everybody all the movies is is always is
all about like you know mafias and
criminals and gangsters there's no M
that's not there is a the reason why
people are are are you know like
watching this stuff and they're going oh
you know I actually sympathize more with
the criminals because everybody feels
that we're under foreign occupation by
colonizer that's how dubious the law has
become the law no longer holds moral
weight and they turn around and they say
you know for us people who are trying to
gain our freedom they go oh that's
criminal you know or what about
criminals they invented that label and
they put that on us and we're playing
the rules by their of their game that
they invented if anybody's the real
criminal you know uh they're the real
criminals 2 million people died in the
Middle East for absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing two million people Di
shocking absolutely shocking things need
to change and we are technologists and
in our hands we hold cryptography I
study a lot of math every day and you
know when you're reading the math you
discover mathematical truths and you go
oh that is very that's very interesting
and you take these mathematical truths
and you piece them together to create
cryptographic schemas and we use these
schemas you know to defend Society from
Attack by States you know that is Magic
if anything is Magic that is Magic we
are like Wizards casting a spell you
know the um you know they used to say
that violence cannot solve math problems
that's what that means no matter how
much violence the state uses with their
man-made laws they cannot defeat the
power of the cryptographers when we wake
up and we realize that power we will
become invincible because the trajectory
of history when a technology whose time
has come it can't be stopped no matter
what laws they try to do we have bought
some time but do not be under the
illusion that governments are our friend
maybe the SEC has stopped has like eased
up on breathing down our necks but
they're not our friend the Crackdown is
coming we have to use this time to build
and to make governments
irrelevant
so oh yeah so you know that's the that's
people waking up realizing you know that
things are changing and this is the you
know the Luna pun uh
fight so um yeah I just you know
like okay CU when we're doing
cryptography we're summoning the power
of Mother Nature that's how powerful
that that stuff is and
uh okay so I so this graph is actually
well we don't need it we just talk about
this so you know anonymity and
surveillance dur in a feedback loop the
more that they crack down on anonymity
the more it valid validates why we need
anonymity and the more it pushes us to
understand this is the value in
cryptography Cipher punk you know Anon
PTP censorship resistant Sovereign
infrastructure for the people for the
community to allow us to build the the
new paradigm the new economic Paradigm
and the more that we're successful the
more that they're like oh this is
disrupting the status quo this is the
thing that actually changes things and
the more that they crack down that's
that's the feedback lube and so yeah you
see it there and so that's that's why
this split dark F regi split it whether
it's 5 years 10 years it's an
inevitability it's coming at some
point and uh so what's so yeah I so for
example tornado cash case how they they
the reason they put the tornado cach
people in jail was because they made a
mixer but it's not how they put them in
jail in the same way it's not how they
put Al Capone in jail they put him in
jail using the taxes the taxes thing so
with tornado cash it was actually uh uh
uh three things the first was they had
access to their internal signal chats
and so they were able to say oh you said
this and you said that so therefore
you're like the CEO so when we were
building darkfire we realized that we
needed to have this like
uh we completely Anonymous Communication
System P2P we where all the messages are
unlinkable nothing like that exists so
that if they come later with chats and
they go oh you said this then we go well
no I didn't it can be absolutely anybody
anybody can assume that identity and we
use cryptography to you know ensure that
we have spam protection and you know
that it's functioning but we've been
using that for several years to quot to
do the dark development and people they
always go oh but you know how can you
how can you do things
anonymously well you know culture does
not come from Reddit all the internet
culture came from
forchan that's like when people are in
free speech zones that's when they like
really explore you know the they explore
thought and that's when um you know
people are are are willing to like think
critically rather than just trusting
Authority and we need that more than
ever and we built technology in the '90s
and we were all Anonymous we're just
join an IRC Channel and we start
coordinating sending patches the the
that not you know that we how we've got
into this situation now where
everybody's like oh you can't run the
internet with people being that's a scop
they've sced us into thinking everything
have to be like you know real name on
Twitter with a blue check mark That's
not how it was the internet wasn't even
built like that the internet the
internet was built by like people
mobilizing together so anonymity is the
is the is the real deal and um second
thing with tornado cash was they had a
DA and the DA they had like all the
people had tokens in the da and they go
oh well you've got this amount of tokens
therefore you're like a board member so
then we were like okay you know and we
had this experience with assanal where
people don't know but assange's case was
bankrolled by San D which you know
raised 55 million to free aange that was
like that was done by the crypto
Community but when we did it we had this
da where where all the members were
completely transparent and so it just
killed the da because it's for it's a
dow to like free a political prisoner by
all means necessary and everybody's like
oh well you know like I don't want to
act in a d i could go to jail I'm just
some random dude if I go to jail nobody
will hear about me or care about me so
and then secondly the Dow was
participating in an auction so the fact
that the treasury was public just broke
the game theory of the auction in 20120
2021 everybody was talking about Squad
wealth DS the Future Organization you
know of uh ethereum of of of blockchain
you know to mobilize community that
Vision never came to pass and instead it
just it just went into like defi dgen
you know uh nihilistic coiny and
the the reason why I think that didn't
happen is because we were missing the
adversarial you know anonymity in Dows
where Dows can't do anything important
they can't change things if people they
can't like have an impact on politics if
people are completely exposed and
vulnerable so you know like we dark five
built the world's first Anonymous D the
only Anonymous D that exists in the
world that infrastructure exists on dark
fire and the third thing about tornado
cash they ran they ran infrastructure
we've built everything ground up you
know completely Sovereign infrastructure
P2P task managers everything and I and
you know they're telling me I'm running
out of time so you know
um so you know I just talk about the UI
because you know when I watch movies
like okay Silicon Valley they've got
this broken Paradigm where they you know
try to capture as many normies as
possible and tax them they they like oh
yeah people are stupid we just need to
get loads of stupid people and crypto
people have fallen into that trap where
that and and that's why I read an
article recently it said gen Z does not
know how to use a file system and it's
indeed like when you go on the Mac
computers and you look at the file
browser it doesn't expose the file
system you can't access it so it's like
literally not only are they designing
the software uh to for stupid people
it's actually making people stupid and
we need to like we need to create uh
software the software the vision of the
future that we were promised in the
Sci-Fi in the movies in the '90s and
instead of trying to copy you know
Silicon Valley you know the the like you
know like all these garbage delivery
apps that are made in electron slop
JavaScript and they're just shitty and
they lag like why why are we why do we
think that is the authority why are we
trying to copy Google why are we not
building actually cool stuff why are we
not building the things that people who
are being oppressed actually need that's
why people is looking at cryptocurrency
guys it's a scam we haven't built the
basic tools everybody's talking about
very fancy stuff we need to actually put
the things that people need how come
darkfire darkfire project has has their
projects which have 20x to 100x of our
budget and they have not even built 20%
of what we've built we've built much
more than other projects which is a
small project how is that possible that
should tell you a lot about this
industry and how this industry is
operating so I just go through some of
the stuff you see we've got OTC swaps ZK
compiler you know the consensus
algorithm you know chat completely
crossplatform Windows Mac Linux Android
uh iOS and lastly to wrap it up you know
you know they call us criminals but
they're the real criminals and in the
end history will be the judge of our
actions and history will absolve us and
anonymity is is offensive it expands
spaces it expands a territori of Freedom
as Satoshi said privacy is not simply a
normi you know people go privacy is
normal privacy is special it's something
we strive for we struggle for and this
is the Dark Forest internet rewilded
with cryptography you know is how we
mobilize to change things we are not
criminals we are Forest Rebels and um
this split is happening and cryptography
is Magic crypto regulation is an open
and official provocation against Liberty
and sovereignity all who advocate for it
are domestic enemies of the people and
must be absolutely opposed the right of
the people to keep and deploy
cryptography shall not be infringed
thank you so much
Amir that was a fantastic presentation
Amir there are a billion questions for
you on the mircat app so just come
approach me I'm very approachable
afterwards you know than much
I'm up next um we have Ash uh who is
with
too
um we have ashes with too and uh she's G
to be talking all about MPC tools which
is really exciting so stick around
[Music]
it's good yeah
hello well um thank you for the
introduction um that was quite I think
it's uh I should have wrote to someone
earlier to ask if I don't go after Amir
because like it's really hard to follow
somebody who's so full of energy and so
full of like good ideas and yeah
principles that we should follow more
and
more um so yeah I will talk to you about
MPC basically um some some of the tools
that can provide some of the Privacy
expectations that the cipher Punk values
might actually benefit from um I'll give
you an educational tour of MPC so from
auctions to ZK my a
toz
uh I don't know if it works
is there a way
sorry is there
some special
trick
this
yeah okay
hello so I go back to the start so yeah
I want to give you a bit of an overview
of uh NPC from a toz which uh if you
know about NPC use cases it's from
auctions to zero knowledge and so one
thing I wanted to start by and maybe uh
this room kind of appreciates this is
that cryptographers are not Cipher punks
and I think I come from a background of
cryptography and there is a tendency in
the cryptography Community to think that
because we build the tools that can you
know help us exercise the freedoms and
the cipher Punk values that we want um
we do feel like we are some sort of
rebels but after quite some time now I
kind of realize that's not actually the
case mostly what people like what the
cryptographers actually like to do is
push symbols around to try and make some
proofs of security and feel uh smart and
so this is uh this is great and it's
really cool that we have a secure
protocols but it does not make them
Cipher punks and it does not result in
the sort of Freedom tools that the
cipher Punk values maybe need and the T
types of things that Amir was talking
about just
now um so yeah yeah cryptographers are
not Cipher punks and this is why I kind
of put it in this in this um in this
session in the cipher Punk session
rather than the uh applied crypto truck
and so I think in building uh kind of
Freedom tools or you know privacy
preserving tools it's important to kind
of understand some of the cryptography
and so yeah this is why I want to give
you some view of MPC so what is MPC been
used for and first of all does everybody
know what I mean when I say MPC
okay one two three people so NPC stands
for multiparty computation um is there
anybody like who has absolutely no clue
at all what multiparty computation
is okay one person at the very back
you're too far back to uh no but anyway
MPC is used for computing on encrypted
data so it started in the 80s with coin
flipping mental poker comparing integers
small things and essentially what it is
is that you know a user Alice has some
data in her local device or in her
machine and whatever machine she can
secret share it to a network and this
network communicates nodes in this
network communicate to do computation on
her encrypted shares and they produce a
result this is it
essentially and so the first large scale
kind of practical example of this was
the sugar beat auction which was run in
2008 and this was a double auction to
determine the market price of sugar
beads um it was an NPC you run between
farmers and a sugar processor and
researchers in Denmark um it was super
nice because everybody agreed that this
was kind of needed and useful um the
farmers didn't have to reveal how much
they were willing to pay the sugar Pro
processors couldn't you know take
advantage of farmers and everybody kind
of won so this was a super nice um
example of an auction that was run in
NPC something that um could have
benefited from something like this is
let's say the Constitution da who lost
an auction because they revealed how
much they were willing to pay and you
know
uh uh their competitors could see how
much there was in a public wallet
before um another one was the Boston
wage study so identifying salary gaps
across gender and um ethnicity so this
was done in Boston they did uh NPC saw
like a private computation across uh
census data to try and analyze whether
there was a disparity between a gender
uh wages across genders naturally they
found that there was um and they found I
think it was 30% maybe it's tooo small
here oh yeah it was 30% I think in 2016
when they first did this study um and
they did it again last year no 2023 yeah
last year and it had decreased to 21% so
by doing this kind of study um at least
you become aware of some problems and
then maybe you can actually start try
and solve them um which is quite nice
for
society um there was also an Estonian
student graduation so I don't know if
you notice we are also doing a bit of a
tour and of different countries here and
these countries are where a lot of the
main NPC researchers are actually from
and so it's kind of interesting also
geographical tour of MPC but this uh
study was uh to try and determine if um
the drop out rates in it studies were
due to people working at the weekends uh
if their part-time jobs were interfering
with their studies and causing them to
drop out and this was particularly
important in Estonia because they became
um much more Tech techologically
relevant country and they needed a
highly skilled it Force but they had
high Dropout rates so they were really
trying to increase like uh the education
of it Workforce they actually found that
there was no correlation between these
two things but the in which was a bit
sad for the study but like at least um
we got a nice example of MPC out of this
so it was run between the Ministry of
Finance and the uh
University so uh another one was and
then then things start to turn a bit
weird um all of these things kind of had
like nice societal uh implications um
but then you know uh the tooling and the
MPC protocols became a bit more
efficient and they started being picked
up by big Tech and the Google so Google
had this experiment with MasterCard I
can't remember what year 2017 is 18
maybe where they wanted to achieve the
Holy Grail of advertising so this was
the headline at the time and so Google
as you know has like a very predicant
compute together like MasterCard would
never be willing to share uh people's
information with Google just in the
clear um because it's first of all
illegal due to whatever privacy
regulations and consumer protection reg
regulations but Google also would not be
willing to share um their information
with MasterCard so they had some sort of
blocker where they wanted to get around
and they were like okay we want to
compute on each other's data but how can
we do this in a legal way um so they did
um an NPC between some Google and
MasterCard to do some aggregate
statistics so saying I show you an
advertisement for um some privacy
bracelets on your uh
browser um did you actually go to the
store and buy privacy bracelets or how
many people went to the store to buy
privacy bracelets after they saw this ad
so this was the kind of thing and then
another one um worldcoin Iris scanning
so this is maybe something that you've
actually now it's called world I should
have updated this but um this is where
an orb scans your eye kind of start
moving towards the
dystopian maybe I shouldn't say this but
like Realm where you know people are
kind of doing MPC to sort of sidestep uh
regulation and so I think the
cryptographer point of view is a bit
like you know okay there are problems in
society and we have privacy issues like
just throw NPC at it like just throw
some crypto tools at it and that's all
fine like your problem is solved um but
I don't think this is is necessarily the
case because like with the Google and
MasterCard uh example there was really
kind of a lot of not uproar but like
discussion at the time about whether
this is actually good or not like um is
it good that now Google and MasterCard
can collaborate on our data okay sure I
can't be singled out it's not my data
necessarily but like um as a group we
all kind of suffer because Google has
more power and so this is a bit
questionable um so it's not really like
just throwing PC or just throwing
cryptographic tools at a problem doesn't
necessarily solve the Privacy issue that
kind of underlies the whole thing and so
the question then I mean like I
think is it possible to solve these you
know like how do you start to think
about solving privacy issues or like you
know um adhering to these Cipher Punk
values with cryptographic tools and
there are some super nice examples which
maybe you have actually seen at this
venue so one of them is from cursive who
are um a small team who are building
privacy preserving
applications and they are doing uh
private proof delegation so this means
that um actually you have these badges
or some stickers or some uh uh coar
bracelets or whatever they're downstairs
in uh in the main hall just after the
registration you can go and essentially
it's a uh a chip that you can tap with
your phone you can enter your socials
and then when you tap other people's
chips you can do a private intersection
of your uh common connections so the
common people that you've met and tapped
and then you generate a proof on this uh
private intersexual conference style and
but the reason that this is interesting
uh is because you know as uh Things
become a bit more complicated the proofs
get big and actually your phone gets
slow and um you know these things need
some libraries for verification and
proof generation and all sorts of stuff
so sometimes it becomes a bit
restrictive to actually do proof
generation on your phone so then an
answer might be well why don't we
actually start delegating proofs and you
see this a lot lot with I think um the
development of proof markets so like all
these proof Markets started popping up
over the last years to say like ah hey
we can you know have some pure beefy
machines that will generate your proofs
really fast for you which is great but
like if you have any sort of sense of
privacy at all this is terrible now
because now you're just Outsourcing all
your private data to This Server who
will generate proofs for you very
quickly but um yeah you don't get any
privacy here uh you Outsource your proof
generation but you do it in a secret uh
shared way like in this NPC way um and
you generate the proof over those secret
shares and so um this is being done now
downstairs not downstairs but like in
the internet you can see it
downstairs um so yeah this just happened
yesterday and when I say actually you
can Outsource this to a network this
network is not this mystical being in
the sky as it has been for the past 20
years now it is actually live um so
there's one Network that has run between
us T the cursive guys who built this
nice uh cryptographic connections app
and the psse group so each of us are
running um a bunch of nodes that are
generating these uh proofs on these uh
secret chairs so yeah go down and see
them if you want to actually feel MPC in
your hands there's also actually an MPC
exhibition that you can learn more um of
the history
so yeah actually what they're doing is
collaborative snarks generating
collaborative snarks which is just
generating zero knowledge proofs in an
MPC Network currently they are using our
tooling actually to do this which is um
available for circom so if you're used
to building circom circuits or Noir
circuits which is up and coming and
getting lots of hype this week in
particular and now you can use our
tooling to do the same thing but in an
MPC
environment um so yeah that's snarks and
so yeah all the stuff that you will
generate here are clabber of snarks and
so uh how is all of this stuff actually
leading to these kind of new nice things
that are not just getting us around
regulation but like this actually cool
solving privacy problems kind of tech
and I think the most interesting thing
that MPC is kind of enabling now in this
blockchain world is this private shared
state so you have these um private
blockchains or l1s or l2s like Alo and
Aztec who now have zero knowledge smart
cont contracts and they have like
private State and sometimes public State
and you generate proofs on your private
State and you can do stuff with the
public State and interact and this is
nice but in a sense it's a little bit
limited because the zero knowledge proof
is just a statement about a fact and
like it's very difficult to actually do
computation with that and so um if you
can instead have a sort of NPC Network
where you can maintain your privacy you
can actually do more like so you can
actually do computation on all of your
private State instead of just um having
zero knowledge proofs on public State
and so um you remember this picture from
before we had like one party sh secret
sharing their data to noes in a network
now I think the interesting part with
private shared state is when you sort of
introduce other uh players or other
entities so now you can take um secret
like multiple people can uh share their
data to a network in a privacy
preserving way and the network can do uh
computation over that and I think this
is super nice because we don't have to
start revealing things to anybody we
don't have to we have like all full
general purpose computation and not just
kind of workarounds with zero knowledge
proofs so for me this is like the most
exciting thing that is happening in the
crypto world at the
moment so I think with that like the
Privacy conversations becoming super
nicely nuanced it's not like full like
privacy is not secrecy necessarily it's
like you're not like completely black
booxed and tied off from everything and
nobody can see my data and no one can
touch it and I can't even use it and
like you shouldn't learn anything about
me and it's not like fully open like
everything on ethereum if I interact
with the chain like everything is public
and everything is recorded forever and
now we're kind of finding this like
somewhere in between this All or Nothing
approach and for me this is super nice
because in my life in my day-to-day life
I come here I stand and in front of you
I want to be seen at times but I also at
times don't want to be seen and I want
to choose like I want to have the option
to come and like um see people and I
want to share myself and my thoughts
sometimes but I also want the option to
not so having this sort of um and I also
want to sometimes avoid some people and
talk to some other people and whatever
like so having this um nuanced view is
super nice and so if you are sort of MPC
inclined but not necessarily A
cryptographer how can you start thinking
about these and I think one of the
things that we're seeing is like okay
you know I get excited and I'm like oh
look it's like it's live you can
actually use it now it's great um
everybody should do this like and some
people are like wait no though like
because I mean like Amir like he's
talking about super serious things where
people are like dying and whatever and
it's
like okay yeah maybe like my little NPC
Protocols are not for that case and like
the question then is like okay who are
your adversaries and how much power do
they have and so like I said to you
before that we are running these coars
on the network which is established
between oo um psse and and uh cursive so
in a sense you're Outsourcing your work
to us and you're Outsourcing your data
to us so in a sense you trust us you
trust us not to collude because if we
all come together we can reconstruct
your secrets and so one question that
you might ask if you're starting to
think about these things is like how
many people need to actually collude is
it like all of them is it just one of
them as long as one of them is honest is
it okay and so there are different
models and different trade-offs that you
can make and different levels of
efficiency and things like that so
another one is then yeah like different
Notions of security so like okay if if
somebody can tamper with your system how
much can they do and so I think the most
common model is normal so maybe there's
some information leakage maybe you like
learn some stuff by uh observing the
network but they still follow the
protocol and then there's kind of the
worst case situation where you kind of
try to protect against militia security
and protecting against this means that
are like adversaries that can break
Security in this sense mean that they
can control and manipulate and
arbitrarily inject messages like they
can just completely destroy your system
so like if you are running an election
let's say in an NPC and you have a
malicious uh like if you um have a
malicious adversary they could you know
just change the results of your election
like you know you have nothing
so if you want to protect in this kind
of situation it's super hard and you're
not going to have much efficiency that's
for sure um so yeah what about
efficiency I think um I mentioned a few
things the Whirl coin example the
cursive example I think these are two
nice examples of things that are running
in production which I think are the
kinds of things I would hope the sort of
Cipher punk people would care about more
than the theoretical people who care
about the math um and so in saying that
the difference between specialized
protocols and like general purpose
computation um is quite different so
like you can do like highly highly
optimized stuff um as in the case of
worldcoin and they are doing un
uniqueness checks you do about 40
billion checks per second and okay that
translates to okay you have two eyes and
you know you have many readings and your
iris is pretty like uh data Rich um yeah
it's data Rich so it's a lot and and
this translates to I think about 15
people uniqueness checks per second and
so these curse of coars that we're
generating downstairs not downstairs but
in the network um are about 12 seconds
each but 11.9 like like the vast
majority of that is the witness
extension so this is like the actual NPC
part rather than just the proof
generation part so proof generation is
very fast but witness extension is not
too bad so this is where it's at now and
so uh that's it for me if you have any
questions I will will be glad to take
them thanks very
much thanks so much for your
presentation Ash um we've got a couple
of questions uh here on the docket um
but before we ask those questions I
meant to actually mention one fun fact
about Ash here is that uh she actually
was an MC just yesterday so she knows
how it feels I know I know how you're
feeling right now after like five hours
I was like I don't remember anyone's
name I don't know what even this topic
where are we this was a great one though
even though it was technical um but the
first question here is when koir koir is
now there like now now you can use it so
um yeah if you go to the TSO GitHub you
can go and find uh Kono and play with
that awesome and then what's the
difference between ZK with MPC versus
FHA
computation
well um I did I I resisted saying things
about FHA so FHA is great and like is a
super ultimate goal for privacy because
even if like there is collusion in the
network stuff is still encrypted and you
cannot like uh it's like a better level
of privacy but it's hyper inefficient
well like it's uh it's super inefficient
so I think
um we saw at CK Summit recently if you
wanted to generate zero knowledge proofs
in an environment it
was like like order of minutes rather
than you know tens per second so it's uh
just low and I think is often
considered a specific example of MPC MPC
is super General so everything can be
cast essentially as NPC but uh yeah f is
just slower thanks and uh the next
question is about NPC wallets is it the
future and what are your thoughts on NPC
wallets generally I also didn't mention
NPC wallets and I was going to make a
comment about that so for me I mean when
I mean MPC I mean like general purpose
MPC like General purpose computation for
me MPC wallets are kind of threshold
signatures and things like this so it's
a little bit of a special case and like
a kind of a sub um sub computation it's
just one type it's just generating
signatures essentially so it's kind of a
small part of NPC um super efficient I
quite like them personally we don't work
on any of that stuff but um I I like it
yeah they're cool cool um and there are
a couple of questions that are more
about the yeah opinion on things but
first one is how do Co snarks work how
do coars very briefly in like 20 seconds
if you know how ZK works you take the ZK
and you split it over uh three people
like essentially like what is needed to
compute a zero knowledge proof is
essentially linear so you just do it
three times and you communicate and you
get one proof in in a
nutshell okay and what do you think of
te or
T and what is te did this question come
from someone who knows me or someone who
doesn't know me that that makes all the
difference so te is a trusted execution
environment and it's like a super Hot
Topic at the moment um I think they're
wonderful and um no so the thing is with
tees they're great and it's a it's a
Super Hot Topic at the moment they're
quite easily breakable so I have
sometimes been critical of them in the
past which is why sometime I'm wondering
if this is someone who knows me but uh I
think it's good like so with the coars
we talked about um the collusion problem
and you know I said that in this network
let's say that we are running now you
trust the three of us not to uh collude
and so tees are one defense against this
if you sort of run the MPC in a te
across you know the nodes and the
network um it's one nice defense and
also
like I as I said te can sometimes be a
bit weak um if you use three of them
from different uh providers than like
spread them around the world it's also a
lot better so ultimately I think um yeah
we're going to see that happening very
soon cool thank you and um I think we
have time for one last question how does
the MPC Network receive private data is
it in the encrypted format for snark
generation
yes simple um I mean it's encrypted like
across the internet but overall like
before that even from your phone it's
sent it's split into secret shares which
is seen as can be cast as a form of
encryption so essentially you encrypt it
on your phone or your local device and
then you send it to the service cool
okay I think we got one time for one
more can we remove initial trust set of
MPC what's the initial trust set I
wonder um so like if you talk about like
the collusion issue um I think that's
what they're implying is the collusion
can you remove it I mean everybody's not
everybody's working on it but like this
is the big problem in MPC at the moment
um can you remove move
it never fully I'd say um but uh yeah we
try I mean one there are different
options like running things in tees you
can start thinking about economic
incentives for people not to collude um
but yeah this is a is a problem cool
well thank you so much Ash and uh thank
you you're a better MC than me you did a
very good job thank you but you can find
Ash outside answer for any other
questions
s
[Music]
in
I don't think hopefully not doing a work
myself
[Music]
hey guys we are back no longer with 30
minute talks finally now we have a nice
short lightning talk that Sasha who's a
researcher here who's going to be giving
all about the philosophy of ethereum
which I'm pretty excited about so uh
welcome to the stage Sasha who fun fact
by today today is uh that she likes
unicorns thank you
[Music]
well hello everyone I'm Sasha and I'm
here to talk about ethereum not just as
a technology but as a
philosophy uh during this few minutes
we'll Journey Through The History of
Thought exploring how ancient and modern
ideas align with what ethereum brings to
our world today but before we di in a
quick disclaimer as philosophical
Concepts I'll touch upon have been
simplified and uh the majority of
philosophers will discuss never foro
blockchain and linking their insights to
etherum is quite an interpretive
intellectual
exercise well we're all aware of how
ethereum is Transforming Our economy
society and governance but its impact
goes even deeper as ethereum also
challenges us to think about core
philosophical Dimensions from the nature
of reality ity and Truth to ethics and
art ethereum core extends Beyond
decentralization programmability and
automation it Embraces resilience open
collaboration it values um inclusivity
and sovereignty rooted in a vision of
social economic freedom ethereum aspires
to create a borderless network where
Innovation thrives and hierarchies
dissolve this fundamental principles
resonate deeply with Timeless ideas
explored by philosophers across the
history thus philosophical Concepts like
decentralization and consensus appeared
in Greek city state or po Plato
envisions them in his works also
trustless or parisia was another cor
idea as well as privacy with Aristotle's
distinction between public polist and
private OAS
spheres furthermore blockchain's
mutability mirrors
determinism and the medieval pursuit of
Eternal truth and decentralization fodal
hierarchies the Renaissance introduces a
concept of security an idea that became
Central to ethereum's framework and um
for example jordano Bruno's idea about
universe as a living organism May match
the ethereum's infinite Garden
metaphor early modern philosophy is
paining the Enlightenment and Beyond
emphasizes reason individual freedom and
skepticism toward traditional Authority
thinkers like Jean jaac rouso or John Lo
championed personal Liberty autonomy and
property rights also this era focuses on
industrialization finding its modern
reflection in smart
contracts as as we progressed through
history anarchism seen in thei
celebrates community-driven intermediary
free
systems Bron's idea of industrial
democracy and kotkin's mutual Aid
resonate here as does libertarian
socialism through Dows that balance
egalitarian PTP interactions with social
justice initiatives like
Ubi and pragmatist thinkers like J John
scores
cooperation uh and practical Solutions
um action based
outcomes contemporary philosophy brings
fresh New
Perspectives thus phenomenology which
emphasizes individual Freedom aligns
with ethereum focus on personalized
interactions then emphasizing Freedom
choice and responsibility existentialism
matches with ethereum which enables
autonomous decisions and
accountability analytic philosophy in
vigen Stein's call for clarity EOS in
ethereum's language for share for secure
exchanges and of course postmodernism
which critics fix hierarchies resonates
with ethereum
ethos worth noting that today's thinkers
bring diverse perspectives on blockchain
some like zek critique it while others
acknowledge its transformative
potential uh now I want to briefly talk
about eum's philosophy philosophical DNA
as I said um I believe and I think many
of us here believe that ethereum
embodies a
convergence of multiple philosophical
movements uh which form its
philosophical DNA
blending in many fascinating ways
starting from Punk and cyer punk which
sound similar but each hold unique
vision of freedom and autonomy while
cyber Punk imagines Rebellion against
sensorization Cypher Punk provides the
cryp cryptographic tools for
privacy other influences are cyber
utopianism which this technology as a
pass to democracy it views ethereum as a
tool for open accessible systems that
Empower individuals worldwide
and the crypto anarchism which
emphasizes privacy and
autonomy resisting State Control through
cryptography U then there is theorem
also draws on techn libertarianism and
post-humanism in essence uh the first
highlights ethereum's role in personal
autonomy while the second envisions is
as a transformative medium reshaping
identity and
Community next are objectoriented
antology and defensive
accelerationism objectoriented ontology
it's a part of a popular speculative
realism movement it views all entities
human and non-human as equally
significant in this perspective every
block smart contract and cod line on
ethereum has its own agency acting
within a flat network of
relationships and defensive
accelerationism as many of you know
support by vitalic butterin it calls for
responsible Tech progress balancing
Innovation with ethical
responsibility lastly solar Punk and
lunar Punk they present ethereum's dual
potential a sustainable open Future
alongside robust privacy Focus
protections um also the further frame
ethereum as philosophy I want to shortly
add several perspectives in terms of
metaphysics physics ethereum can be seen
as a pluriverse an ecosystem of diverse
interconnected realities where multiple
systems cultures and values coexist and
interact then epistemologically ethereum
offers trustless knowledge a paradigm
where truth is verified
collectively then in terms of Ethics
etherum introduces
technotics in terms of
theology um one of the goals of the is a
tool for digital
Liberation uh mainly ethereum isn't just
a technology it's a living philosophy an
experiment in rethinking trust and
freedom is invite us to ask what happens
when the code carries our
values and when autonomy privacy and
decentralization become foundational
together we're shaping a new
philosophical
Paradigm thank you
thank you and we'll start in two minutes
thank you so much Sasha that was great I
don't think we have time for Q&A so
thank you so much um and uh we've got
about two minutes until our next speaker
starts uh talking about uh building
privacy uh protocols on ethereum so uh
we'll come back in two minutes
[Music]
you
I'm excited to announce uh the next
presentation is going to be all about
smart contract privacy with Paul Brody
here um and fun fact about PRL Brody
first off he's with ey and also with the
Enterprise um ethereum Association and
he's very very passionate surprisingly
enough about public blockchains and has
no relation to the next speaker so here
he is hello
[Music]
everybody so uh if you follow me on
Twitter you know I promised a joyful and
uplifting presentation I lied uh this is
going to be pretty pragmatic and
realistic I'm going to tell you about
how to use ethereum and specifically
smart contracts to do something useful
and interesting with privacy uh so
couple key topics for today number one
let's press the magic
button we're not we're having technical
diffic difficult so first item I want to
talk about is the business case for
privacy and as soon as the clicker works
we will advance to the next slide which
it's not
doing it's not doing that so anyway I'm
going to talk from a little bit of
memory so pretty much every business
agreement comes down to something very
simple I've got money you've got stuff
and I would like to exchange my money
for your stuff under the terms of a
business agreement and the challenge
with that is that for companies they
want that information to be private how
much money you have how much stuff you
have what you're buying where it's going
that's all like super secret sensitive
business information oh it's working now
so business case for privacy as I said
companies want to do very simple stuff
exchange money for stuff under under the
terms of an agreement with privacy
and blockchain is actually this
incredible piece of infrastructure for
doing this way more efficiently so we
can tokenize the money we can tokenize
the stuff and we can turn all the
business terms and conditions into a
programmable set of rules that can be
implemented very easily to make this
work however we need two kinds of
privacy number one we need privacy about
the transfer of assets and payments
right how much I'm paying you what
you're giving me where it's going that
stuff needs to be private but secondly
we also need privacy for the terms and
conditions of our agreement like it's
really important if I can read the
agreement between company a and Company
B and it says I'm going to buy 500
widgets at $10 a piece I mean I kind of
gave away all the information that you
need to know anyway so we need these two
kinds of privacy and in particular uh
pseudo privacy or mixers or things like
that aren't really good enough for
businesses because if a lot of companies
do lots and lots of recurring business
with each other and eventually if do
enough of these types of transactions
you're going to be traceable even in a
public mixer environment and most
business assets are not fungible tokens
money might be fungible but the things
that you're buying are often not
fungible and anything that's
non-fungible becomes instantly traceable
in a public environment so it's really
hard to design without leaking
information and that's some of the stuff
that we've really been working on now
before I talk to you about how I just
want to take a second and talk about
like what is the uh value proposition
like why is this worth doing and I want
to share with you a very specific
example which is around the use of smart
contract for business automation uh
about five years ago ey and Microsoft
worked together to replace the
procurement system for the Xbox video
game network with a set of smart
contracts and the idea here was to
replace uh an existing system which had
a traditional Erp system uh and it was
sort of semi-automated at the end of
each month month they would look at all
the transactions and they would manually
apply some of the rules that they had
implemented between Microsoft and their
3,000 odd gaming suppliers well it took
on average in the old system about 45
days to calculate how much they were
owed and go through all the individual
contracts and special rules when we turn
those into blockchain based smart
contracts the beauty of these kind of
smart contracts is they're basically
scripts right doesn't matter as long as
the rules that you and I have agreed
upon are logical and clear then I can
automate them and they can run properly
and the result was that we basically
took a process that used to take 45 days
and we brought it down to about five
minutes right that is a good Improvement
and we did it for about half the cost of
the existing system so the value
proposition of being able to take a
complex business agreement and turn it
into an automated smart contract is
incredibly large the problem that we had
at the time was we didn't know how to do
this under privacy on a public
blockchain right eventually where we
want to go to is his ability to put
together tokenization with smart
contracts and in a way that you can
create a complete business model that's
running on chain in this picture what we
have is you know a very typical supply
chain right raw materials they get
manufactured they get transported they
get put in a warehouse they get sold to
a customer and then they get supported
now every single item in a traditional
manufacturing supply chain we can
represent as a token some of the things
are fungible tokens most of them are
non-fungible tokens anything with a
serial number becomes a non-f funable
token right and so basically in this
picture stuff moves from left to right
and money moves from right to left and
the set of smart contracts governs this
movement of the process away and not
only can we run the business process for
about half the cost but we can also run
the supply chain much more efficiently
we think we can typically if we move
from traditional supply chain models to
a tokenized supply chain model with all
the rules of preventing double spend you
can actually cut maybe as much as 20% of
the inventory from your supply chain and
have the same service level so in short
this is worth crazy amounts of money now
let's talk about a specific use case
that we are implementing for clients and
rolling out worldwide and this is
renewable energy and I want to talk
about why renewable energy is such an
incredible use case and application and
how we we got there I want to start with
the road map for privacy that we are
working on at ey we've got two
applications that we're building I
talked about two types of privacy that
we want to do one is privacy of moving
stuff around and the other is privacy of
the terms and conditions of a business
agreement so for the privacy of
tokenization and moving things around we
have created a layer 2 ZK rollup called
Nightfall Nightfall allows you to move
around fungible and non-fungible tokens
uh it's an evm compatible layer to so it
actually can run on top of the main net
it can also run on top of say a layer
two as a layer three so Nightfall is for
moving stuff around Starlight is a
transpiler that basically takes a
solidity smart contract and turns it
into a set of zero knowledge circuit our
idea our concept is to get each one of
these pieces working independent ly and
then bring them together so that you can
have this full uh businesso business
kind of complex road map both of these
to be clear are although they are
largely developed by ey we have put them
into the public domain they are public
domain open source contribution to the
ethereum ecosystem there are no
proprietary gchas here there are no
surprise like you know uh special uh
terms and conditions in the open- source
license it is full public domain we have
relinquished all ownership to these
assets thank you
sir that is how much we love and believe
in the ethereum ecosystem and we have
been on this journey for a while by the
way I know uh we been getting a lot of
attention from uh the Noir uh program
that's launched this week um I tell you
that we started about the same time as
the folks at Aztec and we are across
most of our team is across town from
them in London uh and one of the things
that Delights me so so much is to come
to Devcon and see how much competition
is now in the Privacy space like I I
really believe that even if we lose a
competitive race with some of the other
Solutions we win but I'm I'm not yet
given up on losing um we have been on
this journey for a while even though the
the the numbers didn't sort of look out
correctly we started in
2017 and here we are in 2024 we're on
Nightfall version 4 Nightfall version 3
which is currently in production is a ZK
opt optimistic rollup ZK for privacy
optimism for finality Nightfall version
4 which we showed off earlier this year
and will be in production next year is a
ZK ZK rollup so one ZK for privacy and
one for uh instant
finality all right let's talk about
renewable energy and exactly how we
implemented this so the way that
renewable energy contracts work and the
reason why they're such a good candidate
for uh zero knowledge uh applications is
that they are kind of complicated and
this is a simpli ified version very
simply you got a power buy you got
somebody they got a factory they want
electricity they want a lot of
electricity they're going to buy it from
uh somebody but maybe they're a large
company they have a good social
responsibility plan they have committed
to become carbon neutral so what power
buyers do is they reach an agreement
with a renewable energy seller somebody
who's got solar facilities battery
facilities whatever it is it's renewable
and and fully green here's the
problem electrons are fungible right you
might want to have your locally produced
organic artisanal electrons but actually
the way it works is you have to take
what the power company is giving you and
so what happens is the power buyer
basically buys electricity from the
power company at whatever the market
price is in their environment the power
company in turn buys power from a whole
bunch of suppliers some of them are very
green some of them are not so green uh
the agreement exists between the
renewable seller and the renewable buyer
and what the smart contract does is it
basically keeps track of the market
price that the power buyer paid to the
electric company and the difference
between that and the agreed upon price
and then they settle up usually every
month or so if one party owes the other
and there's there's usually complex
terms and conditions like a commitment
to buy a certain minimum amount of power
in the Grid or a certain like maximum
price that they have to pay p and the
idea is that uh they are basically
providing the incentive and enough
financial value to the renewable
provider to structure long-term
investment and these renewable energy
contracts are incredibly important
because a lot of these solar facilities
wind facilities they could not be built
without the advanced commitment of
buyers like these kinds of factories or
other companies that are committed to be
carbon neutral these Advanced
commitments that they make they're often
five or 10 years at a certain price
price for a certain number of megawatts
these are incredibly important to
guaranteeing the revenue that provides
the investment funding to build these
kinds of facilities right so that's what
the structure is so a little bit like
you know video game contracts with
thresholds and minimums and rebates
renewable energy contracts can be quite
complex to build this renewable energy
contract we went through a a multi-step
process which I want to explain we
started by just creating a solidity
smart contract without privacy that did
that followed the terms and conditions
that we wanted to implement and once we
had that working we created a modified
solidity application which we call a
solidity application and all we did was
Mark up the variables and the logic that
we want to be private so we have a
little guide on how to do this uh and
then we put that into the Starlight
transpiler and what that does is it
spits out a zero knowledge circuit a
whole application that you can run on
chain which we call a zap right for a
zero knowledge app uh and please don't
ask me who is in charge of our naming
but uh uh it's a there's a lot of Z's in
there uh and so um the idea here is to
keep it very simple and starlight itself
came out of a really important learning
experience we had so about three or four
years ago we tried to teach our research
team our PhD mathematicians tried to sit
down and teach our developers how to
write zero knowledge circuits using
tools like zres it was a spectacular
train wreck like it just did not work at
all our solidity developers were like
this is too difficult I don't like this
I don't want to do this and so we went
back to the drawing board and we said we
need to find a way to make this much
easier and much simpler and you just
should have to do some minor changes to
a solidity smart contract and that's how
we ended up with Starlight so Starlite
is really designed to be as easy as
possible it allows you to take a
solidity application that you know
already works and turn it into a zero
knowledge application um you still have
to think very carefully about how to
design it in such a way that you're not
going to leak really sensitive metadata
because if you're not careful you will
accidentally end up Le leaking metadata
um but the goal is to get to the point
where anybody can do applications um
it's as I said it's public domain and
open source you can go and try WR out
yourself there are currently about a 100
companies worldwide that are designing
and testing applications using Starlight
and in particular we've been working
very closely with the Central Bank of
Brazil we have about uh 60 or 70 banks
in Brazil that are testing out Starlight
based applications and we for the last
year we've been working really hard to
refine the uh Starlight application
development process and
tooling right now where we are is that
uh we are in a kind of a stateless
environment so the Starlight application
receives data it calculates the amounts
owed uh but it does not store anything
on chain it doesn't store any
commitments even offchain it's a
stateless component uh and transactions
are relatively
inexpensive um provided you deploy them
on a layer 2 Network the future path is
that we want to integrate Starlite with
onchain payment and with some level of
offchain State full storage of things
like the amount of electricity consumed
and the amount of money paid so that you
really have a proper continuous record
of the entire set of business
transactions uh but that's that's the
goal as I said we we're following a kind
of crawl walk run strategy and the goal
is to start and build things that are
very very pragmatic and useful to
business users uh rather than try to
like bite off the whole thing at once so
we have fun fundamentally a bit of a
different approach than say Aztec or
some of the others who are I think have
a very ambitious and kind of complete
approach uh we welcome participation our
content it's public domain it's open
source uh all of our tools are open and
available and we publish them on the ey
blockchain site on GitHub so uh that's
um really important to us we have many
many contributors but underpinning all
of this is kind of a long-term
commitment from Ewan to invest in
privacy because we believe it is the one
thing that enterprises need in order to
get fully engaged with onchain business
and to give up this fixation that a lot
of people have with private
blockchains uh lastly we are here we
have an impact Booth our research team
is here uh both and and and quite a few
members of our engineering team as well
we would love to talk to you about how
to help you make privacy enabled
applications that are regulatory comp
client right they will not lend you know
end you up in jail I feel like you know
I myself would not do very well in
prison um so I don't want to go there um
and then lastly uh I want to I'm ready
to take a couple uh uh questions but I
also want to share with you my little QR
code it is it will take you to a website
uh that will give you what we call a
proof of Paul NF uh which is minted on
the polygon uh proof of stake blockchain
and we made a special one just for
Devcon on uh
so am I on time have we got enough time
for a couple minutes of questions yeah
we've got some time we've got about six
seven minutes perfect so we've actually
got a lot of questions but feel free to
ask some more on here so it looks like
the top question here is why did you
build Nightfall rather than contribute
to other open source ZK rollups well at
the time that we got started there
weren't any other open source ZK rollups
I mean this was 7 years ago and by the
way almost all the the ZK rollups that
are out there are ZK for scaling not ZK
for privacy and in fact one of my
frustrations was you know seven eight
years ago when we got started down this
path everyone's like hey we got to fix
the scaling problem for ethereum and
while I agree with that and I'm really
pleased with the progress that ethereum
has made on scaling I think it's
incredible uh at the end of the day for
business users there's no scaling the
scaling problem is not a problem until
you solve the Privacy problem without
privacy no business user is going to
touch ethereum and I want every business
agreement in the future to be on
ethereum awesome well how do you
tokenize real world assets without them
being centralized that's a great
question um so I think
uh let's see
here I guess the quick answer is I think
for individual companies they are those
those assets are going to be if if
you're tokenizing your own asset it is
going to be to a certain degree
centralized in your company and this is
kind of an issue that we've talked about
with a lot with other people is in
certain circumstances there are some
things where only one participant really
knows the status of that asset the only
company that knows where your UPS or
FedEx package is is UPS or FedEx right
and so you have to accept that and one
thing that is a really cool thing is
there's a process's a well accepted
business process from the world of trafi
it's called a um a sock audit right
which is is a systems and organizations
control and what it is is you have an
independent organization come in and
assess your reporting mechanism and so
uh in the cases where you can't have
proper decentralization you should have
external auditing and testing to make it
more
reliable and I think we have time for
one more question can you talk about the
Brazilian cbdc and how the experience is
of using Starlight on Drex and for my
sake can you explain what Drex is yes so
Brazil has um a really they've had some
really cool thoughts about their cbdc so
as many of you may know cbdcs are really
struggling with acceptance and and
success because they they don't offer a
lot of value the Brazilian Central Bank
has taken note of that and they've
really thought a couple of steps ahead
and they've said you know what if we
want our cbdd cbdc to be successful we
really uh should consider making it
programmable and in an evm environment
which I think is fantastic now I have
urged them to go one step further and
just plug their their whole cbdc into
public ethereum I'm not sure they're
ready for that yet but what is exciting
about this is that um uh in this
environment Brazil has a clear banking
secrecy laws and so if I want to trade
with you if I want to do a transaction
with you the Brazilian government
doesn't just say privacy is nice the
Brazilian government says You must
respect the privacy of your users you
must build privacy enabled applications
and so they have been testing a number
of different privacy Solutions
what I think is really exciting about
Starlight compared to some of the other
ones is that it is our our whole goal in
building Starlight Nightfall is to be
100% compatible with an evm environment
where you use native ethereum tokens
like erc20 is and 721s you preserve all
of the true native ethereum
functionality around like the prevention
of double spend the proper management of
assets our goal is not to create
something new it's to to make these
things fully compatible and transparent
in a very straightforward way so we we
want to make it simple and I think
that's a big part of the value
proposition we'll see how Drex evolves
right but I think this idea of like
fully programmable privacy respecting
kind of cbdc evm is quite exciting thank
you and I actually lied you have about
three minutes left for this Q&A so
fantastic it looks like we've got a
couple other questions what made you
choose ZK over Oasis Sapphire or the
secret Network I assume that's because
you guys started back in 2017 it's
partly because we started back in 2017
but it's also because again we we want
uh we want True full native privacy and
one of the things that's also really
important to us is that we don't want
any kind of um offchain systems that are
required we don't want any uh special uh
security like uh Hardware security
modules or proprietary tools our goal is
to have a fully open source ethereum
native privacy application with no uh
kind of builtin tax or license or or you
know system so that was our goal is is
to be completely open and another
question it's more applicable but like
I'm curious all the smart contracts that
you've developed for um Nightfall and
Starlite are they compatible with con
like just any smart contract and being
converted into ZK circuits are there any
changes required to satisfy those
constraints so there are some changes
and and the the basically the the the
Starlight kind of user guide explains
how to make those changes you really do
have to be careful you know if you
design what you what you end up with is
it like a black box and so if you're not
careful you know you if I have a black
box and I put and I have only two
parties in it and I put in $10 and you
put in two widgets doesn't matter how
fancy the logic is in there the from an
external point of view you know that
your contract is basically saying the
pricing is $5 a widget right you you've
leaked all the meaningful information so
you have to really carefully design your
application so that it is um uh it it is
uh optimal for preserving privacy I
before I've got one minute left I want
to talk about this one around privacy uh
for governments uh and and how
Regulators VI this kind of thing and
here's I want to share with you kind of
the one really really important Insight
that we have learned in terms of working
effectively with Regulators it's really
important to help them understand
privacy and anonymity are not the same
thing so when we design nightall which
is our privacy Layer Two in order to use
it you need to have an Enterprise
identity certificate this doesn't mean
that your transactions are visible and
there are no back doors in the system
but externally governments and
Regulators can see who is transacting
they cannot see what you're doing they
cannot see with whom you are transacting
but they can see that you are
transacting they can the these
Enterprise ID certificates x. 59s can
only be issued to companies that can
pass basic backgrounds and sanctions
checks as well so I would not call it by
the way kyc but it is identity it is a
legally accepted form of business
identity in many countries including the
United States and uh if a regulator
comes to you you can tell them what
you're doing and very importantly you
can also prove to them that what you're
sharing with them is truthful so I think
we're done awesome thank you so much
great presentation
[Applause]
[Music]
is
oh for
[Music]
oh
for e
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys it is now the last session of
today's uh Devcon talks congratulations
you made it this far um we now are going
to have lovely Ann Brody come up here
and talk to us about infinite Gardens
and before an comes up I want to mention
one fun fact about her um she used to be
a drummer in a band before doing this so
here here
[Music]
in hello hello I know it's late and I
thank you for being here your presence
signifies your support for the social
sciences and I appreciate it um so thank
you it's such an honor to have the
opportunity to return to another Devcon
and get to uh present the research
findings that Dr Paul Dylan Enis and I
have been working on in the past year
from our latest paper which we've titled
tending the infinite Garden
organizational culture in the ethereum
ecosystem now unfortunately Paul who
maybe maybe some of you know him as
Polar punk from crypto X he couldn't be
here today he's off fulfilling his Noble
Professor duties but for anyone who
actually knows polar punk I suspect that
the real reason is he's probably too
busy playing hell diver and I have
onchain proof look at that tweet I mean
if you've seen his dedication to that
game you know it's like practically a
second job for him so you're stuck here
with me and we're going to talk about
the sexiest subject in crypto and we we
all know what that is
right it's governance governance is sexy
come on okay okay so I'm not a
governance Guru and I don't claim to be
able to provide you with the answers to
the most compelling governance questions
in ethereum but what this talk is
intended for is to provide you with a
perspective for thinking about
governance in the context of
ethereum now before delving into our
publication let me briefly introduce who
we are we belong to a rare breed we are
the social scientists that have chosen
to Grapple with the intricacies of the
social layer of this weird and wonderful
ecosystem and we both published one of
the earliest academic papers on the
culture of ethereum and then we decided
to join forces and this is the result
and you're going to get to hear about it
now Dr Paul Dylan Enis is a professor at
University College Dublin in Ireland his
research focuses on ethereum culture
with an emphasis on the social layer he
is the author of absolute Essentials of
ethereum I highly recommend buying the
book I myself am a doctoral candidate at
Mill University in Montreal Canada my
background is in anthropology Science
and Technology studies and communication
studies and my research interests are
based on the culture of open- source
movements hackers activism Dows
governance and crypto ideologies
okay so to begin I will give you a brief
synopsis on what the paper is about and
present the core argument before
actually getting into the rest of the
content so we focus on the role that
culture plays in shaping ethereum's
governance by exploring what we refer to
as social imaginaries of ethereum core
developers now I'll explain what social
imaginaries are in a moment but in
Essence we argue that in the absence of
centralized hierarchy such as with the
case of ethereum these social
imaginaries step in to define the
boundaries of legitimacy in decision
making within ethereum's protocol
governance okay so social imaginaries
what are they social imaginaries is this
theoretical framework that STDs Science
and Technology Scholars like to use now
without getting too philosophical here
as much as I love philosophy uh there is
an element of studying subjectivity and
people's relationship to technology but
to put it more simply it's really just
trying to understand the collectively
held
beliefs um norms and attitudes about a
technology deriving its theoretical
understanding from thinkers like Charles
Taylor and jasenof and Kim so the way
Charles Taylor describes it is quote the
ways people imagine their social
existence how they fit together with
others how things go on between them and
their fellows whereas jasenof and Kim
they extend on this definition to
Encompass more publicly formed visions
of desirable technological Futures now
why should we even study social
imaginaries well studying social
imaginaries is crucial I think because
it allows us to uncover the dominant
ideologies unquestion assumptions that
shape our understanding of technology so
for instance there is a widespread
belief that technology is inherently
neutral or that economic efficiency
should always be uh prioritized during
the design process so studying social
imaginaries equips us to Envision
alternative technological Futures and
Pathways and it Empower empowers us to
rethink existing directions and avoid
perpetuating hegemonic structures or
political agendas emed embedded in
technological choices and this in this
way we can build more robust tools that
serve the needs of various groups of
people now as I mentioned blockchain
Scholars really love studying social
imaginaries and there's already been
some studies done on blockchain
community so Lana Schwarz helped
popularize the use of social imaginaries
in the context of blockchain communities
um so according to Schwarz who first
started studying Bitcoin she argued that
Bitcoin represents an effort to
collaboratively build a monetary system
that she refers to as infrastructural
mutualism and that is an imaginary in
itself and this concept Blends the
ideals of Open Source collaboration with
cyberpunk culture which strongly
emphasizes online autonom and privacy
however Schwarz also points out to
another more individual aspect of
Bitcoin culture which is what she calls
digital metalism and this reflects the
libertarian values that are held by many
bitcoiners now there is also the world
computer imaginary as proposed by Yos
trui of course I did not coin the term
it's from Gavin woods and the world
computer imaginary is what distinguishes
it from Bitcoin and is therefore quite
Central to how ethereums view themselves
so instead of a money system like its
predecessors um Bitcoin ethereum is
basically read by its Community as a
neutral platform a shared with computer
that people can build daps on and
experiment in these more expressive and
creative ways okay there's also the
hacker engineer imaginary by J ja claraa
brai and that that one has more of an
emphasis on the hacker culture that
embeds the construction of artifacts so
yes blockchain does have a neoliberal
bent to it but then this imaginary
reminds us that in fact there is also a
hacker tradition that is part of a
broader historical lineage which often
gets forgotten but is very much relevant
to how these systems are conceived and
how they get
constructed okay and the productive
money imaginary is basically when and in
Bitcoin you
have um the sole focus of the currency
is its existential Focus but in ethereum
it has more of a prod productive
function which is for staking or to pay
for transaction fees okay and then today
we propose a new imaginary which we
refer to as the infinite Garden which
refers to ethereum's continuous
Evolution alluding to an eventual
endgame or state of
alific now I'm going to talk about the
research approach and how we did
it so we interviewed key figures from
ethereum's core Development Group and
what is interesting about ethereum core
devs is that they're part of a poorest
group theoretically anyone can become a
core Dev through consistent
contributions as there are no formal
barriers our interviews weren't limited
to developers we also spoke spoke with
researchers and coordinators within the
ecosystem and here are some of the
people that we interviewed including
vitalic himself Danny Puja Tim Alex Ben
and Trent um so our interviews were
semi-structured meaning that we had a
set of open-ended questions that allowed
for deeper exploration of topics as they
unfolded we then analyzed the discourse
using something we call grounded Theory
a method where you start with raw data
gathered from the field and then
gradually built theoretical insights by
identifying patterns and themes in the
discourse we began collecting data in
February 2023 coinciding with the
ethereum all core Dev calls particularly
the time of the chappella upgrade our
Focus was on the interpersonal Dynamics
within the core Dev group and we wanted
to understand how decisions were being
legitimized in this sort of
decentralized environment and through
this process we aimed to identify the
cultural constructs that shape
ethereum's decision-making
process now I don't have time to fully
dive into how ethereum's governance
works but here's a quick overview of the
key stakeholders involved we have the
core devs the full notes the stakers the
media the D Builders and the end users
now this structure forms what we call a
polycentric governance system
essentially it means that multiple
overlapping decision-making centers
operate autonomously but interact with
each other through cooperation
competition and conflict resolution no
single entity holds control and
governance happens through coordination
among these decentralized bodies in
ethereum this polycentric governance is
distributed across these various
stakeholder groups with no Central
Authority decision- making is spread out
and different actors must work together
to manage governance and address
conflict and by the way for a really
Stellar description on ethereum's
governance and all the details I really
recommend checking out the work of
Kristen
Kim okay so now let's talk about the key
themes that emerged in the
discourse so the first one was cyberpunk
values for anyone who doesn't know the
cyberpunk movement began in the 1980s
emerging from online hacker culture as a
protest Against The Growing Power of the
state to monitor its citizens through
digital networks they are activists who
advocate for the widespread use of
strong cryptography as a root to
nonviolent direct action and political
change some of the core values that
Define cyberpunks include
decentralization permissionless
censorship resistance and credible
neutrality our research showed that
these values are very much alive Within
ethereum's development culture and
here's a quote from Ben Edington
confirming this he says we are for
decentralization we are against
political capture and we are for
credible neutrality and making ethereum
robust against capture in all its
aspects now it's no surprise that
ethereum devs exhibit cyberpunk values
uh but what stood out in our findings is
how many of the interviews perceive
themselves as part of this broader
lineage
which directly traces back to bitcoin's
cyberpunk inspired ethos and this
concept of infrastructural mutualism
which I mentioned earlier which embodies
open source collaboration and
decentralization and it resonates deeply
with ethereum's core developers
today another key theme that emerged
during our research was conflict
resolution specifically how core devs
managed differing perspective Ives
within their group and from The Wider
ethereum Community our interviews took
place around the time of a major
ethereum upgrade known as chappella
which went live on April 2023 and this
upgrade allowed participants in ethereum
staking mechanism to withdraw the East
they had locked up during the transition
from mining to staking which was a huge
milestone for the ecosystem now many of
the developers we spoke with emphasized
the clarity of the decision-making
process reflecting ethereum's
collaborative governance approach
despite some setbacks back and forth
setbacks um on the technical design the
considerations were relatively
straightforward as Alex Stokes put it
the process was quote pretty streamlined
and Danny Ryan reinforced that decisions
were largely based on rough
consensus um which means complete
agreement is not required but a general
alignment is
ideal and here we have have a quote from
vitalic himself stating sometimes there
are disputes and people generally try to
you know keep talking until some kind of
a fairly reasonable solution can be
decided on I feel like it just almost
always ends up resolved in some sort of
way because it bubbles over before it
kind of bubbles over into some really
serious horrible conflict okay so this
kind of suggests that overall ethereum's
decision-making culture has stabilized
over
time also Ben eding has highlighted how
decisions are generally made through
discussions where descending opinions
are welcomed and heard in cases of
disagreement the direction is determined
by the overall sentiment of the all core
devs meetings this speaks to a strong
pragmatic ethos that is committed to
engineering Excellence but one that is
also fundamentally anchored in a mutual
trust among the cor devs as well as the
wider confidence within the ethereum
ecosystem in their technical proficiency
it is within this context that the
hacker engineer imaginary is most
vividly realized this ethos not only
prioritizes practical Solutions but also
embodies a deep faith in the specialized
expertise of those tasks tasked with
ethereum's continual
development and so one of the key
research questions we had was to
understand the extent to which Market
pressures influence the decision-making
process of course devs and what we found
was that after ethereum's transition uh
from staking to staking in September
20122 developers did not initially
prioritize enabling withdrawals of
staked eth however other participants
within ethereum's polycentric ecosystem
notably stakers media and end users felt
that unlocking staked eth should be the
top priority in response the core devs
adjusted their focus deprioritizing ing
other upgrades and shifting their effort
to enable withdrawals through the
chappella upgrade because they wanted to
deliver that promise and Alex Stokes for
example emphasized the imperative to
quote fulfill that commitment to
withdrawals while Danny Ryan pointed to
a sense of Duty towards the early
community members noting that many
stakers were individuals who had taken a
leap of faith during the transition to
staking we found that this commitment to
fulfilling promises to early
contributors was a significant factor in
prioritizing Chappelle's upgrade and
also here's another quote from vitalic
basically reaffirming this stating I
feel like there weren't really any
Social Challenges for chappella because
this is one of those examples of
something that's purely technical which
is just that people wanted to withdraw
it was promised that people are going to
withdraw and so the biggest challenge is
just implementing the
withdrawals we specifically found Ben
Edington remark important because he
emphasized how developers have a degree
of autonomy for Market pressures and do
not allow it to sway them from their
core Mission so as Ben Edington States
mercifully we've been free of commercial
pressures cevs are pretty resistant to
being told what to do and we will make
our own minds up we found that cevs
appear resistant to immediate Market
pressures but are flexible when it comes
to protocol Chang NS that are driven by
Fair economic considerations so in this
case community members who staked early
have contributed to the protocol and
therefore should be prioritized in the
right context but prioritizing a change
just to boost the market price would be
out of the question in this case it's
clearly the productive money imaginary
that appears where eth has an important
functional role in ethereum to pay
transaction fees to reward stakers but
core devs do not see their mission as
holding up an assets
price okay so now the new imaginary
we sense the presence of an unspoken
social imaginary guiding ethereum's
Evolution which refer to as the infinite
garden now this term was coined by a
amaguchi who's the executive director of
um the ethereum foundation and it
perfectly captures the essence of
ethereum's ethos in A's words quote
ethereum is a protocol for human
coordination coordination is a game but
not that one not one that is played to
win coordination is more like attending
a garden where one works only so that
the garden continues to thrive and this
analogy reflects a temporal Dimension to
the thinking of ethereum's core devs
where social imaginaries provide a way
of understanding our place in time and
space among others and within history so
beginning in 2020 ethereum's co-founder
vitalic ban introduced what is often
referred to as the etherum road map
however it's important to note that the
road map is not an official or for Al
document everyone must follow rather it
collates various long-term research
strands on ethereum's protocol
development so it suggests that there is
maintenance work to be done on ethereum
but that these seeds are being planted
for the long term where eventually you
know the garden will thrive on its own
and it will achieve a state of
alific so that's how we basically
presents the imaginary of the infinite
Garden so why do we think the social
imaginary is important we think it's
important because while there are clear
structures or processes and practices
such as eips all core Dev calls and
research forums we found this social
imaginary significant because Beyond EIP
1 and readme text ethereum lacks a
formal Constitution or governance
document so these social imaginaries
serve as the essential enabling
conditions for ethereum's governance to
function seamlessly in the ABS of formal
guidelines for offchain governance these
imaginaries play a vital role in
defining the boundaries of acceptable
actions and behaviors as a result core
devs lean heavily on these implicit
imaginaries to ensure cohesion within
the ethereum community and to push its
Collective goals forward they guide core
developers by fostering a shared sense
of foundational values long-term
alignment and Nuance understanding of
the ecosystem Collective expectations
without a formal hierarchy these social
imaginaries become crucial for
maintaining legitimacy and keeping
ethereum's development on track they
might be the only mechanism in fact that
core devs can truly rely on since making
unilateral decisions risks alienating
other
stakeholders so this infinite Garden
imaginary suggests a dynamic ever
evolving ecosystem where growth and
transformation are ongoing but a key
challenge we discovered was for core
devs in maintaining cyberpunk values as
the ecosystem grows as Ben Edington put
it how do we incorporate the interest of
these stakeholders into protocol
development without compromising our
cyberpunk ideals I don't think it will
be
easy similarly Alex Stokes reflected
you'll get less alignment as the
community grows these things have gotten
bigger and I expect they'll keep getting
bigger in some form of fashion as it
happens it's harder to maintain
alignment these concerns turns reflect
an underlying anxiety as ethereum grows
the original cyberpunk ethos could
become diluted for the cord devs this
signals success but it also invites the
possibility of New Visions of ethereum
that may diverge from the foundational
values they aimed to embed into the
protocol so the term cyber Punk is
becoming endangered despite of this its
ethers burns brighter than
ever to remain relevant in a changing
world the cyberpunk ideology must evolve
Beyond its historical Origins embracing
radical inclusivity that acknowledges
the diverse ways that people contribute
to its ideals cyberpunks are not only
coders but also researchers educators
curators of digital spaces Community
organizers and writers and there are
organizations actively working to
preserve this Legacy through privacy
education and advocacy y so web 3
privacy now is a leading Think Tank they
are creating invaluable educational
resources while women in web3 privacy is
championing privacy specifically
tailored for women in the space this is
a crucial moment to safeguard ethereum's
future and preserve cyberpunk values in
a world where control and influence Loom
large your privacy is the foundation of
your freedom the key to resisting
coercion from dominant actors now more
than ever protecting your privacy is not
just a choice but a vital Act of
defiance that ensures your voice remains
your own and we invite you to get
involved support these efforts and
explore how you contribute to the future
of privacy together we can ensure that
the principle of the cyberpunk ethos not
only remains relevant but also evolves
alongside the infinite
garden thank you so much for your
attention I appreciate you being being
here I hope you got some value out of
this talk and this paper is currently in
publication but it will be public soon
if you want to continue the conversation
feel free to hit us up on cryptox we are
pretty active either myself or Paul and
thank you again enjoy the rest of your
Defcon
you thank you so much an that was a
fantastic presentation I know you guys
had a lot of questions in mircat so you
can find an after the words and talk
with her and ask any other questions and
thank you so much for sticking around it
is now the end of presentation so hope
you guys had a good day here watching
lots of different talks and uh hope to
see you all tomorrow
[Music]
m
e
[Music]
see
for
[Music]
for e
m